SAFETY WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING TURNING
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS TO
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
A MINUTE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICES
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PROCESS
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT COLD NUMBER IS.
877-692-8953 THAT'S. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE. AN ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX NINE
ZERO NINE. AGAIN ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN ZERO. FIVE SIX NINE ZERO
NINE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES FROM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE OR ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC. YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO. FOR SUPPORT
AND OR OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOUR LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE HER LINE NUMBER. YOU
WILL BE WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU'LL NOW BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTED DEVICE THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR YOU. OUR HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE HEARING
ALL BILLS ON OUR SCHEDULE TODAY
AFTER INITIAL WITNESSES A
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
LIMITING PUBLIC COMMENT TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICES ARE
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
FOR EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINING HEARING
PROCESSING CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
AND IT'S CLOSE AS THE SAME
ARMOR SAME MANNER AS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. TODAY WE HAVE TWENTY TWO
BILLS ON OUR AGENDA AB NINE
THREE ONE BY. FILOPODIA I HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR AND
WAS MADE IT TO YOUR BILL- SIX
ARE ON CONSENT THAT'S AB TWO
SIX TWO AB FIVE TO SEVEN AB
FIVE SEVEN NINE AB SIX HUNDRED.
EIGHTY SIX TWO FIVE IN AB TEN
FIFTY SEVEN. AND THERE IS A
BILL FOR VOTE ONLY A. B. SEVEN
SEVEN NINE BY SOMEONE MONTH
BROKER LOW TO A LACK OF QUORUM
WE WILL- MOVE AND THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE TIME WILL STOP SAID
A QUORUM BUT RIGHT NOW WE DO
NOT HAVE ONE STILL. WE'LL HEAR
OUR FIRST BILL AND THAT'S AB
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMAN FONG ARE
YOU PREPARED TO MAKE YOUR
TESTIMONY. BY MR. WHEN YOU'RE
READY. BUT THERE WAS A SHARE I
TO I AM PROUD TO PRESENT THREE
ALONGSIDE MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND CHAIR OF
TRANSPORTATION LAURA FRIEDMAN
HI FI FIRST LIKE TO OFFER THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF THE ACLU
AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS FOR
THE ROBUST DISCUSSIONS
ULTIMATELY LED TO THIS APPROACH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. HAS
BEEN A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR ROAD
SAFETY SAFETY AND HAS LED THE
CHARGE INTERESTING SIDESHOWS
AND STREET RACING WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATELY LED TO
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES FOR
PEDESTRIANS AND DRIVERS
STATEWIDE I AM HONORED TO LEND
MY TIMES ARE FOR HER TO PRESENT
TODAY. I WANT TO THANK A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG FOR
INVITING ME TO BE HERE AND
THANK YOU MR- THAT MISTER CHAIR
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL IN
YOUR ASSISTANCE AND THAT OF
YOUR STAFF. I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT THIS BILL TODAY TO
BRING OUR SIDE SHOWS IN
CALIFORNIA IN LINE WITH OUR-
TRAFFIC LAWS ABOUT SPEED
CONTESTS. SIDESHOWS REFORM OF
ORCHESTRATED SPEED EXHIBITION
THAT OCCURS. WHEN TWO OR MORE
VEHICLES WORKTOGETHER TO BLOCK
TRAFFIC. TO DO THE VEHICLE
STANDS TO DO SPEED CONTESTS- ON
OUR PUBLIC STREETS. PUTTING THE
PUBLIC A GREAT JEOPARDY. NOW WE
HAVE LAWS- DEALING WITH SPEED
CONTESTSWERE TWO CARS ARE
RACING SIDE TO SIDE. BUT WE
DON'T HAVE THE SAME LAWS IF
SOMEONE'S DOING IF WE HAVE
THREE OR FOUR VEHICLES DOING
DONUTS IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
INTERSECTION. DOING RACING ONE
BY ONE AND OTHER DANGEROUS AND
RECKLESS BEHAVIOR. SO THE
ATTEMPT OF THIS BILL IS TO
GIVE. THOSE JUST AS DANGEROUS-
CONTESTS THE SAME GRAVITY UNDER
THE LAW. AS STREET RACING. NOW
WE KNOW THAT IN LOS ANGELES
THIS IS A HUGE AND GROWING
PROBLEM. AS MOVIES ENGINE UP
THE IDEA OF THESE TYPES OF
CONTESTS WE HAVE SEEN DEADLY
RESULTS. WITH PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY IN OUR
DISADVANTAGED IN BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES BEARING THE
BRUNT OF THE DEATHS AND
INJURIES. BECAUSE OF THESE BE
CONTESTS. ARE THE MY DEATH IN
TWO THOUSAND ROAD BY 24% AS
LESS PEOPLE WERE DRIVING ON THE
ROAD WHICH IS THE SINGLE
GREATEST INCREASE YEAR INCREASE
IN NINETY SIX YEARS. CHP
RESPONDED TO OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALLS PER SPEED
CONTESTS AND MOTOR VEHICLE
EXHIBITIONS OF SPEED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. NEARLY THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED TIMES MORE THAN
THE YEAR BEFORE. THE CHP HAS
DETERMINED THAT SPEEDING IT
KILLED MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. AND BECAUSE
ALMOST SIXTY THOUSAND INJURIES.
SPEEDING IS RESPONSIBLE 431% OF
ALL TRAFFIC FATALITIES. IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND MOTOR VEHICLES
EXHIBITIONS OF SPEED LIKE SPEAK
CONTACTS ADDED EXTRA LAYER OF
OFFENSIVENESS. TO SPEEDING IT'S
NOT JUST GOING OVER THE SPEED
LIMIT BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU MAYBE
DIDN'T NOTICE EARLY TO WORK
IT'S DOING IT JUST TO SHOW OFF
FOR OTHER PEOPLE. THESE
DANGEROUS SIDE JOBS ARE PUTTING
PEOPLE AT RISK FOR THE PURPOSES
OF THE LEGAL ENTERTAINMENT AND
WE NEED THE DISCRETION. TO HIT
PEOPLE WHERE THEY REALLY CARE
ABOUT WHICH IS SUSPENDING THEIR
LICENSE FOR A SHORT TIME TO
BASICALLY SHOW THEM. THAT
DRIVING IS A PRIVILEGE NOT A
RIGHT AND THAT THEY HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO USE THAT CAR
AS A TRANSPORTATION VEHICLE NOT
AS A WEAPON. WITH THAT I WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE YOU CONTINUE
TESTIMONY I'M GONNA ASK COUNCIL
TO STALL FOR QUORUM. COME
THROUGH WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BRADFORD YOUR RECORD HERE
A CHOI BOGUE HERE CHAU BUG HERE
DRAWS SO KAMLAGER HERE I'M
LONGER HERE SKINNER. BURKE
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT NOW
YOU CAN CONTINUE YOUR
PRESENTATION I'M I WOULD JUST
LET THAT WELL I'LL JUST ADD
THAT WE RECENTLY TOOK
AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVED ALL OF
THE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I'M
WORKING WITH YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WHO HAD CONCERNS AND THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND WOULD. REQUEST
FULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU. IF YOU HAVE. A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT YEAH
I WAS HERE SERRA. KAMMLER
INITIAL. DESERVES TESTIFIED
TODAY. YES I HAVE SECOND THEIR
FAMILY WHO IS EXPERIENCE
FIRSTHAND THE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS OF. RACING ACTIVITY.
FROM MY DISTRICTS UP THERE. IT
UP. A GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS MY NAME
IS SERRA CAN LEARN I'M FROM
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN I
RECEIVED THE MOST TERRIFYING
INCONSEQUENTIAL PHONE CALL THAT
CHANGED MY FAMILY'S LIFE
FOREVER MY MOM WAS STRUCK BY A
DRIVER WHO LOST CONTROL OF
THEIR VEHICLE DURING AN ILLEGAL
STREET RACE THIS TERRIFYING
CALL QUICKLY TURNED DOWN THE
CITY MY MOM LOST ER LIFE
SHORTLY AFTER AT THE SCENE I
COULD HAVE NEVER PREPARED FOR
THE OVERWHELMING GRIEF THIS
PRECIOUS BROUGHT MY FAMILY. THE
CRASH THE MOST HORRIFYING I'LL
NEVER FORGET SEEING SO VIVIDLY
HOW MUCH DAMAGE THREE RACING
INSIDE SHOWS CAN CAUSE MY MOM'S
CAR WAS MANGLED THE FIRST
RESPONDERS HOW TO USE THE JAWS
OF LIFE TO CUT OPEN THE VEHICLE
TO REACH MY MOM MY MOM WAS THE
ONLY PERSON IN THE RECTA LOST
HER LIFE THAT DAY BUT THE
TRAGEDIES OF THE SENSELESS
CRASH COULD HAVE GONE SO MUCH
FURTHER NOT ONLY DID THE
VEHICLES RACING HAVE SEVERAL
PEOPLE IN THE CARS BUT MY MOM
WAS HIT ON A SUNDAY AFTERNOON
ON A MAIN STREET IN BIGGER
STILL RIGHT OUTSIDE OF A BUSY
MALL AND A CLOSE WALK TO A
POPULAR PARK AND CHURCH. PEOPLE
PARTICIPATING IN SIDESHOWS
ENTRY THING DO NOT THINK ABOUT
THE DEVASTATION THEIR ACTIONS
CAN BRING WHEN YOU PERFORM
STUNTS AT SUCH HIGH SPEEDS IT
BECOMES NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE. TO
STOP YOUR CAR WHEN YOU LOSE
CONTROL. DESPITE THE COUNTY
HEADLINE SCHERING'S. LIKE MINE
THE BAKERSFIELD POLICE
DEPARTMENT REPORTED OVER SIX
EXPEDITION OF SPEED. ENTRY
RATING LAST YEAR ALONE.
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE ARE
EXPERIENCING THE SAME LIVING
NIGHTMARE MY FAMILY FELL EVERY
SINGLE DAY. EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THE STREET CRASHES HAVE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS ON VICTIMS
FAMILIES AND EVERY SINGLE
STREET RACING CRASH IS
PREVENTABLE. AB THREE. PROVIDES
LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL TO PREVENT
THESE TRAGEDIES BEFORE THEY
HAPPEN. THANK YOU MR FONG FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB THREE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE HERE
IN THE ROOM TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE STAGE NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR SEAN RUN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU IN ADDITION
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM
WHICH IN TESTIFYING SUPPORT OF
AB THREE. LET'S GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM IN TWENTY FORTY I
NO ONE THERE. MODERATOR LET'S
GO NOW TO OUR PHONE LINES FOR.
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE. IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
I DO NOT SHOW ANYONE KEEPING UP
ON THE PHONE LINES AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVED
OPPOSITION I SEE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY LEAD WITNESS ON IN
OPPOSITION SO WILL COME TO THE
HEARING ROOM HERE IN FORTY TWO
OLD THREE IS THERE ANYONE.
DESIRING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE. SEEN
NINE GOING TO TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE. MODERATOR
CAN GO TO PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. THREE IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. EXPECT
ME TO HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP
PLEASE ALLOW US A FEW MOMENTS
TO GIVE PROVIDE LINE NUMBERS.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SEVEN THAT'S ONE EIGHT SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT'S A FAIR
MEMBERS- THE KIND OF BRANDED UP
ON BEHALF OF THE L. A. COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT I
APOLOGIZE I WAS. UNABLE TO GET
IN THE QUEUE ON THE PORT SIDE
BUT- WILL BE ABLE TO GET IN NOW
BILL JUST WONDER BREAD- L. A.
COUNTY SHERIFF'S SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
WHEN I WOULD A LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED NINETY ONE IT'S ONE
NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
AM RG RETIRED CHECK FROM CRUISE
STRATEGIES- ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT
SORRY I COULDN'T GET IN DURING
THE SUPPORT WITH THE WORKING
TITLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THIS. GROWING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO THAT'S
ONE FIVE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT AFTERNOON LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
WITH THE ACCEPTANCE OF THE
AMENDMENTS REQUESTED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SIX THAT'S ONE NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE NUMBERS
CAROLINE APOLOGY THEY WASN'T
ABLE TO GET IN THE QUEUE IN
TIME FOR THE SUPPORT I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. OF AB THREE I THINK
YOUR CALL CAN BE DONE ONLINE.
THANK YOU. WHAT A LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN THAT'S
TWO ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KATHY SURE FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION- WE ALSO ARGUE- CALLING
TO CONFIRM THAT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE ARE. MOVING OUR
OPPOSITION AND TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ALL OF HIS- WORK IN
ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS. THANK
YOU FOR THIS. WELL I NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED TWO ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT AND MY
APOLOGIES I WAS UNABLE TO GET
IN Q. FOUR DEAD SUPPORT
POSITION THANK YOU. ACCORDING.
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO ONE TWO TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HI GOOD AFTERNOON
ANDREA KOLLER ASSISTANT DA ON
BEHALF OF THE KERN COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
CALLING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
A BI THREE AND MY APOLOGIES AS
WELL I WAS UNABLE TO GET IN-
BEFORE. MODERATOR CAN WE JUST
WE'RE CUED UP ON EXACTLY HOW
MANY MORE WHEN THIS WE HAVEN'T
SUPPORT VERSUS OPPOSITION SO WE
CAN. I HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. I DO
NOT KNOW WHICH THEY ARE FOR BUT
WE'LL FIND OUT HERE MOMENTARILY
LANGUAGE TWO HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THAT'S TWO ONE FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT LOOKS
LIKE THEY REMOVED THEMSELVES
FROM THE QUEUE. WE HAVE NO MORE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT.
I WILL GIVE IT A SECOND JUST TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S NO STRAGGLERS.
PART I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE IS THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS SOONER
CAMARGO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- TO THE CHAIR I HAVE A
QUESTION I- YOU KNOW I
GENERALLY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
BILLS LIKE THIS- WILL I WILL I
LET ME REPHRASE THAT I THINK
FOLKS ARE ENGAGED IN THIS KIND
OF BEHAVIOR PROBABLY NOT
CHECKING THE PENAL CODE TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT EXACTLY THEY
SHOULD BE DOING WHEN THEY
DECIDE TO STREET RACE- SO I AM
WONDERING IF THERE IS. ANY DATA
ON- IF THIS KIND OF LEGISLATION
HAS BEEN PASSED AND ENACTED IN
OTHER STATES AND IF SO WHAT'S
BEEN ITS RATE OF AFFECTED
BUSINESS IN THOSE STATES
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
INTENT BEHIND THIS BILL IS TO
CURB THIS KIND OF ACTIVITY.
CONTRA APPRECIATE QUESTION UP.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA FOR-
REMOVING ARE SUSPENDING
SOMEONE'S LICENSE WHEN IT COMES
TO DO EYES OR TO ACTUALLY TO
STREET RACING SPECIFICALLY IT'S
BECAUSE AS- DETERRENCE RATE IS
ACTUALLY VERY SIGNIFICANT- I WE
ACTUALLY HAVE THE CHP HERE- FOR
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. AND
I'M SURE THEY'LL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ANY SPECIFIC DATA BUT-
THE REDUCTION OF- RECIDIVISM.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO- DO YOU
EYES ABOUT 65% AND THE
REDUCTION IN RECIDIVISM WHEN IT
COMES TO- STREET RACING THIS BE
CONTACTED SO IT'S ACTUALLY OVER
90% IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA AT
THE CBS BUT- CERTAINLY DIFFERS
THIS DISEASE BE IF THEY'RE
HERE. HAPPY TO LEND. ABOVE THEN
THE MY TIME. IF HAVE. I AM SURE
THAT THE SUPPORT BY JUNE KAMARG
VIA DE TO ADDRESS THAT WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR THAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF MY
COVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL- ALTHOUGH THE
DEPARTMENT DOES NOT HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL. HI
THIS IS V. IS AWARE THAT- THAT
SPOT EXHIBITION SPEED. DOES
PRESENT A UBIQUITOUS PROBLEM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH
RESPECT TO PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS- TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO
RECIDIVISM. I YES WE DO HAVE
DATA WITH RESPECT TO RECIDIVISM
RATES. TO FOR A SPEECH CONTEST
CURRENTLY. LAW DRIVER'S LICENSE
SUSPENSIONS ARE STATUTORILY
AUTHORIZED- FOR ANYBODY THAT
HAS BEEN CONVICTED OF A SPEED
CONTEST- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ALL THE COURT CASES
ADJUDICATED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA COURTS
BORDER FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
DRIVER LICENSE SUSPENSIONS.
AFTER SPEED CONTEST
CONVICTIONS. AND RECIDIVISM
RECIDIVISM RATE DROPPED A
NINETY NINE POINT THREE
PERCENT. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA COURTS
ORDER FOUR HUNDRED FORTY DEAL
SUSPENSIONS. AND THE RECIDIVISM
RATE DROP NINETY EIGHT POINT
EIGHT PERCENT. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA COURTS
ORDERED THREE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE DRIVER LICENSE SUSPENSIONS
AFTER CONVICTIONS. AND THE
RECIDIVISM RATE A RATE DROP
NINETY NINE POINT FOUR PERCENT.
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY CASES THAT
HAVE BEEN ADJUDICATED THUS FAR.
OF THE RECIDIVISM RATE DROPPED
1100% MEDIAN THAT ARE CURRENTLY
THERE ARE NO CONVICTED
OFFENDERS. THAT HAVE BEEN A RE
CONVICTED. FOR A SPEED CONTEST
VIOLATION. I THINK THE QUESTION
ALSO WAS IS THERE ANY STATES
THAT HAVE ENACTED LAWS
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
THIS- ST EXHIBITIONS AND-
OCCUPYING INTERSECTIONS AT THIS
BILL IS REALLY TRYING TO
ADDRESS. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER STATE DATA ARE READILY
AVAILABLE FOR THAT. OKAY THE
CONGRESS. YOU'RE RIGHT. SENATOR
I'M TROUBLED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
FOR THIS C. H. P.
REPRESENTATIVE- THROUGH THE
CHAIR. I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HIS
COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH THE
ACLU AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS
TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN VERY
COMMITTED TO- ADDRESSED THE- OR
HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
CONSIDER HOW THE LOSS CAN
AFFECT DISPROPORTIONATELY-
CERTAIN COMMIT. A COMMUNITIES
THAT THE CHP HAVE ANY
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA ON THE
INDIVIDUAL CITED FOR EXHIBITION
OF SPEED. YES MA'AM- SO THIS
ISSUE DOES PRACTICALLY TRACK.
DATA WITH RESPECT TO EXHIBITION
BE. INCLUDED IN THAT THAT DATA
TRACKING IS A DEMOGRAPHIC
BREAKDOWN OF ALL CG CITATIONS
AND ARRESTS. I'M SO OVER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS FOR A VIOLATION
OF EXHIBITION S. B. HISPANICS
LATINOS REPRESENTED FORTY SIX
POINT 4% OF ALL HIS FEET
ARRESTS AND CITATIONS. WHITES
REPRESENTED THIRTY EIGHT POINT
5% OF AUSSIES CARESSES
CITATIONS. ASIANS REPRESENTED
FOUR POINT 5% OF ALL SEIZE
PEREZ AND CITATIONS. OF BLACK
AND AFRICAN AMERICANS.
REPRESENTED FOUR POINT 4%
NATIVE A REP- POINT 4% OF ALL
ARRESTS AND CITATIONS. AND THE
REMAINING FIVE POINT 8%
REPRESENT- AND ETHNICITY OR
RACE THAT WAS QUOTED AS EITHER
OTHER OR UNKNOWN. OF THOSE
ARRESTS AND CITATIONS OVER 96%
MORE- WERE MALES. WHEN COMPARED
TO EITHER FEMALES TRANS GENDER
OR- GENDER NON CONFORMING. MANY
DISCUSSIONS NO ONE OF- SENATOR
ASSEMBLY MINIMUM FONG I
APPRECIATE ARE YOU WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE I TO HEAR
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO- THIS
BILL- AND I. AGREE THERE IS A
GROWING PROBLEM WITH
EXHIBITIONS- SPEED IN THE
THREAT THAT IT PUTS THE GENERAL
PUBLIC NOT ONLY DRIVING PUBLIC
A WALKING AS WELL AND I'VE SEEN
WHAT IT DOES AND- OCCUPYING
INTERSECTIONS FOR. SOMETIMES
HOURS AT A TIME- WITHOUT ANY
RESPONSE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT-
AND IT IS A GROWING PROBLEM
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BUT
YEAH I WOULD I TOO WAS
QUESTIONING- ANY. HISTORICAL
DATA OF HOW THIS IS WORKED IN
OTHER STATES FOR OTHER. AREAS
AND I KNOW IT'S PROBABLY NEW TO
FALL FOR ALL OF THIS BECAUSE
IT'S A GROWING PHENOMENON. OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS BUT IT'S
ONE THAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED BECAUSE IT'S TOTALLY
GOTTEN OUT OF HAND EVEN TO THE
POINT OF. JUST WHAT IT DOES TO
THE STREET HIS OWN TEARING UP
ASPHALT AND- LEAVING BEHIND ON
TO SCREECH MARKS ALL IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE STREET TO- I JUST
WANT TO KNOW- YOUR CURRENT
ADDRESS STOOD- I WILL SEE THREE
DID. BUT OUR- FULL FOLLOW AREA
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
ANYTHING OR CLOSE. BY THE
CERTAINLY THIS THAT THE RATE OF
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
CITATIONS HAVE HAVE HAVE RISEN-
CERTAINLY WELL AWARE OPENED AT
SEIZE PLEASE OPEN TO COLLECTING
THE DATA AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
BUT THAT WAS SOMETHING HAS TO
BE DONE- AS THE CHAIR
TRANSPORTATION INDICATED- THIS
IS A GROWING PROBLEM STATEWIDE
AS AS AS YOU SAID MISTER CAIR-
THE DATA THAT SHOWS. THE SAME
TYPES OF- WHO WOULD THAT WE
LOOK AT SUSPENSIONS OF LICENSES
FOR OTHER TYPES OF A SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES THAT THE REDUCTION
OF RECIDIVISM IS SIGNIFICANT-
SO- THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL
BRINGS THE PARITY- THE TWO
BEHAVIORS THAT ARE RELATED A
NUMBER OF TIMES IF YOU LOOK AT
THAT THOSE WHO PARTICIPATE. IN
SPEECH CONTESTS THEY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING IN SUCH AS SO
THIS BILL VERY NARROWLY DEFINES
WHAT A SIDE SHOW IS AND
APPLIES- THAT PARITY- SIMILAR
TO- ST CONTEST. A TO THAT
BEHAVIOR. I'M A BIG BIG GREAT
COURTROOM JUST OUR SYSTEM. IN
LIEU OF LICENSE SUSPENSION HAD
BEEN CONSIDERED HAVING AN
INDIVIDUAL- BEAR THE COST OF ST
REPAIRER ANY DAMAGES THAT WERE
DONE FROM SUCH ACTIVITIES. BUT
WELL MOST OF THE- THE PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION THAT ATTEMPTS AT
LEGISLATION HAVE BEEN
IMPOUNDMENTS OR- AND ENHANCED
FOUNDRIES HE FELT THAT THIS
WAS- SOMETHING THAT CREATED
PARITY BETWEEN THE TWO
BEHAVIORS- WE CERTAINLY ARE
OPEN TO THAT IDEA- MAYBE IN THE
FUTURE BUT NO THAT THAT HASN'T
BEEN SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
CONSIDERED IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. THANK YOU- WE
TALKED CLOSE DIED I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR DILIGENT WORK I
WANT TO THANK US HERE IN OUR
FAMILY FROM TRAVELING ALL THE
WAY DOWN FROM BIGGER STILL TO
SHARE HER STORY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A TO PASS.
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WERE
SEEKING A MEMBER- MOTION ON
THAT IS OUR MOTION. MOVED
THROUGH AND MOVED BY SENATOR
CHOI BALK. CANCEL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON AB THREE AB THREE
BRADFORD BY REDFORD I'D SHOW
BOTH. TURBO GUY DURAZO COM
LAGER HI AMAKER AYE SKINNER.
THAT'S THREE VOTES WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION COUNCIL NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE- FIVE ITEMS ON.
EURAMERICA. TO FOUR. SHE SAID I
FIVE ITEMS ON SIX ON ON CAN CAN
WE CALL THOSE CONCERNS A TWO
SIX TWO AB FIVE TO SEVEN AB
FIVE SEVEN NINE AB SIX HUNDRED
SB SIX TO FIVE AND A. B. TEN
FIFTY SEVEN. IS THERE A MOTION
IS THERE A MOTION ON CONSERVE
GALA IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
CALM WATER. CONSENT CALENDAR
BRADFORD ARE AFRAID I'D SHOW
VOGUE I PHOTO GUY DORADO COM
AUGER NINE MARGARET I SKINNER.
FINANCING VOTES TO BE A GET OUT
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN ON THE
CONCERNED CALLER WE ALSO HAVE
ONE BILL ONE ITEM JUST FOR VOTE
ONLY AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE IS OUR
MOTION ON EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
NINE. BIGELOW BILL. YES SOME OF
THE- REMOVED BY A SENATOR
TROUBLED. COUNCIL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE.
AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE BRADFORD
ROAD FOR DIETRO BOOK I HAVE A
BUG BITE- DORADO. KAMLAGER
SKINNER. WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN ON AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO AB
EIGHT NINE EIGHTY NINE FIVE
SENATOR JOHN I MISS SOME WOMEN
JONES SAWYER ON RECORD BODIES
CENTER THE- AND MY SENATOR
SUSAN RIGHT THIS PLEASE- THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS. I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY THANKING THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH INCLUDE
CLARIFICATION OF THE PRINT AND
RADIO MEDIA CAMPAIGN TO BRING
AWARENESS TO THE EDUCATION
DEGREE AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT
PROGRAM. I AM PROUD TO PRESENT%
AB EIGHTY NINE TO PEACE OFFICER
EDUCATION AND AGE CONDITIONS
PROCLAIMING ACT PART PIECE ACT.
THE PEACE AT FIRST INCREASES
THE MINIMUM AGE FROM EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF AGE TO TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF AGE ALIGNING WITH THE
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND LEGAL
AGE TO POSSESS A FIREARM IN THE
STATE. THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES
POST HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS FACULTY MEMBERS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEVELOP AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
INTO MODERN POLICING. THE NEWLY
DEVELOPED A WILL INCLUDE
COURSES IN PSYCHOLOGY
COMMUNICATIONS HISTORY ETHNIC
STUDIES AND THOSE IN CRITICAL
THINKING AND EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE. AND EARNING THIS
DEGREE INCOMING PEACE OFFICERS
WILL BE BETTER EQUIPPED IN
SKILLS NECESSARY FOR DE
ESCALATION WHILE ALSO
DEVELOPING A CRITICAL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE HISTORY OF
COMMUNITIES OF VARIOUS
BACKGROUNDS. WITH ONE OF THE
BEST TUITION COMMUNITY TUITION
FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEMS
IN THE NATION THIS MODERN
POLICING NAY WILL BECOME AN
ASSESSABLE OPTION TOWARDS A
CAREER IN POLICING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S MOST DIVERSE
HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
POPULATION. AFTER A DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION TO PROVIDE TIME
FOR THE DEGREE TO BE OFFERED
ALL CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
MUST BE TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE
THAT CAME EITHER TO NEWLY
CREATED DEGREE IN MODERN
POLICING. OUR PASTORS DEGREE IN
THE DISCIPLINE OF THEIR
CHOOSING THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS I HAVE HAD
IT ROBUST CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND EFFORT TO
CONCERNS REGARDING THE IMPACT
THIS BILL MAY HAVE. A
RECRUITMENT TO RECRUITMENT POOL
POOL ESPECIALLY OUR RECRUITS OF
COLOR IN RESPONSE THE PIECE
THAT ALSO REQUIRES POST TO
DEVELOP A FINANCIAL SUPPORT
PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS COMMITTED
TO THE NEW AGE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSION. AND A MEDIA
PROMOTION TO BRING AWARENESS TO
THOSE WITH ACCESS BARRIERS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION WHEN ELEVATED
EDUCATION ENTRY STANDARDS ARE
EXPECTED OF OUR EDUCATORS. AND
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT WE ALSO DEMAND THE
BEST OF OUR PEACE OFFICERS
IMPROVING. CONDITIONS FOR
EMPLOYMENT WILL STRENGTHEN CAN
MANY TRUST ALOFT. AND ENSURE
SAFETY ESPECIALLY CAN MEMBERS
OF. WHO DISPROPORTIONATELY
VICTIM TO EXCESSIVE FORCE AT
THE HANDS OF PEACE OFFICERS THE
PIECE THAT WILL PROFESSIONALISE
POLICING BY ENSURING A MORE
MATURE. AND BETTER EDUCATED
WORK FORCE AS WELL AS TRANSFORM
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
MARKING A TRANSITION IN
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES
BEHIND EXCESSIVE FORCE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WITH ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL R. ESTEBAN
NOON YES ON BEHALF OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION. COALITION
CO SPONSOR OF THE PEACE ACT AND
JENNIFER FELDMAN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. THEY WERE BOTH
TESTIFIED VIA REMOTE
TELECONFERENCING LINE. IT WILL
GIVE A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES A
TO MINUTE HAVE EACH TO MAKE
YOUR TESTIMONY SO MISSING
KNOWING US IF YOU'RE READY YOU
CAN BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY MISTER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU SIR KAREN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS THAT BY NOON AS I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF ADVOCATES AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION ALSO
KNOWN AS ARC. ARC MEMBERS KNOW
VERY WELL THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING PEACE OFFICERS
SPECIFICALLY THOSE THAT WORK
WITHIN CORRECTIONS. TO HAVE THE
MENTAL CAPACITY TO MAKE
OBJECTIVE DECISIONS IN HIGH
STRESS HIGH STAKES SITUATION.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO RECOGNIZING
HAVE POLICIES THAT REFLECT
BRAIN. THE PREFRONTAL. WHICH
GOVERNS EXECUTIVE FUNCTIONS OF
REASONING ADVANCED DOT AND
IMPULSE CONTROL IS NOT FULLY
DEVELOPED UNTIL THE MID TWENTY.
NINE SHOULD BE REFLECTED IN THE
POLICY THAT GUIDES OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. I MEAN
PROPER EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND.
OR IF FULLY DEVELOPED BRAIN
HELPS INDIVIDUALS IN POSITIONS
OF AUTHORITY DEVELOP A DEEPENED
UNDERSTANDING OF THE VARIOUS
FACTORS THAT PLAY INTO
CRIMINALITY SUCH AS TRAUMA.
THIS REDUCES THE RISK OF
UNLAWFUL OR IMPULSIVE USE OF
FORCE AND INCREASES THE
PROBABILITY OF REHABILITATION
FOR THOSE INCARCERATED. AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW ON THE INCARCERATED
I SPENT SIX YEARS IN PRISON FOR
THE TRAGIC ANIMATRONIC VERSION
THAT MADE MY USE. DURING MY
INCARCERATION I WORKED IN MY
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE DRIVING FORCE
BEHIND MY DECISION BEHIND MY
DECISION. IN DOING SO I THOUGHT
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE FROM MY
FAMILY PEERS AND EVEN
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. IN MY
EXPERIENCE IT WAS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS WHO
ACHIEVED A DEGREE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT TREATED ME AND
THOSE INCARCERATED AROUND. NEED
A HOPE AND COURAGE TO WORK TOO
MUCH PROBLEM. I ALSO FOUND
THOSE WITH NO HIGHER EDUCATION
OR MARKET TO SPEAK TO US YET
QUICK TO FOLLOW IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF OTHERS. WHO
REGULARLY DEMEANED AND
BELITTLED. WITH NO REGARD FOR
REHABILITATION OF SUPPORT.
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE
INDIVIDUALS IN POSITIONS OF
AUTHORITY BUT ALSO IN A UNIQUE
POSITION TO GUIDE. OUR
INCARCERATED COMMUNITY THROUGH
THE REHABILITATION PROCESS. THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES BOTH
IN AND OUT OF THE CARCERAL
SYSTEM RELIES ON OFFICERS WHO
CAN OPERATE EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY WHILE ALSO
UNDERSTANDING THE INFLUENCE OF
TRAUMA. THE DIFFERENCES IN
BRAIN MATURATION FOR THOSE WHO
WANT TO THE SYSTEM BEFORE THE
MID TWENTIES. AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE WE
BELIEVE AND IT'S BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE. THAT BOTH EXIST.
HELLO HELPED SHAPE A CALL SHIFT
BY DEEP AND- TO YOU. HELPING TO
PROMOTE POSITIVE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE ABOUT ON A. B.
EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MY GOODNESS. REMEMBER THIS
IS ACTUALLY MAX PERRY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION OF
THEIR POLICIES MISTER COLEMAN
CAN BE YEAR I'LL BE BRIEF I
FIRST WANT TO THANK MISTER
JONES SAWYER FOR WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR
ORGANIZATION AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO MERGE THE LANGUAGE OF OUR
SPONSORED BILL SB THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN INTO AB EIGHTY NINE AB
EIGHTY NINE AS AMENDED IS AN
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION EPA IS PROUD TO BE
IN SUPPORT. THE BILL WITH THAT
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
EDUCATIONAL PATHWAY FOR
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
WILL FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM
POLICING IN THE YEARS AHEAD OUR
GOAL IS TO CREATE A CHANGE NOW
COMES BY HAVING EVERY SINGLE
KID THAT LEAVING THE ACADEMY
COMPLETE COLLEGE COURSE
BREAKING AREAS OF STUDY.
CRITICAL TO THE CRASHING.
THINKING IN A- AND- ARE KEY
TRADE WE NEED TO. IN OUR
OFFICERS. IT PATHWAY CREATED BY
BEATING. WHICH WILL BE
DEVELOPED WITH EDUCATORS.
LEADERS AND WANT WORK AND-WORKING TOGETHER. TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE TRAITS ON HAND IN
EVERY PROSPECT OF BOXER. YOU C.
A. EXCITED BECAUSE BILL BECOME
A REALITY AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THE WORK AHEAD. AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU NOW WE MOVE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTY NINE. SEEN ON OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM IN TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS WELL
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES INTO THIRDS WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF AB. EIGHTY NINE. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
ALREADY HAVE- SEVERAL IN Q.
WILL START WITH LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO THAT'S
TRIPLE TO. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO YOU MAY HAVE SELF MUTED
WE'RE HEARING AUDIO. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
THAT'S ONE NINE ZERO. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE HAVING ALL
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WITH
THAT LINE. OKAY ONE NINETY
TRIED NOW I THINK YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. DANNECKER ROAD ARE
NOW ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
SUPPORT. YOU WOULDN'T PUT A
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO THAT'S ONE SEVEN
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS
WOULD ALIGN NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TWO THAT'S ONE FIVE
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LASTLY
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. X.
WOULD ALIGN NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO THAT'S TWO THREE
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAND TO LOSE
OUT ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
NOW GROWING NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE TWO THREE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RON RAPP SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WE'RE APPROACH
WHERE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB
EIGHTY NINE AND- ENCOURAGING I
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR GOING TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE THAT'S
TWO THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH
SHOULD DEBATE WITH- BEHALF OF
EXONERATED NATION IN SUPPORT.
GROWING NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX TWO THREE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AT THE MOMENT I'M
WITH CALO FOCUSING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE NATIONAL
ACTION NETWORK AMOUNTS AFTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. EXHORT A
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINE ONE ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE
WADE. AND I SUPPORT THE BILL MY
SON WAS WITH THE BARBER OF
POLICE BRUTALITY. AND USE-
KNOWING THAT YOU KNOW ALL THIS
IS A HARD IN THE VERY YOUNG AGE
WITH NO EDUCATION NOT MUCH
EMPATHY. AND EVEN YOU KNOW WITH
THEM COMMITTING CRIMES ON OTHER
PEOPLE THEY'RE ABLE TO BOUNCE
AROUND TO OTHER POLICE
DEPARTMENTS OF THE CITY OF THE
STATE THAT I DON'T THINK THAT'S
FAIR. YOU KNOW THIS IS WHO HAVE
BEEN HARMED BY POLICE TO SO I
STRONGLY. SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
IN Q. THAT'S FINE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE THAT'S TWO
THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE WE CHECK CALLING FOR SELF
MUTE. YEAH POLITIES I HAD
ABILITY TO PUT DIFFICULTY
ENEMIES AND LIKE THE CAR ON
BEHALF OF UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE
TO OPPOSITION I SEE THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES ARE LISTED AS
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS WLL COME
NOW TO FORTY TWO OLD THREE OR
OTHER WITNESSES HERE. WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AND
YOU CAN STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PUSH RESEARCHER
MEMBER SHARON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION WITH THE AMENDMENTS
WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION C. NINE MOVING TO
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE AS WELL. MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO OUR PHONE LINES SEEN IF
THERE'S WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TELEPHONICALLY. IF YOU WISH TO
ASK IN OPPOSITION AGAINST AB
EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE THAT
IS JUST SHOWING UP PLEASE ALLOW
ONE MOMENT FOR US TO PROVIDE
THE LINE NUMBER. BORDERLINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SIX THAT'S ONE EIGHT SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS MATTHEW
NUCLEAR PLAN CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE STILL
STILL REVIEWING THE EVENTS-
TECHNICALLY WERE OPPOSED YEAH
THAT THAT MAY CHANGE AFTER WE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY BUT THERE
ARE SOME. TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH
THE BILL RELATED SAID THE
PROGRAM BEING RUN OPPOSED OUR
CERTIFICATES BEING ISSUED BY
PEOPLE'S THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'M SURE THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
INTO AT THIS TIME BURKE WILL
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AT THIS TIME EITHER QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS RELATES
TO AB EIGHTY NINTH. CENTER COME
ON. I DON'T THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANNA THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FOR BRINGING
THIS- BUILT FORWARD AND FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT. IN THIS SPACE.
YOU KNOW I DON'T NECESSARILY
AGREE THAT- BOOK SMARTS- AND
AKADEMI ARE THE ONLY ANSWER BUT
YOU KNOW I'M- ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS ABOUT A COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE. IS THAT IT PROVIDES
YOU THE SPACE. TO LEARN SKILLS-
PROBLEM SOLVING SKILLS DECISION
MAKING SKILLS- TIME MANAGEMENT-
IT PROMOTES DISCIPLINE- AND
ALLOWS YOU THE SPACE THE SAFE
SPACE. TO EXPERIMENT WITH THOSE
SKILL SETS AND FAIL. AND THEN
LEARN NEW TOOLS AND SKILLS THAT
WILL ALLOW YOU TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY THAT'S WHAT IS AT
THE HEART OF THIS BILL HOW DO
WE- CREATE DIFFERENT
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR FOLKS WHO
ARE INTERESTED IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BY ENCOURAGING-
THESE RECRUITS. WHO HAVE THESE
KINDS OF SKILLS BECAUSE MOST OF
WHAT WE ARE SEEING- ON THE NEWS
AND IN REPORTS AROUND- POLICE
MISCONDUCT. REALLY HAVE TO DO
IS KIND OF FAULTY DECISION
MAKING OR FAULTY PROBLEM
SOLVING SKILLS- AND SO I THINK
THIS IS- AN ELEGANT APPROACH
AND YOU KNOW THE REALITY IS IF
NOTHING ELSE IT MIGHT ATTRACT A
DIFFERENT CALIBER OF RECRUITS
AND I THINK ULTIMATELY WE CAN
ALL AGREE THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING. THAT WE WANT TO SEE
SO I THINK YOU AGAIN I'M FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND FOR
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION.
THANK CENTER CENTER TROUBLE.
SEVERAL CLARIFICATION PURPOSES-
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
ARE TAKING YOU ARE ACCEPTING TO
LOWER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE SO
MY ORIGINAL QUESTION HAD BEEN-
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH THE
TWENTY FIVE YEAR. AGE OUR AGE
AND THEN NUMBER TWO JUST- SO
NOW IT IS I UNDERSTAND IT'S
TWENTY ONE YEARS WITH A DEGREE
OR BY COMPLETING THE NEW DEGREE
PROGRAM OUR CHURCH ON SEPT I
POSTED AND THAT'S THE STANDARD
TRAINING RIGHT RIGHT CORRECT
WITH THE NAY GOSH SO HOW WE
CAME UP WITH THE- TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF AGE WHEN WE TALK TO
THE PROFESSIONALS. THE SPECTER
AS FOR SHIA. ONE OF. THAT ARE
CAL STATEFULLERTON DR
CHRISTINE GARDNER SHE
RECOMMENDED TWENTY FIVE- AND AS
I ALSO DID MY OWN IT IS OBVIOUS
IS NOT. EMPIRICAL WORK IN ANY
WAY BUT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU TALK
TO A LOT OF. WOMEN WHO Nó MEN
A LOT OF THEM WILL SAY THAT
MOST MENTAL MATURING JULY
THIRTY SO TWENTY FIVE SEEM LIKE
A GOOD PLACE TO START. THAT
DISCUSSION BUT THE WHOLE
DISCUSSION ABOUT- GIVEN AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD. A GUN AND A
LICENSE TO KILL AND THEN PUT
HIM OUT IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS IN
THE STREET JUST I THINK IT WAS
APPARENT EVEN TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND SO THAT BECAME
A GOOD COMPROMISE ALSO SINCE A
LOT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ALREADY KIND OF STIPULATE TO
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE SO IT'S
REALLY ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THAT INDIVIDUAL WHO STARTS. IS
MATURE ENOUGH AND WIDE ENOUGH
THIS IS ABOUT. QUALITY OFFICERS
GOING AND NOT QUANTITY OF
OFFICERS GOING TO. AND DO YOU
HAPPEN TO KNOW HOW THE
PROFESSOR I CAME UP WITH THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE BUT STATE
DOES SO OUR DOCTOR CHRISTINE
GARTNER RESEARCH FROM CAL STATE
FULLERTON SHOWCASE THAT
INCREASE EDUCATION REQUIREMENT.
DOES NOT NECESSITATE A GROUP
TYPE REDUCTION AND THAT'S IT
ELIGIBILITY OF MINORITY CAN IN
FACT NATIONAL RATE THE SERVICE
SHOWN THAT- ROLE THAT THE
RECRUITMENT CHIEFS AND SHERIFFS
HAVE OFTEN REQUIRE THAT SO SHE
ALSO DID STUDIES ON THE FRONTAL
LOBE AND I THINK YOU I KNOW
YOU'RE NEW TO THE COMMITTEE BUT
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF- STUDIES.
ON PEOPLE WHO ARE CONVICTED OF
CRIMES IN FACT IF YOU'RE
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WE'VE SAID
THEY MAY NOT BEEN TO MATURE
ENOUGH EVEN THOUGH THEY'VE DONE
A HEINOUS CRIME THEY MAY NOT
HAVE HAD THE MENTAL CAPACITY OR
THE MATURITY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY WERE DOING SO WE'VE WE AS
A AS A STATE WE'VE LOWERED THAT
BECAUSE OF NOT JUST HER BUT
OTHERS HAVE COME IN. AND
TESTIFIED THAT- OLDER BUT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS SEEM TO BE
THE AGE WHERE WE WOULD SAY LOOK
AT THAT AGE AND OLDER THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
AND SO WE'VE WE'VE ALLOW PEOPLE
WHO'VE DONE SOMETHING YOUNGER
TO GET OUT EARLIER FOR A
FEDERAL CRIMINAL SIDE SO WHY
AREN'T WE DOING THAT ON. THE ON
THE POLICE ARE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I THINK YOU HAVE
SOME JONES SAWYER FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA HI TO-
THE LESSER ME BELIEVE. A-
COLLEGE DEGREE IN IT OF ITSELF
GOING TO SOLVE SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE FACE SOME LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT I THINK WE ALL
HAVE TO AGREE- MORE WORLD
EXPERIENCE MORE- KNOWLEDGE IS
ALWAYS GOOD- AND WE KNOW THE
MAJORITY OF POLICE OFFICERS. IN
THIS COUNTRY IN IN STATE- OVER
75% OF JUST HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA THOMAS SO. I THINK IT
WOULD BE- WE ALL WOULD ALL BE
BETTER SERVED IN WILL CREATE A
LITTLE BIT OF A GREATER DEGREE
IN TRUSTING CONFIDENCE IF- THEY
DID HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
EXPOSURE- TO THE WORLD AND IF
THAT'S TO THE COLLEGE DEGREE
THEN I'M ALL FOR THAT- SO I
WANT TO. THANK YOU FOR. WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND BRING
THIS MATER FORD AND- FOREIGN.
ALL WHO ARE YOU CLOSE. BUT WHEN
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
FOR. AMENDMENTS FOR. HAVING
THIS SPACE. TO DIVE IN AND
ADVERTISED FOR PEOPLE FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
MINORITIES I THINK WILL ALSO.
HELP BRING THIS IS A
CLASSIFICATION OFFICERS TO MAKE
IT EVEN MORE DIVERSE. SILENT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR AMENDMENT
BECAUSE I. THINK IT WAS A
BRILLIANT WAY. TO EXPAND THAT
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. PHONE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO COAX A
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS OR
CHICKEN AMID- MOTION ON AV
EIGHTY NINE. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR CALM WATER COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE V.
EIGHTY NINE AB EIGHTY NINE
BRADFORD BY APHRODITE CHOI
BOGUE I. HELLO GUYS DURAZO COM
LOGGER NINE. ONE MARKER I
SKINNER. THE MEASURE OF THREE
VOTES WILL LIBERAL OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS SHOT OFF. THANK
YOU NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FOLLOW NUMBER THREE AB TWO TO
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD
AFTER WE DO OUR HOUSE. KEEPING
WILL YOU CAN GET IN YOUR
TESTIMONY. THEY MEDICARE
MEMBERS ARE I WOULD LIKE TO
START OFF WITH OFFERING
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO AB TWO
TO THREE THAT CHANGES THE
MINIMUM DOLLAR AMOUNT FOR THE
FIRST AND SECOND OFFENSE BY
POACHING DUDLEYA CAPS THE
MAXIMUM DOLLAR AMOUNT FOR FINES
AND CHANGE THE PENALTY FROM A
PER PLANTED TO RESTRICT DOLLAR
VALUE VIOLATION THE MOMENTS
WILL ALSO CREATE AN EXEMPTION
FROM THE PENALTIES FOR
PURCHASING OR SELLING DUDLEYA.
UNDER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
IN VALUE TO ENSURE THAT THE
FOCUS IS ON THE LARGE POACHERS
AND NOT SOMEONE WHO MISTAKENLY
FIND THEMSELVES IN POSSESSION
OF A FEW ILLEGALLY HARVESTED
PLANTS THESE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS COME OUT OF
DISCUSSIONS YESTERDAY WITH THE
ACLU AND COMMITTEE STAFF AND I
UNDERSTAND WITH THESE MEMBERS
OF THE ECL WOULD REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION. BUT WHAT IS AB TWO
TO THREE IT MAKES IT UNLAWFUL
TO TAKE DE LEON FROM ITS
NATURAL HABITAT ON LAND OWNED
BY THAT STATE OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR ON PROPERTY
THAT'S NOT ONE'S OWN DUDLEY IS
A GENUS OFSUCCULENTS THAT
INCLUDES FORTY SEVEN SPECIES
TWENTY SIX OF WHICH ARE FOUND
IN NATIVE HABITATS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. RECENTLY THIS GENUS
HAS BECOME INCREDIBLY POPULAR
AND SOME OTHER COUNTRIES A
SINGLE PLANT A TYPICALLY SELL
FOR FIFTY TO EIGHTY DOLLARS AND
SOMETIMES UP TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A LARGER MATURE
DUDLEYA PLANTS AS A RESULT
POACHERS HAVE BEEN HARVESTING
DUDLEY ABOUT THE THOUSANDS
TARGETING THESE LARGER MORE
MATURE PLANTS ALONG OUR COAST
AND THEN SHIPPING THEM OVERSEAS
AND SELLING THEM ELSEWHERE.
WHILE THE COURTS HAVE BEEN
CREATED IN PENALIZING POACHERS
THE FINE AMOUNTS THAT CAN BE
LEVIED ARE MINUSCULE WHEN
COMPARED TO THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
POACHERS COULD MAKE SELLING THE
PLANTS ON THE UNDERGROUND
MARKET THE PENALTIES
ESTABLISHED THROUGH TV BE TWO
TO THREE ARE ANALOGOUS WITH
RECENT LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS
IVORY AND SHARK FIN POACHING.
SO BY EXPLICITLY MAKING IT
UNLAWFUL TO POACH DUDLEYA AND
ESTABLISHING STRONGER PENALTIES
FOR VIOLATIONS AB TWO TO THREE
WILL HELP DETER THIS POACHING
AND PROMOTE EFFECTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON THE LINE TODAY I
HAD NICK JENSEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
TO TESTIFY BY PHONE IN SUPPORT
AND. WHEN THE TIME COMES I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
I. I VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
YOUR FIRST WITNESS ARE YOUR
ONLY PRIMARY WITNESS OTHER
PREPARE TO BEGIN THEIR
TESTIMONY THE A PERMANENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NICK
JENSEN AND I'M THE CONSERVATION
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
AND PS. MY REALIZATION AT THE
SPONSOR FOR A B. TWO TWENTY
THREE AND WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARDS WHICH REALLY FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL. THE IT HAS
BEEN VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
ISSUE OF DEADLY APPROACHING IF
YOU LEARNED ABOUT IT ABOUT
THREE YEARS AGO. TWENTY SEVEN
YOU'VE BEEN DOWN THERE WHICH I
FIND COVERING CLOSE FACES IN
GORGEOUS PLACES LIKE WHITE
MOTHER IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS. YOU CAN ALSO FIND AT
LEE AND OTHER PARTS OF OUR
STATE INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
DESERT AND HEARING ABOUT A-
THIRD PARTY PARTS OF OUR
NATIVE. BIODIVERSITY PROVIDING
FOOD FOR POLLINATORS AND OTHER
SPECIES. AND PROTECTING AGAINST
ORIGINAL ON CLICK HEALTH SIDE.
OUR STATE IS A WORLDWIDE TENURE
OF DEADLY DIVERSITY AND
POACHING ACTIVITIES THREATEN
BOTH RARE AND COMMON SPECIES.
BUDGET HAVE REMOVED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PLANTS WORTH
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM THE
WILD AND THIS SHOWED NO SIGN OF
SLOWING DOWN. PIETISTS
INCLUDING MYSELF ARE VERY
CONCERNED THAT THIS TREND COULD
DRIVE SOME OF OUR RAREST PLANT
SPECIES TOWARDS EXTINCTION.
WHILE DEGRADING HABITAT. INDEED
BUDGET OPERATIONS HAVE REMOVED
ENTIRE HELD BY THE W. LONGER
KIND OF THE STATE LINE THE
STABILIZING QUEST. AND CREATE A
HAZARD TO THE PUBLIC. I
PERSONALLY UNDER LAW. MANY OF
THE DEADLIEST SPECIES MOST AT
RISK FROM THE HAVE THE
DEMOCRATS. ARE NOT PROTECTED.
AB TWO TWENTY THREE GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN
DISTRICT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO TARGET ILLEGAL W. POCI
OPERATION. IT CLARIFIES THAT
FOR MOVING DOWN THERE FROM LAND
IN CALIFORNIA IT IS ILLEGAL
WITHOUT MY ENDEAVOR INFORMATION
FOR A PERMIT FROM CDFW.
ESTABLISHES APPROPRIATE
PENALTIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF HARD THING ABOUT
THE ILLEGALLY. THIS BILL IS A
NECESSARY STEP TO DETER FUTURE
APPROACHING OPERATIONS THAT
THREATEN CALIFORNIA'S
REMARKABLE BIODIVERSITY. CAN'T
GET HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
ALONG WITH THIRTY FIVE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
STATEWIDE CHAPTER NETWORK OF
ELEVEN THOUSAND NUMBERS. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWENTY THREE HAPPY. DAY AFTER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK NOW WILL MOVE TO THE
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
ARE THERE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWO TO THREE. C. NINE
WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
AND TWENTY FORTY OR THEIR
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THERE'S
NO ONE THERE AS WLL COUNCIL
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES
WERE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TO THREE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL BEGIN WITH LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THAT'S TWO
ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN KIM DELFINO ON THE
BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO TO
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE
QUICKNESS. GROWING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CAN MEMBERS THIS
IS JENNIFER FEARING TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWENTY
THREE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME WARDEN
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS.
ASSOCIATION AND THE MOUNTAIN
LIONS AND THE- THANK. THANK YOU
FOR THE- PEARLING NUMBER TWO
AND FOUR NINE FOUR NINE LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER NUMBER
NIKITA KARATE THE NATURAL
RESOURCES CAL CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS
ALAINA TWO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
TO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- THIS IS KATHY SURE
FOR THE FOR A DEAL YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND I'M JUST
CALLING TO CONFIRM THAT WE-
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORKING
WITH US AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS
WE ARE REMOVING. THANK YOU FOR
TO ADDRESS. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT ONE
THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS ABDALLAH MILD
REPORTING SUPPORT FOR THE NEXT
FINANCIAL PLAN FOR REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. WILL GO TO
ONE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT. TWO TWO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRY MEMBERS THIS
IS A PASSIONATE MAN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
OF RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT AND THE MOJAVE DESERT
LAND TRUST IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. SMARTER WE HAVE INDEED
EXHAUSTED BUT YOU MISTER MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE
TO LEAD OPPOSITION I SEE
THERE'S A KATHY SHEARER. OUR
LEAD OPPOSITION. YEAH MODERATE
CAN YOU Q. SHE'S ARE KALRA.
MARCH IS NOW NEUTRAL ARE WILL
COME TO FORTY TWO OLD THREE ARE
THERE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO TO THREE. C. NINE
WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS WELL
MODERATE WILL GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TO THREE.
IF YOU WISH TO VOICE OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. SURE THERE IS NO ONE
SHOWING UP IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
REGARDING THIS MEASURE. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS WERE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THIS
MEASURE. WILD CENTERS LOOKING
THROUGH OUR NOTES I JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION. WHAT IS THE PLANT
LOOK LIKE SO THE NEXT TIME I
MIGHT IN A WILDERNESS ON
PICKETING GO TO JAIL SO IT
WOULD LOOK LIKE THANK YOU
SENATOR- GORGEOUS DIET-
SUCCULENT SPECIES- MAYBE YOU
KNOW ABOUT THE SIZE OF A
BASKETBALL OR LASTS ON AND-
THERE. HE WOULD YOU KNOW BE
HAPPY TO SHOW YOU ON A TOUR OF
A STATE PARK- OR SOMEWHERE
ALONG THE COASTLINE- ALSO
INLAND- SPECIES'S WHILE OTHERS
TAKE A PICTURE FOR NOW BUT HERE
I HAVE IT ORDER OFFICE A COUPLE
I. CAN'T SAY ENOUGH. NO URINE.
I GUESS IS NO QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS- SERMON WHICH OUGHT TO
CLOSE. IT IS RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTED ITEMS. WE HAVE A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS WERE SEEKING A
MOTION ON THIS ROGER. IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR HOOKED TO A
BOAT. CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON AB TWO TO THREE AB TWO
TO THREE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
DIETRO VOGUE I TROUBLE GUY
DORADO COM LONGER SKINNER.
BELIEVE THE RULE OPEN FOR UP TO
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION NOW WE'RE MOVING
TO AB TWO TWO NINE MISTER
HOLDEN I DO NOT SEE ON THE
WRONG. ALL RIGHT SOME CONCERNED
I SEE MR LARKIN- MISTER LUCKY
FIRST. HOWEVER GRAYSON IRATE
WHIMS GRAYSON NINE. WE HAVE.
MEMORY IS AT. ELEVEN OH FOUR.
AB ELEVEN OH FOUR OKAY. TIM
GRAYSON HAS MR HOLDEN JUST
WALKED. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LAST SESSION I AUTHORED A
SIMILAR BILL BUT AND I ALSO
STATED THAT MY INTENT TO FIND A
LONG TERM FUNDING SOLUTION FOR
AIR MBULANCE PROVIDERS- WOULD
BE MIGHT WITH WOULD BE MY GOAL
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
FOUND A LONG TERM SOLUTION.
EMERGENCY ERR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS ARE IN THE CENTRAL
PART OF THE STATEWIDE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES SYSTEM EMS
THEY ALSO PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
HOMELAND SECURITY AND DISASTER
RESPONSE INCLUDING THE
EVACUATING OF HOSPITALS IN THE
PATH OF WILD FIRES AND
RESPONDING TO COVERT NINETEEN
CRISIS EVERY YEAR THAT THE
PROVISIONS OF A MODEL MUST BE
EXTENDED BECAUSE THE A GREAT
DEAL OF ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY
FOR AROUND FOUR AND LET'S
PROVIDERS EXIST FOR EXAMPLE
LAST YEAR. TO THE LEGISLATORS
LIMITED ABILITY TO MEET BECAUSE
OF COVERT NINETEEN RESTRICTIONS
THE PROVISIONS OF AMADA EXPIRED
AND THE PROVISIONS OF A MODEL
AGAIN EXPIRED. ON JULY FIRST OF
THIS YEAR. EDIT CAL AIR
AMBULANCE RATES HAVE NOT BEEN
INCREASED SINCE THEY WERE
INITIALLY ESTABLISHED IN JULY
OF NINETEEN NINETY THREE. AND
AS WITH OTHER EMERGENCY
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS IS PLACED AN
ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC STRAIN ON
PROVIDERS. THE US ANY REDUCTION
OF FUNDING PROVIDED BY A MODEL
AT THIS TIME WOULD UNDOUBTEDLY
PLEASE THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY
OF MANY EMERGENCY HELICOPTER
BASES. AT RISK OF CLOSING
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AREAS AND
THOSE PROVIDING SERVICES TO
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL TO HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF MEDIC CAL
UTILIZATION. AB ELEVEN OH FOUR
WILL PROVIDE A TEMPORARY
EXTENSION OF A MODEL TO ALLOW
THE AIR AMBULANCE PROVIDERS TO
CONTINUE. TO PROVIDE LIFESAVING
SERVICES IN THE INTERIM AFTER
THAT THE MODEL WILL BE PHASED
OUT AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WILL
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT. A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT PROGRAM
PROVIDE A LONG TERM OVERDUE
RATE INCREASE. MY WITNESS TODAY
IS CHRIS KELLER PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. OF
AIR MEDICAL SERVICES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AS STATED MY
NAME IS CHRISTIAN KELLER AND I
COME EARING TWO HATS TODAY I
AM THE PRESIDENT AND ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF AIR MEDICAL SERVICE WILL.
KNOWN AS KALENDS REPRESENTING
ALL MEDICAL SERVICES BRING
CALIFORNIA AND BREACHER MEDICAL
SERVICES ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST PROVIDERS OF EMERGENCY
AIR AMBULANCE SERVICE. I'M HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A LEVY AB
ELEVEN THEREFORE AND ONE OF
SEVERAL CO SPONSORS. AND MA'AM
MR GRADING STATED AMBULANCE
SERVICES PROVIDE LIFESAVING
EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION FOR
THE MOST CRITICAL PATIENTS
DIRECTLY TO TRAUMA CENTERS. IN
RURAL AREAS WHERE EMERGENCY
HAPPENED PARTLY TREATMENT
CENTERS OR DIFFICULT TO REACH
PLACES ERIN GO UNDER ALL THE
PATIENT ONLY HOPE FOR RECEIVING
EMERGENCY TERTIARY. CARE IN A
TIMELY MANNER. I AM GOING TO
THE GAME OUR NOT THANK PART THE
STATE AMONG MEDICAL SERVICE
SYSTEM I NEED TO PLAY A ROLE IN
THE- RISK. HOMELAND SECURITY
AND THERE'S NO OTHER STATE NET
IN PLACE TO PAY IT WHAT. THIS
BILL WILL. TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
FUNDING THE FENCE. IN TERMS. WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MR ND
COURSE NEXT CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUE WE RESPECT- YOU. YOUR
ARTICLE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER TAYLOR- NOW LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN AT ZERO
FOUR. YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT OF IT- IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE FOUR EIGHT AB
ELEVEN OH FOUR C. NINE DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WAS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN FORTY.
C. NINE. MR MURRAY WILL NOT
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
OH FOUR WILL BEGIN. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE A COUPLE IN Q.
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT CENTS
TO FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN OH FOUR THANK YOU. SIX
WHAT A LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOUR THAT'S TWO FIVE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU- MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DOMINIC TOMORROW BEHALF OF
ERROR MESSAGE- DOING BUSINESS
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA TWO.
DIFFERENT NAMES WE ARE SPONSORS
AND IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN OH
FOUR. GROWING NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX THAT'S
TWO FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU JOHN HENSCHEL HERE ON
BEHALF OF GLOBAL MEDICAL
RESPONSE ALSO ONE OF THE
SPONSORS ALSO OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT THANKS SO MUCH. WE
pON NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE THAT'S TWO FIVE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN NUMBERS MALAM COOPER WITH
NIELSEN MARKSMAN ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MHM I'M SURE WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR HE
WILL NINE CHECKING THE LINES
ONE MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM ALL OF
OUR SUPPORTERS. FOR EIGHTY
ELEVEN OH FOUR. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO REACH OUT AND
SUPPORT. AND VOICE THAT YOU MAY
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE IS NO ONE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT NOW WILL MOVE
TO OPPOSITION- JR ANYONE HERE
AND FORTY TOOL THREE WHOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION- A. B. HELLO FOR.
WELL LET'S GO TO OUR FIRST
PRIMARY A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- ARE THEIR- PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION LOOKS
WITH. AND OFF POSITION NONE
LISTED. GOING BACK TO THE ROOM
IS THERE ANYONE HERE SHE NINE
WHAT ABOUT TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NO ONE THERE AS WELL. MODERATOR
HOW ARE THEIR COLLARS IN
OPPOSITION THAT ARE CUTE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO VOICE OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE SHOWING UP IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE OTHER ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS
RELATES TO A REAL. ELEVEN- FOR.
NINE YOUR SISTER CENTER SKINNER
WELL WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR SKINNER WE HAVE A TWO
PASSES IT TO PASS AS AMENDED
THIS TO PSS STRICTER
APPROPRIATIONS ALL RIGHT-
ASSUME GRAYSON WHICH OUGHT TO
CLOSE THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN AND UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COUNCIL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON AB ELEVEN OH
FOUR ELEVEN OH FOUR BRADFORD
ROAD FOR DIETRO VOGUE HI OBOE
GUY DURAZO'S COM LONGER. AND
LONGER AYE SKINNER. SKINNER I.
THE BILL HAS FISH BOAT TO GET
OUT WILL LOSE ROLE OF THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU. NOW
GO PRACTICE TO SEE SOME
MOVEMENT HAS READY. FOR WE HAVE
TWO TWO NINE. SEVEN WHEN YOU'RE
PREPARED YOU MAY BEGIN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AT FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
CONSULTANT AS WELL AS ITS HERE
OF SENATE BMP AND HIS
CONSULTANT FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF AND CAL SEGA. TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS THAT COUNTS SIX
PRESTON BMP. I ACCEPT OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE AGREED
UPON AND I HOPE THAT THOSE
AMENDMENTS SATISFY YOUR SENATE
COLLEAGUES. THAT WANTED TO SEE
US COME TO A RESOLUTION ON THE
TRAINING AND REPORTING ASPECTS
OF THIS BILL. TURN MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWENTY NINE A BILL
THAT PROHIBITS A PERSON
REQUIRED. TO BE REGISTERED AS A
SECURITY GUARD FROM CARRYING OR
USING A FIRE ARM OR BATON
UNLESS THE SECURITY GUARD IS AN
EMPLOYEE. OF A PRIVATE PATROL
OPERATOR LICENSEE HARM POORLY
OF THE STATE. MEMBERS AS THE
COUNTRY WHAT'S THE TRIAL OF
DIRECTOR CHILDREN. THE EX
POLICE OFFICER CHARGED WITH THE
KILLING OF GEORGE FLOYD. THERE
WAS A SIMULTANEOUS DISCUSSION
REGARDING LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THE TRAINING OF THE APPROPRIATE
USE OF FORCE. THE CONVICTION OF
THEIR CHILDREN WAS THE FIRST
STEP IN SECURING JUSTICE FOR
GEORGE FLOYD NOW THE NATION
SETS ITS SIGHTS ON THE OTHER
THREE OF POLICE OFFICERS THAT
FAILED TO INTERVENE AND
ULTIMATELY WATCHED. AS GEORGE
FLOYDS FINAL MOMENTS ON EARTH
EXPIRED. BUT TODAY I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND BRING AWARENESS
OF THE FACT THAT THERE. ARE
OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
THAT CARRY FIREARMS OF THE
TAUNTS. THEIR EMPLOYEE TO KEEP
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND PROPERTY
SAFE AS WELL AS THE FINANCIAL
DEALINGS. OF BUSINESS
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THEY ARE HARD TO KEEP THE PEACE
AT SPORTING EVENTS AND
CONCERTS. THEY ARE OUR PRIVATE
SECURITY GUARDS. WHILE PRIVATE
SECURITY GUARDS DIFFER FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN A NUMBER OF
AREAS. I WOULD ARGUE THAT THEY
OFTEN FACE SIMILAR SITUATIONS
EVEN TRAGIC ONES. MEMBERS MARIO
MATTHEWS WAS A MEXICAN AMERICAN
WHO WORKED AS A WAREHOUSE
WORKER. ACCORDING TO A LAWSUIT
FILED BY HIS PARENTS ON JULY
SECOND TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AT
AROUND THREE THIRTY AM AFTER
ATTENDING AN OUTDOOR CONCERT
FOLLOWING TO IN THE ACCIDENT
NBA EXPERT TO EXHIBITION GAMES.
MARIO ENTER THE GOLDEN ONE
CENTER HERE IN SACRAMENTO. UP
TO OPEN DOOR WHICH WAS PART OF
THE MAIN ENTRANCE. VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE SHOWED MARIO
RUNNING AROUND THE COURT AND
DRIBBLING AS IF HE WAS PLAYING
BASKETBALL. INTO UNIVERSAL
PROTECTION SECURITY PERSONNEL
BEGAN SIXTY MARIO AND
EVENTUALLY DETAINED HIM. THE
LAWSUIT ALLEGES THAT MARIO WAS
SLAMMED FACE FIRST INTO A WALL
TACKLED AND RESTRAINED FACE
DOWN ON THE FLOOR. WHEN THE
BILL'S HANDS WERE HANDCUFFED
BEHIND HIS BACK AND THE TWO
SECURITY PERSONNEL GOT ON TOP
OF HIS BACK. WHILE SECURITY
GUARDS USE HIS RIGHT KNEE TO
APPLY PRESSURE TO THE SIDE OF
MARIO'S MAC. MAXIMALLY FOUR AND
A HALF MINUTES. IN ADDITION TO
THE IITIAL TO UNIVERSAL
PROTECTION SECURITY PERSONNEL A
THIRD SECURITY OFFICER PLACED
HIMSELF ON MORROW'S BACK. LARA
BECAME UNRESPONSIVE AND WAS
TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL. HE
PASSED AWAY TWO DAYS LATER THE
LAWSUIT CLAIMS THAT THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY CORONER
KNOWLEDGE THAT RESTRAINT WAS A
CAUSE OF MORROW'S DEATH.
ADDITIONALLY THE CORONER'S
PATHOLOGIST NOTED DEEP BRUISING
TOMORROW'S BACK AS A RESULT OF
THE WEIGHT AND PRESSURE THAT
HAVE BEEN PLACED ON HIM. MARIO
WEIGHED A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE POUNDS. WELL THE NATION
DEBATES LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING AND THE APPROPRIATE
USE OF FORCE PRIVATE SECURITY
GUARDS CURRENTLY HAVE NO
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS FOR
COURSES ON THE APPROPRIATE USE
OF FORCE. AB TWO TWENTY NINE
WOULD ADD THE APPROPRIATE USE
OF FORCE TO THE TRAINING
COURSES WITHIN THE PRIVATE
SECURITY SERVICES ACT INCLUDING
TRAINING ON THE USE OF
OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE FORCE.
DE ESCALATION TECHNIQUES
IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT BIAS AND
CULTURAL TRAINING. ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
COURSE IN THE CARRYING AND USE
OF FIREARMS TO INCLUDE TRAINING
IN THE APPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION COULD HELP SAVE
OTHERS. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THIS STUART
KATZ AN ATTORNEY FOR THE FAMILY
OF MARIO MATTHEWS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES PREPARED YOU
MAY BEGIN ASSESSMENT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SHARE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TO WORK AT. FAMILY OF
MERRILL MATTHEWS AFTER THAT
CASE ARE EERILY PRESCIENT OF
WHAT HAPPENED TO GEORGE FLOYD
IN TERMS OF THE PRESSURE FROM
THE NECK. BUT SENATE PRETTY I
WOULD NEED AND THIS WAS A
SITUATION WHERE I DON'T LIKE
WITH GEORGE FLOYD THESE
INDIVIDUALS DID NOT HAVE THE
TRAINING THAT INDICATED THAT.
WHAT THEY WERE DOING WHAT
IMPACT LIFE THREATENING. BOB
ACCOUNT IN THE COURSE OF MY
THIRTY PLUS YEAR CAREER
MULTIPLE OTHER INSTANCES WHERE
THE REALLY TRAGIC. ANNIVERSARY
OUTCOMES WITH SECURITY GUARDS
WHO SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
TRAINING COOLEY ONE CASE WHERE
AN INDIVIDUAL ARE ALMOST. 11%
OF BODY YOU SUFFERED THIRD
DEGREE BURNS FROM BEING
CHALLENGED. ON A PARKING LOT.
NECESSARY IN OF FACT THERE ARE
MORE SWEET WHITE RICHARD GUARD
IN THE WORK OFFICERS.
INTERSTATE CAL. APRIL INTERACT
WITH THE PUBLIC PAPER GLENROCK
WITH MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WHO
HAVE VERY FORMS OF DISABILITY
IS OF A MENTAL NATURE OF
PRIMARILY IN IMPORTS OF ALCOHOL
OR DRUGS. AND INTERACTION WHERE
YOU BRING GET A TRAGIC CON. AND
THESE POSTERS DON'T HAVE ANY
TRAINING- THE ROLE OF BENEFIT
THIS TRAIN WILL PROVIDE GOING
FROM ZERO TO AT LEAST TWENTY OR
THIRTY MILES AN HOUR IT'S A
HUGE DIFFERENCE IN WHAT WE
CURRENTLY HAV- THERE'S NO COST
REALLY IS TRYING TO RESTORE
CORD OUT OF TRAINING IT IS
ADDITIONALLY NOT TO HAVE
REQUIRED OF TRAINING REGARDING
THE USE OF FORCE. WHICH WE
PROMOTE CREDIT CONSEQUENCES I
WOULD URGE AND REQUEST THAT YOU
DO APPROVE THE- BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM
MOVES HERE TO SUPPORT. AB. TWO
TWO NINE. IF YOU ARE A WE NEED
TO COME TO THE MICROPHONE STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION. ON
ITS PART OF OUR AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN TWO TWO NINE C. I
MEAN TO FORTY TWO OH THREE C.
NINE NOW WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM OF. TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE MODERATOR
OTHER CALLERS IN Q. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWO NINE. IF YOU WISH TO
TWO NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. PICTURE
NONI QUEUING UP IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. OKAY NOW WILL MOVE
TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE A ALEX
HAD X. THE CORRECT WHO'S HERE
IN OPPOSITION OR TESTIFYING
TELEPHONICALLY. YES SIR IF YOU
THIRTY MAYBE GAINES TESTIMONY
US THROUGH MOST. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS ALEX HADDOCK'S AND I'M
A CO OWNER OF SECURITY TRAINING
CENTER WHERE COMPANY THAT
PROVIDES JOB TRAINING FOR THE
PRIVATE SECURITY INDUSTRY. WE
DO NOT OFFER PHYSICAL SECURE
SECURITY SERVICES WE FOCUS
EXCLUSIVELY ON NEW JOB TRAINING
AND CONTINUED SECURITY
EDUCATION ASK PRESCRIBED BY THE
B. S. I. S. THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
TWO NINE. THE PROVISION IN AB
TWO TWO NINE THAT MAKES THE
INITIAL EIGHT HOURS OF TRAINING
CALL THE POWERS TO ARREST
COURSE EXCLUSIVELY LIVE
CLASSROOM TRAINING IS TERRIBLE
FOR CALIFORNIANS. AND
DISENFRANCHISED IN FOR THE
WORKING POOR AND UNDER
EMPLOYED. IT WILL COST PEOPLE
LIFE CHANGING JOB OPPORTUNITIES
WHICH BASE TO REALLY NEED NOW
MORE THAN EVER. OUR PRIVATE
SECURITY IS EXTREMELY LIMITED
THEY ARE NOT GRANTED SPECIAL
POLICE POWERS THEY HAVE NO MORE
SPORTY THAN YOU OR I DO.
SECURITY GUARDS ARE CIVILIANS
WHO HAVE BEEN TRAINED TO
OBSERVE AND REPORT. THEY'RE
INSTRUCTED TO INTERVENE IN
EXTREMELY LIMITED PASSIVITY AND
CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN
APPROPRIATE. HOW TO RISK
COURSES NOT JUST THE FIRST
COURSE STERN A SECURITY GUARD
LICENCE IT IS THE COURSE WHERE
THE LIMITATIONS ON AUTHORITY
ARE TAUGHT. MOST SECURED
EMPLOYERS WILL NOT INTERVIEW A
CANDIDATE UNLESS THEY'VE
ALREADY COMPLETED THE POWERS TO
ARREST CORPORIS AND HOLD A
SECURITY GUARD LICENSE. ALL
EMPLOYMENT AND FUTURE TRAINING
PROHIBITS ON THIS ONE COURSE.
TALENT COULD LIMIT DISCOURSES
ACCESSIBILITY TO ONLY THOSE WHO
CANAFFORD TO TRAVEL TO A
TRADITIONAL CLASSROOM CREATES
AN UNNECESSARY BARRIER TO ENTRY
FOR THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
SEEKING BETTER JOBS. USING OUR
COMPANY AS AN EXAMPLE WE HAVE
TWO FACILITIES IN THE GREATER
LOS ANGELES AREA. SO FAR THIS
YEAR THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE TRAINED
ELEVEN PEOPLE ON THE POWER TO
ARREST. DURING THE IDENTICAL
PERIOD WE HAVE TAUGHT THE SAME
COURSE ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX TIMES ONLINE. ELEVEN
VERSES ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX. THAT'S OVER A
THOUSAND NEW JOBS IN CALIFORNIA
USING ONLINE JOB TRAINING. THE
FLEXIBILITY OF ONLINE TRAINING
ALLOWS THE UNDER EMPLOYED AND
WORKING POOR TO GET THE
CRITICAL JOB TRAINING THEY NEED
TO RESTART THEIR LIVES. THE
SAME GROUP OFTEN CANNOT AFFORD
A PERSONAL CAR THEY MUST RELY
ON PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. MANY
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY
IN THE RURAL AREAS DO NOT HAVE
LOCAL TRAINING FACILITIES. THE
DISTANCE BETWEEN THE FACILITY
CAN BE A HUGE BURDEN OR
INSURMOUNTABLE BARRIER. BUT
AGAIN ONLINE TRAINING IS THE
BEST SOLUTION HERE NO TRAVELS
NEEDED. THE TRAINING CAN BE
KEEP COMPLETED ON A SMARTPHONE
TABLET OR COMPUTER FROM A HOME
OR SHELTER. IF NONE OF THESE
DEVICES ARE OWNED OR CAN'T BE
BORROWED THE LOCAL PUBLIC
LIBRARY CAN BE USED. EVERY TOWN
HAS A PUBLIC LIBRARY BUT NOT
EVERY TOWN HAS A SECURITY GUARD
TRAINING FACILITY. THE BETTER
JOB INSECURITY OR A SECOND PART
TIME JOB AND SECURITY CAN HELP
LIFT THE WORKING POOR AND UNDER
EMPLOYED OUT OF POVERTY. THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT ONLINE JOB
TRAINING OFFERS SHOULD NOT BE
DISMISSED. NOT ONLY CAN THE
TRYING TO BE COMPLETED FROM
HOME BUT IT CAN ALSO BE
COMPLETED AT ANY HOUR. RATHER
THAN SIX TWO BUSINESS HOURS
ONLINE TRAINING ALLOWS A
CANDIDATE TO COMPLETE THE
COURSE WORK DAY OR NIGHT. DON'T
AFTER A LONG DAY THE WORKING
PARENT CAN COME HOME SPEND TIME
WITH THE FAMILY AND THEN
COMPLETE THE JOB TRAINING AFTER
THE KIDS ARE ASLEEP. JUST AS
IMPORTANT THE ONLINE JOB
TRAINING DOES NOT FORCE THE
WORKING PARENT TO SKIP A DAY OF
WORK TO ATTEND TRAINING FOR A
SECOND OR BETTER JOB. BUT
LEGISLATION IS CURRENTLY POSED
BUT PROPOSED SHOULD BE AMENDED
TO PERMIT ONLINE TRAINING TO
CONTINUE AS IT IS PRESENTLY
AUTHORIZED BY THE BSS. IN
ADDITION I SUPPORT THE
STRENGTHENING OF THE BASIC
TRAININGS- TRAINING AS SET
FORTH IN PROPOSED LEGISLATION.
AND OFFER MY KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERTISE IN FURTHER INTO THE
SCHOOL. WE NEED TO KEEP HIS JOB
TRAINING ACCESSIBLE AND KEEP IT
AFFORDABLE TO ALL- ACCESS TO
ONLINE JOB TRAINING WILL
UNFAIRLY AFFECTED THE
ECONOMICALLY VULNERABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS WHY SIMPLY
BILL TWO TWO NINE CANNOT PASS
AT AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN. ONLINE
TRAINING MUST BE PRESERVED.
THANK YOU NOW WILL GO TO THE
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TWO NINE.
SHE NINE WILL GO TO R. OR FLOOR
ROOM AND THERE'S NO ONE THERE
AS WELL MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
CALLERS DESIRING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TO KNOCK.
IF YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE ONE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO THAT'S ONE A TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LOCHER AND
MEMBERS JERRY DESMOND ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSED INVESTIGATORS. NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THAT
ARE WERE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF
ON A TECHNICAL AMENDMENT. THAT
ACTUALLY MAY BE IN ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY AS A-
AND A AND A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. TO ADDRESS SOME
ARCANE PROVISION IN THE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR ACT. SINCE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS DO NOT HELP THE-
STATUTORY POWER TO ARREST. OR
TO USE FORCE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT IS CLARIFIED IN THE LAW.
THAT LACK OF POWER AND THAT THE
APPLICATION THE BILL. NECESSARY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MR SURE
NO ONE ELSE IS QUEUED UP IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME RIGHT-
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FOR AS SOON
HOLDEN AS IT RELATES TO AB TWO
TWO NINE. YES CENTER TROUBLE. I
JUST HAD A QUESTION WITH REGARD
TO THE CONCERN THAT WAS
EXPRESSED EARLIER- WITH THE-
THE FORMER EDUCATOR I'M ALL
ABOUT CHOICES AND OPTIONS- BUT
YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
POSSIBILITY OF HAVING AN
ONLINE. COMPONENT YES THE BILL
PART OF WHAT WE ADDRESSING OUT
OF THE BMP DISCUSSION COMMITTEE
DISCUSSION WAS THAT THE BILL
WOULD HAVE 50% CLASSROOMS 50%
ONLINE. BECAUSE OF SOME OF WHAT
IS BEING EXPECTED TO RAISE THE
GOING TO PROBABLY REQUIRE IN
PERSON TECHNIQUE TRAINING
SIMULATION AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE. AND BUT NO THIS IS NOT
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS
STILL A LOT OF ELEMENTS OF HOW
THESE OFFICERS ARE TRAINED FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE TRYING TO
BE- SECURITY PERSONNEL THEY CAN
BE DONE ONLINE AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND SO THE
BILL STILL CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT. TO OCCUR.
AND HOW WOULD YOU ADDRESS THE-
THE IN PERSON- COMPONENT THAT
IS REQUIRED CURRENTLY AND IT'S-
ITS ABILITY TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE THAT COULD QUALIFY
TO- ATTEND OR PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROGRAM RIGHT. FIRST OF
ALL WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH CARL SAGAN TO
ADDRESS THESE TYPE OF ISSUES
AND I MEAN I TERMS OF IN A
CLASSROOM THERE ARE- LOCATIONS
AND IT'S MADE AVAILABLE THROUGH
A PROGRAM THROUGH- EXISTING.
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES BUT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH KOUSEI
GOOD TO KIND OF INSTRUCTORS AND
SHOW US HOW THIS WOULD BE
WORKING OUT AS WELL BUT WE'VE
BEEN COLLABORATING THEY
SUPPORT. HERE WE ARE. BECAUSE I
THINK CLEARLY THIS IS- AS WE'VE
SEEN NOT ONLY IN THE INSTANCE
THAT I. RECITED AND MY
PRESENTATION BUT WE'VE SEEN IT
IN SAN DIEGO. WHERE OUR
SECURITY PERSONNEL BASICALLY
NOT EXACTLY KNOWING HOW TO USE
TECHNIQUE APPROPRIATELY. KILLED
AN INDIVIDUAL DOWN IN THE SAN
DIEGO AREA- AND SO WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE MORE AND MORE
INSTANCES WHERE. THERE NEEDS TO
BE OF GREATER FOCUS. ON THESE
HOW THESE TECHNIQUES ARE USED
DE ESCALATION TECHNIQUES IN THE
LIGHT BECAUSE THEY COME IN
CONTACT WITH THE PUBLIC AS
WELL. AND SO TO HAVE THE PROPER
TRAINING THAT IN SOME INSTANCES
REQUIRE IN PERSON. IS WHAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO ADDRESS BUT
ALSO RECOGNIZING. THAT THE
ONLINE IS A PORTENT- VEHICLE
THAT CAN STILL BE ACCESSED FOR
PEOPLE TO. TO GET THE TRAINING
OFFERED AS WELL. DO YOU HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE GOOD OF THE
STATURE. THE LAST SPEAKER WHO.
MADE REFERENCE TO SOME
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS WE ARE
WORKING. WITH AND THAT JUST
CAME OUT RECENTLY. AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO- GARON'S AROUND ALL
OF THAT BUT I THINK THEY'RE ALL
TECHNICAL AS HE SAID AND WE'RE-
WILL BE COMFORTABLE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT. THE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BYE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SO I'M
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE ARE
MEMBERS THAT YOU AGREE TO AND
BMP AND THAT WILL WORK AS IT
REGIS COMMITTEE TO GONNA THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY HOW COULD NOT I'M
TO THE POINT. THE SAME ISSUES
WERE BROUGHT UP AND THOSE ARE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
TO ADDRESS THE 50% FINALIZATION
AREN'T BURKE SHINO FOR THE
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS- MISTRAL
WHICH ELECT CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. ARE WE WERE SEEKING
A MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED OR
WILL BE AMENDED AND GOING TO
APPROPRIATIONS MOST MOTION BY
SENATOR COM LONGER. COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AB TWO
TWO NINE. AB TWO TO NINE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE CHOI
BOGUE I DROBO GUIDE TERRAZZO
COM LONGER. COME UNDER AYE
SKINNER. SKINNER I. BUDGET
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU WE MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTY TWO WHICH FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY AND ONCE
WE HAVE PREPARED THE PODIUM
WITH PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWO
EIGHTY TWO. LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE BILL
WHICH WAS AB THIRTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM.
THE AUTHORIZED VERSION FOR ALL
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES EXCEPT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE STALKING.
CRIMES THAT WOULD REQUIRE A
PERSON TO REGISTER AS A SEX
OFFENDER. HOWEVER THIS BILL
CREATED AMBIGUITY AND POTENTIAL
CONFLICT WITH SPLIT STATE LAW
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA VEHICLE CODE
SECTION TWENTY THREE SIX FORTY.
ALREADY PROHIBITS DO YOU EYES
AND DELAYS WITH INJURY TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION.
FURTHERMORE THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZED THIS COMPLEX LAST
YEAR SIGNING MESSAGE WHICH HE
STATED HE WANTED TO REVISIT
THIS POLICY AND QUOTE UNQUOTE
EXPLICITLY. HOW DO YOU AYE
CRIMES TO THE INELIGIBLE LIST
FOR DIVERSION. WELL THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. IT EXPLICITLY
PROHIBITS DIY APPROACHES FROM
BEING ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION.
THIS BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIES ANY
AMBIGUITY THAT COULD ARISE WITH
LAST YEAR'S AB THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR THE STATION ALL THE
LIES ARE ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION.
DIVERSION AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
CRIMINAL CONVICTION FOR
OFFENDERS. IT ALLOWS OFFENDERS
TO ESCAPE CONVICTION AVOID JAIL
TIME AND HAVE THE REST RECORDS
RELATED TO THE CRIME HE RACED.
FURTHER ALLOWS DANGEROUS
OFFENDERS TO AVOID LIMITS ON
FIREARMS POSSESSION AND DENIES
VICTIMS COMPENSATION. FOR THEIR
INJURIES OR LOSS. DURING MY
TIME AS A HIGHWAY PATROLMAN I
CAN TELL YOU. THAT THE WHEN YOU
ARRIVE AT THE SCENE OF A
COLLISION THAT INVOLVED A
FATALITY. AND THE DRIVER
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE COLLISION
WAS AN IMPAIRED DRIVER. IT'S A
TRUE TRAGEDY ON ALL ASPECTS. MY
AGE I FELT DISHEARTENED ALSO
FOR THE DRIVER. THEY WERE
UNAWARE OF THE TRUE. DANGER
THEY POSE TO THE PUBLIC.
HARDEST PART IS WHEN YOU HAVE
TO NOTIFY A MEMBER OF THE
FAMILY THAT- THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS NEVER GONE HOME AND I
DID THAT OVER FORTY TIMES
ANYWAYS. DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE. AS PART OF MY LIFE.
AND I CAN'T ERASE THE MEMORIES
THAT I HAVE OF THE TRAGEDY
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS. PROBLEM
IT'S A SERIOUS CRIME MUST BE
TREATED AS SUCH WITH ME TODAY
IS NINA SOLARO MUSSELMAN WITH
CRIMES I'M SORRY WITH CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED AND AMANDA WITH
AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE. WE HAVE A K<c.cyan></c>
LEAD WITNESS ON THE ONLINE.
YEAH THE REPORT OF THE SMOKER
AND ATTENTION AT IT. PLEASE
PROCEED MA'AM. I WANT TO THANK.
THE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF CRIME
VICTIMS OF CALIFORNIA. WHY WE
SUPPORT REHABILITATIVE MEASURES
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE- OFFENDED
AND HURT OTHERS IN SOCIETY WE
ALSO ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS OF
THE COUNT ABILITY AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF NOT ALLOWING
DIVERSIONS FOR UNDER THE
INFLUENCE DRIVERS IS. CRITICAL
TO PUBLIC SAFETY CALIFORNIA HAS
A POINTED OUT BY THE ASSEMBLY
MEANT. DO YOU LIVE PLAGUE OUR
STATE THEY TAKE LIVES STATE
NAME PEOPLE WE- THIS PROCESS IS
GREAT MORE PEOPLE DIE FROM DIY
INJURIES. AND IF WE ALLOW FOR
DIVERSION WE ARE THEN NOT DOING
ANYTHING TO HOLD THOSE
ACCOUNTABLE BUT ALSO TEACH THEM
WHEN SOMEBODY IS CONVICTED OF A
FIRST TIME DUI OFFENSE. THEY
ARE MANDATED TO GO TO DO YOU
AYE SCHOOL THEY ARE MANDATED TO
TAKE VICTIM IMPACT PROGRAMS THE
PROBLEM WITH THE BILL THAT WAS
PASSED THAT ALLOWED PER
DIVERSION. IT DOESN'T STATE
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THESE
OFFENDERS WOULD DO FOR
DIVERSION AND THAT WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO WHOEVER THE
SENTENCING COURT WAS SO COULD
BE VERY WELL AND VERY WELL
MEANING BUT THAT SOMEBODY THAT
HAS COMMITTED A FIRST TIME
OFFENSE UNDER G. WHY WOULD NO
LONGER BE MANDATED TO TAKE THE
VICTIM IMPACT PROGRAM. YOUR
PARTICIPATE IN THE LIVE CALL
PARTICIPATE NAY BECAUSE A LOT
OF THE TRUTH OF THE PROBLEM IS
ADDICTION AND IF WE ALLOW TO
VERSION TWO X. EIGHT ALLOW
PEOPLE TO SKATE PERHAPS
LEARNING FROM THE ABILITY TO
MEASURES THAT WE ARE JUST DOING
A REPETITIVE PROBLEM. THE OTHER
PROBLEM WITH- ALLOWING PER
DIVERSION HAS POINTED OUT. BY
ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY. THE VICTIMS
COMP IN THE VICTIMS WHO WAS
KILLED WHAT YEAR IS INJURE.
THEY HAVE A TO FREE- RECOUP
SOME OF THEIR LOSSES AND IF
DIVERT PEOPLE ADAM. THEM IT
EIGHT FROM THE ABILITY. TO INTO
THE COMED. THE OLD. IT IS
VICTOR. THAT IS HARMED BY
ALLOWING THE CUSTOMER. AS WELL
SAFETY ON THE OF CAL. BECOMES
THE CRIME AND I'M OF CRIME
VICTIMS. I WOULD URGE YOU TO
PASS THE- BILL I'VE NOTICED
GOVERNOR NEWSOM THAT IT NEEDED
TO BE A- ONE THE PATH LAST YEAR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I MA'AM NUMBER MOVE ON A BILL
WE HAVE AN S. LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS- SWIMMER- LACKEY WE
HAVE AMANDA CALLED AROMA. YES
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM
PROCEED. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON AMANDA CALLED RAMA
WITH TRIPLE A TESTIFYING TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO EIGHT TWO.
INCLUDED DIVERSION FOR THOSE
CHARGED WITH DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL OR DRUGS
AB TWO EIGHT TO TAKE THE STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION NOW IS
NOT THE TIME TO RELAX IMPAIRED
DRIVING LAWS. ALCOHOL IMPAIRED
DRIVING CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE
TO ABOUT A THIRD OF ALL VEHICLE
CRASH FATALITIES AND DRUG
IMPAIRED DRIVING IS QUICKLY ON
THE RISE. A VERSION PREVENT
GENERALLY LEAD TO DISMISSAL OF
THE CONNECTION AFTER COMPLETION
OF AN EDUCATION OR TREATMENT
PROGRAM AND CAN PREVENT THE
OFFENSE FROM APPEARING ON
OFFENDERS PUBLIC DRIVING RECORD.
RESEARCH SHOWS FIRST LAND
CONVICTIONS ON DRIVING RECORD
OFTEN DO NOT REFLECT FIRST TIME
OCCURRENCES. AND MANY LOCAL
BIRTH CAN DELAY UNDER ALREADY
HAD EXTENSIVE HISTORY OF
ALCOHOL IMPAIRED DRIVING BY THE
TIME THEY'RE CONSIDERED
DOCUMENTED ON THE PUBLIC
DRIVING RECORDS. ACCORDINGLY
TRIPLE A REJECT ANY PROGRAM
THAT COMMITMENT CARE DRIVING
EVENT TO BE DROPPED FROM THEIR
RECORD. AND THAT'S THE COURTS
AB TWO EIGHT TWO THANK YOU.%
THANK YOU MS FULLER AMOUNT FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO EIGHTY TWO HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE.
SCENOGRAPHER MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. CM. NINE THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OR
VERSUS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO EIGHTY TWO. WILL
BEGIN. IF YOU'D LIKE TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR A BI TO YOU TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
AND IF YOU WERE TO AND PLEASE
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND CHECKING THE LINES ONE
MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LISTEN TO OUR SUPPORT
WITNESSES. ONCE AGAIN THE VOICE
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I AM BEING TOLD BY-
ONE OF MY- PEERS THAT APPEARS
MY SCREEN IS NOT REFRESHING I
ASK YOU A MOMENT- TO WRITE
MYSELF I'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
ONE
TWO EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ADAM
SMITH CHAIR AND MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO EIGHT TWO THANK YOU. PINE
TO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWO EIGHTY FOUR. NOT ABLE
TO HEAR YOU YOU MIGHT BE ON
MUTE. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON THE
LINE TO NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS DONALD ON AIR
FROM EMPOWERING MARGINALIZED
ASIAN COMMUNITIES ARE YOU MAC
AND STOCKTON CALIFORNIA. I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR NINE ZERO
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN
ABOLISHING VIOLENT APPROACHES
TO MENTAL MENTAL HEALTH CRISES
THANK YOU JERRY COMMITTEE. FIND
TWO SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAUL INVOLVED ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION DIY TREATMENT
PROVIDERS AND SUPPORT. WE GO TO
LINE TWO NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ROCKY
ISLAND. YEAH OF THE BLACK
LANGUAGE. HE. WHAT VERSION ACT.
WE HAVE TWO MORE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME JUST MORE EXAMPLES MY
MEMBERS. MISTER MODERATOR IT
SEEMS WE MIGHT HAVE SOME
CONFUSION AS FAR AS THE BILL
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
ADDRESSING WOULD YOU MIND-
CALLING WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
AB. TWO EIGHTY TWO. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWO
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE ONE MESSAGE QUEUING UP
PLEASE ALLOW A MOMENT TO
PROVIDE A LINE NUMBER. WILL I
NUMBER TWO NINETY SIX TWO NINE
SIX YOUR IS A LOT. HOME ALL
RIGHT. MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
LARA NO. NOT GOING. IT WOULD
PROBABLY. YOU GOT TO MR
MODERATOR WIDELY MY THE STATE
THEMSELVES MUTE. YOU. THIRTY
ONE. IF YOU WERE A WITNESS THAT
IS CURRENTLY WE AN OPEN PLEASE
MUTE YOUR YOUR CAUSING SOME
INTERFERENCE OR THE COPS. YOUR
ABILITY. WHAT'S ON YOUR MOVE
WORD- YEAH OKAY I HAVE AN
ISOLATED THAT NOISE PLEASE CAN.
ACCORDING. MISTER MODERATOR PUT
DO WE HAVE ANY MORE WITNESSES-
IN LINE OR WAITING ON Q. FOR
AND IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO
EIGHTY TWO. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE TO
LEAD- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE JOSH WERE PRICE FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA D.
Y. LAWYERS ASSOCIATION. IN
PERSON WE. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOSH FOR
PRICE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
DO YOU AYE LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY TO EIGHTY
TWO UNLESS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
FIRST OFFENSE MISDEMEANOR THE
WIVES. I'M NOT IN SUPPORT OF
THE Y. DRIVERS I'M NOT IN
SUPPORT OF NOT HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
WHAT I AM IN SUPPORT OF IS
GIVING WELL DESERVING
INDIVIDUALS A SECOND
OPPORTUNITY FOR. PEOPLE TO GET
THE TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED TO
TURN THEIR LIVES AROUND RIGHT
THE SHIP SO THEY'RE NEVER BACK
BEFORE THE COURT. IF YOU LOOK
AT THE STATISTICS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THERE IS
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND. REPEAT
DIY OFFENDERS TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND. WE CAN GET THAT
NUMBER TO ZERO OR CLOSE THEIR
TO. IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY WHERE I
PRACTICE WE HAD A TERRIFIC
JUDGE THE LATE HONORABLE ROGER
CROUSE. HE HEADED VETERANS
COURT FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS
THAN HE DID MILITARY MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION FOR OVER SIX
YEARS. OVER 90% OF HIS CASELOAD.
WAS THE WIFE ENTERS YOU KNOW
HOW MUCH RECIDIVISM HE HAD OVER
SIX PLUS YEARS ZERO. PERSONALLY
PRACTICING D. Y. DEFENSE AND
DOING DIVERSION FOR DIY
OFFENDERS FOR OVER SIX YEARS
I'VE HAD ZERO RECIDIVISM. AND
PEOPLE PENAL CODE SECTION ONE
THOUSAND ONE NINETY FIVE PASSED
THIS YEAR THERE IS DISPUTE
AMONG COURTS AT FIFTY WISER
ELIGIBLE BUT IN THOSE COUNTIES
THAT THE WHITES HAVE BEEN
ELIGIBLE THERE'S BEEN ZERO
RECIDIVISM AS FAR AS MY
KNOWLEDGE TODAY. DIVERSION
WORKS AND I THINK THERE'S A BIG
MESS PER DAY MISCONCEPTION THIS
IS FOR MISDEMEANOR FENCES NOT
FELONY THE WHY IS NOT
MANSLAUGHTER D. WHY IS THE
RESULT IN DEATH. OR SERIOUS
INJURY THIS IS MISDEMEANOR
FIRST OFFENSE D. WHY IS. WHERE
PEOPLE ARE SUPPORT ADVERSELY
AFFECTED YOU HAVE ONE OUT OF
FOUR OCCUPATIONS THAT REQUIRE
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE THAT'S A
LICENSING BOARD THEY HAVE THAT
THEY GET PUNISHED BY. YOU HAVE.
DACA RECIPIENTS. THAT WILL BE
DEPORTED NO LONGER ELIGIBLE FOR
DACA ON A FIRST OFFENSE. DUI
CONVICTION. YOU HAVE MILITARY
PEOPLE THAT OTHERWISE DON'T
QUALIFY FOR MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION THAT WOULD QUALIFY
FOR G. JUDICIAL DIVERSION- THAT
MAY GET KICKED OUT OF THE
MILITARY. AND SO IT GIVES THESE
PEOPLE A SECOND OPPORTUNITY AND
JUDGES ARE GOING TO OPEN THE
FLOODGATES HERE OKAY IT IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO GET
SOMEBODY INTO A DIVERSION
PROGRAM. AND AS THE ATTORNEY
YOU WORK WITH THE COURT WITH
THE PROSECUTOR AND SET UP.
THINGS ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT
THEY WOULD DO THE OFFENDER
WOULD DO IF THEY WERE CONVICTED
IN COURT. AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE ALMOST A QUARTER OF FIRST
OFFENDERS REOFFEND EVERY YEAR.
DIVERSION A FULL LOWER THAT
FREE AND I'VE SEEN IT FIRST
HAND. SO SOMEONE GOES INTO
PLEADS GUILTY YES THEY HAVE TO
DO A FIRST CONVICTION PROGRAM
VICTIM IMPACT PANEL PAY A FINE
THEY'RE ON SUMMARY PROBATION NO
OVERSIGHT WITH THE VERSION
OFFERS UP TO TWO YEARS UNDER
THE THUMB. OF A JUDGE. WHERE
DEFENDANTS ARE COMING BEFORE
THE COURT. EVERY THIRTY TO
NINETY DAYS. WRITING LETTERS ON
SELF REFLECTION. DOING
TREATMENT OR WHATEVER THE COURT
ORDERS APPROPRIATE FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL CASE. AND IT
PROVIDES CALIFORNIAN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE SAFER. THAT'S
WHAT IT DOES THERE'S AT LEAST
TEN OTHER STATES OFFER SIMILAR
DIVERSION PROGRAMS FOR A FIRST
OFFENSE D. Y. AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR HERE ON A
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSE GIVE HAVE
FAITH IN THE JUDICIARY AS THE
GATEKEEPERS. TO MAKE THAT
DECISION BECAUSE NOT
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO QUALIFY
FOR DIVERSION ALL RIGHT BUT
THOSE THAT DO SHOULD BE GIVEN
THE CHANCE AT REDEMPTION TO
MAKE OUR STATE SAFER TO EDUCATE
THEM SO THEY CAN TURN THEIR
LIVES AROUND. AND I WOULD ASK
FOR A NAY VOTE ON. EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY TWO. UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
PRICE WE ALSO HAVE ROSE CON
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT
IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER
AND SHE I BELIEVE SHOULD BE
ONLINE MODERATOR. YES AND HERE.
MY NAME IS ROSE CON AND I'M A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER
RIGHT DIRECTOR WORK AT THE
INTERSECTION OF CRIMINAL ON
IMMIGRATION LAW. WE HAVE BEEN
DEEPLY ENCOURAGED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE CONSISTENT
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF EXPANDING OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
CREE CREE DIVERSION
UNDERSTANDING THAT TREATMENT
NOT CAGES ARE ESSENTIAL TO
APPROVING THE CAUSES OF
CRIMINAL CONDUCT. ENDING THE
CYCLE OF HARM AND IMPROVING
PUBLIC SAFETY. THIS CELL WHICH
WOULD LIMIT A JUDGE'S
DISCRETION TO GRANT DIVERSION
IS THE MOVE IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION FOR MANY REASONS. BUT
I CALLING TODAY TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE DAMAGE
THIS BILL WILL COST AND THEN.
THIS ISSUE IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
HOLDS OVER A QUARTER OF THE
COUNTRY IMMIGRANT POPULATION
AND OVER A QUARTER OF THE
COUNTRY DACA APPLICANTS. I
THINK HUNDRED INSIDE
CONVICTIONS ARE TREATED
PARTICULARLY HARSHLY UNDER
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION. FOR
EXAMPLE. DACA IS BARRED THEY
HAVE A SINGLE E. Y. CONVICTION
ON THEIR RECORD SIMILARLY A
LONGTIME GREEN CARD HOLDERS
SEEKING TO OBTAIN U. S.
CITIZENSHIP WILL BE BARRED FROM
DOING SO IF THEY WERE TWICE
CONVICTED OF THE D. Y. WITHIN
THE PAST TEN YEARS. UNDER
CURRENT. DIVERSION PROGRAMS
ALLOW IMMIGRANTS TO ACCESS
NECESSARY TREATMENT WHILE
PROVIDING A MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESERVE
ELIGIBILITY FOR SOME FUTURE
FORM OF IMMIGRATION EIGHT. IF
THE CURRENT LAW IS AMENDED SO
THAT INDIVIDUAL CHARGE NOT
CONVICTED YOU Y. OFFENSIVE
CANNOT ACCESS BY VERSION
NONCITIZEN DEFENDANTS WILL HAVE
NO IMPACT IT SHOULD. BE AND
WILL INSTEAD HAVE EVERY
INCENTIVE TO TAKE THEIR CASE TO
TRIAL BY THE CHANCE OF A
DEPLORABLE CONVICTION COSTING
THE STATE MORE MONEY ONE TIME.
RIGHT HOW CAL WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO GRANT BY VERSION A
JUDGE DECLINE TO A DIVERSION
AND OR TO GRANT ALL BASED ON
THEIR INDIVIDUAL ASSESSMENT.
LUXURY THE CASE BY CASE
JUDICIAL ECONOMY THAT IS SO
ESSENTIAL. AND AVOID ADOPTING
HARMFUL BRIGHTLINE PROBATION.
PLEASE VOTE NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WILL WILL GO TO
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM ARE
THERE WITNESSES HERE IN THE
ROOM WHEN HE XIN TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO EIGHT TWO.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. HI MY NAME IS LINDA
AROUND LIKE AND I'M A CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEY- FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA. I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB TWO EIGHTY TWO UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED. AB TWO READY TO
PROPOSES TO ELIMINATE THE Y.
CASES FROM CONSIDERATION FOR
MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION THE
AMENDMENT WHICH IS A WELL
REASONED APPROACH WOULD ALLOW
CONSIDERATION A DIVERSION FOR
FIRST TIME D. Y. CASES IN VERY
LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES GIVE THE
JUDICIARY TREMENDOUS LEEWAY IN
TERMS OF THEIR ANALYSIS OF WHO
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE AND WHO
WOULD NOT. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FIRST TIME DO YOU LIVE IN IS
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
FELONIES WERE CAUGHT NOT
TALKING ABOUT MAN'S EYES WERE
NOT TALKING ABOUT. THANK YOU.
IS THAT IT YES WE'RE BACK WE
ARE PRIMARY WITNESSES ON THE
CAR AND I CORRECT WE ARE HERE
PRIMARILY WITH THIS I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWO A TWO. C. NINE WILL GO TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S NO
ONE THERE AS WELL NOW MODERATOR
WILL GO TO OUR PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWO EIGHT TWO. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
EIGHT TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE A
TOTAL OF SEVEN IN Q. WE WILL GO
FIRST TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN TWO ONE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN'T BE
SURE OF HER ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION- IN OPPOSITION. NUMBER
ONE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO THAT'S ONE FIVE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND NINETY ONE NINE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BANNEKER A DARN
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER IN OPPOSITION.
FOR THE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ALL FOR FUTURE
FISCAL LOOSENING IN OPPOSITION.
BUT A LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE ONE SEVEN NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
SERRA REGNI ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
NINE ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT ONE EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE I AM TWO HUNDRED
NINETY THREE TWO NINE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DARGER TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS AND- CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. AND A
FINAL WARNING TO HIS LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FOUR TWO SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS SUSAN
MUSSELMAN ATTORNEY IN NEVADA
CITY I'M STRONGLY OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. SENATE MODERATES YOU
HAVE ONE LATECOMER THAT'S JUST
WE DO HAVE ONE ONLY COVER THAT
JUST POPPED IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
ALLOW US A MOMENT TO VITAL LINE
NUMBER. RIGHT THANK YOU. LITTLE
I NUMBER. TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE THAT'S TWO SEVEN
ONE. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JAY BASKET ON THE
HEALTH COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE OPPOSE. Q.
AND WE HAVE EXHAUSTED ALL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES THANK YOU WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BUT IT'S
COMING. RELATES TO. HE TO A TWO.
SENATE SKINNER- I KNOW THE
ASSEMBLY WERE LUCKY LUCKY YOU
CITED A REFERENCE- FROM THE
GOVERNOR AROUND- MAYBE IT WAS A
VETO MESSAGE I'M NOT SURE- NO
NOT AS APPROVAL- IS AN APPROVAL
WHERE OKAY- HOWEVER WE'VE ALSO
GOT COURT CASES THAT INDICATE
WE HAVE TO THAT WE. WHEN WE
MAKE CHANGES TO THE PENAL CODE
INTO CERTAIN ALLOWING FOR
DIVERSION FOR CERTAIN PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE TO APPLY IT FAIRLY
AND THAT WE HAVE A- I SHOULD
READ DIRECTLY FROM THE HOUSES
ANYWAY. AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
CONFRONTED IN THE PAST
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE. WE HAVE
MADE EXCLUSIONS THAT WERE THEN
RULED TO BE NOT A FEAR
APPLICATION. AND SO. THERE THAT
ASPECT OF THE- ANALYSIS. MADE A
LOT OF SENSE TO ME BUT IN
ADDITION THOSE WITNESSES WHO
TALKED ABOUT THE ABILITY FOR
THE DIVERSION PROGRAMS TO. NOT
ONLY MONITOR THE PERSON BUT TO
ALSO IN EFFECT BE MORE
PRESCRIPTIVE IN TERMS OF THE-
PROGRAMMING AND OTHER
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY DO TO
ADDRESS THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
LED. TO THE D. Y. N. IS. WELL
NOT EVERY D. WHY IS SOMEONE WHO
IS AN ALCOHOLIC IS VERY
COMMONLY AND ALCOHOLISM AS WE
KNOW IS NOT SOMETHING THAT FOR
MANY PEOPLE WHO SUFFER FROM
THAT IT IS NOT AN EASY. IT'S AN
EASY THING TO OVERCOME AND SO
WELL I DO NOT WANT. I DO NOT
WANT DRUNK DRIVERS AND I DO NOT
WANT THE CONSEQUENCES OF DRUNK
DRIVERS BUT I THINK THAT WE'VE
SEEN THAT THE DIVERSION
PROGRAMS CAN SOMETIMES RESULT
IN BETTER OUTCOMES. IN TERMS OF
ACTUALLY- REDUCING THE END IN
THE NUMBER OF DRUNK DRIVERS AND
THE INTERESTING THING I FOUND
IS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
INCREASING. A LOT OF OUR
PENALTIES TOWARDS DRUNK DRIVING
WHICH AGAIN IS NOT NECESSARILY
A BAD THING AND YET WE'VE OVER
TWENTY TWO YEARS. ONLY SEEN A
4% DROP. IN IN THE INCIDENCE OF
THE WHITES. I'VE NOT YET SEEN
ANY KIND OF STUDY THAT SHOWS
THAT THE DIVERSIONS ARE LESS
EFFECTVE IN TERMS OF THE
REDUCTION OF THE D. WEISS. AND
THERE IS IT WE OBVIOUSLY NEED
MORE DATA TO FULLY UNDERSTAND
IT BUT THERE'S SOME INDICATION
THAT SOME OF THE DIVERSION
PROGRAMS ARE MORE EFFECTIVE SO
I AM NOT COMFORTABLE WITH THE
BILL IN THE WAY THAT IT'S
STRUCTURED- SO WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT AS AS- AN-
AS WRITTEN TODAY. AT YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS VIA COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO. I TO- SOON MARK YOU HAVE
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO THE
RIVER DIVERSION SPECIALLY FOR
FIRST TIME OFFENDERS AND
MISDEMEANORS I THINK- FIRST
CALLING FROM BERKELEY. CLEARLY
STATED- THE BENEFITS THAT HAVE
BEEN SHOWN BY OFFERING SUCH
DIVERSION PROGRAMS AND ARE
GIVING PEOPLE OPPORTUNITY TO-
CHANGE REALIZE VERSUS LOSING
THEIR LICENSE OR GOING TO JAIL
AND I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
THE- FLEXIBILITY THAT HAS BEEN
IN EXISTENCE FOR QUITE SOME
TIME- FOR THE FOR THE
MISDEMEANOR FIRST ON FENCES SO.
I TO HAVE CHALLENGES SO WE
OFFERED UP SOME AMENDMENTS IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU'RE
NOT TAKING THE MOMENTS ARE NOT
CORRECT YOU ARE CORRECT. OKAY
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT SO THAT
THE TO CLOSE YEAH WITHOUT.
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE YOU MAY CLOSE.
FIRST OF ALL- I WANT TO TAKE A
THE COMMITTEE WITH OLDER SOME
HARSH DISAGREEMENT THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC. THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE'S
LIVES. AND WHETHER YOU ACCEPT
OR REJECT THE FACT THAT THE
ALLIES ARE AS DANGEROUS AS I
CLAIM THEY ARE. DOESN'T CHANGE
THE FACT THAT THERE WILL BE
LIVES LOST EVEN TODAY AS WE
SPEAK BECAUSE OF AN IMPAIRED
DRIVER. SPEAKING OF SENATOR
SKINNER TO YOUR POINT. I WOULD
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT AWARENESS OF
THE PROBLEM IS THIS PART OF THE
IMPORTANT REMEDY TO TAKE CARE
OF THE PROBLEM AND TO ADDRESS
APPROPRIATELY NO MATTER WHAT
LEGISLATION WE PASSED HERE
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE IMPAIRED
DRIVING BY THE VERY NATURE OF
ALCOHOL. THE GOAL IS TO LIMIT
THOSE THOSE TRAGEDIES. AND I
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL CLEARLY.
DO THAT AND THE REASON WHY WILL
DO IT IS BECAUSE IT WILL. EIGHT
AWARENESS DIVERSION DIMINISHES
AWARENESS OF THIS PROBLEM
BECAUSE IT RACES AT- AND THAT
THE AMENDMENT FIRST OF ALL THE
FIRST TIME CONVICTION IS JUST
AS DANGEROUS AS THE SECOND OR
THIRD. AND I WOULD SAY THAT-
IT'S TRAGIC IT'S ABSOLUTELY
TRAGIC THE SERIOUSNESS OF DIY
AND I KNOW THAT BECAUSE MANY OF
US HAVE FRIENDS WHO PROBABLY.
BY LATE THIS LAW AND THEY'VE
NEVER HAD THERE BEEN ANY KIND
OF NEGATIVE ENCOUNTER. BUT I
PROMISE YOU IT'S LIKE. A
RUSSIAN ROULETTE EVENTUALLY THE
BULLETS GOING TO SHOW UP. AT
IT'S VERY TRAGIC WHEN IT DOES
NOT WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT I
COME FROM A PLACE OF NOT.
GETTING ANY INCITEMENT ABOUT.
TAKEN SOMEBODY INTO CUSTODY
IT'S A COMPASSIONATE MOVE
BECAUSE I WILL TELL YOU. THE
NUMBER OF THOSE DO YOU AYE
TRAGEDIES OFTEN WERE SOLO
COLLISIONS. SO GUESS WHO THE
VICTIM WAS WAS ALSO THE
PERPETRATOR OF THE PROBLEM. AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO GO OUT AND
GET TO THE NATURE OF THE
PROBLEM WHICH IS AWARENESS. AND
WE DIMINISH AWARENESS WE DID
MANAGE OUR ABILITY TO ADDRESS.
THIS PROBLEM FOR WHAT IT TRULY
TRULY IS NOT A TRAGIC TRAGIC
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES THAT- I
MEAN IT'S LIKE SHOOTING A
WEAPON INTO A GATHERING OF
PEOPLE AND HOPE THAT THE BALL
IT DOESN'T HIT. THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH FOLKS
AND I'M TRYING TO BRING REMEDY
TO THIS PROBLEM AND I HOPE I
GET YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE SEEKING A
MOTION ON. AB TWO EIGHT TWO THE
MOVED IT IS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR REPORT THE TROUBLE-
THERE IS A- TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I BELIEVE IT'S
JUST TO PASS JUST TO PASS TO
CARE- CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AB TWO EIGHTY TWO D.
PASSED BRADFORD NO READ FOR NOW
WHICH- BUG I TROUBLE GUY DURAZO
CRIME LONGER. KAMLAGER NO
SKINNER OR FOODIE SKINNER NOT
VOTING. THE ROLE OPEN AND SHOE
PHONE WELL. HELPFULLY THE ROLE
OF MARKUPS MEMBERS THANK YOU.
SLASH RECOVERY YOU CAN ANSWERED
RECONSIDERATION FOR SURE THANK
YOU. NEXT UP IS SOMEONE GIPSON
AFTER WE DO OUR FLAWS GIVEN
WILL ALLOW MR GIPSON TO MAKE
HIS PRESENTATION. FOR THE
REGULAR FELLOW. IS. COMMITTEE
CRITICS YEAH. IN TERMS GIPSON.
AB FOUR NINETY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR NINETY MY NAME TO THE
ANGELO KITTLES LOFT TO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE WHICH SEEKS TO BAN
LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM USING.
RESTRAINTS. THE CALLS
POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA. POSITIONAL
ASPHYXIA IS A DEADLY CONDITION.
THAT CAN OCCUR WHEN A PERSON IS
RESTRAINED AND CANNOT BREED.
AFTER THE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOOR
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED LANDMARK
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN NINETY SIX TO BANLAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM USING CHILL
CALLS. THE OFFICER WHO KNEELED
ON FLOYD'S NECK DID SO FOR MORE
THAN NINE MINUTES. AND TWENTY
EIGHT SECONDS. UNTIL HIS BODY
LAID LIFELESS. BUT ALSO IN
DECEMBER. BUT LAST YEAR AND
LOOKING TO. BY UNITED STATES
NAVY MEANT FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WHAT'S ALSO
TRAGICALLY KILLED AT THE HANDS
OF POLICE. ANGELO HAD BEEN
SUFFERING FROM A MENTAL HEALTH
EPISODE. WITH HIS FAMILY CALLED
THE POLICE FOR HELP. IN ORDER
TO DE ESCALATE THE SITUATION
THAT WAS TAKING PLACE AT HOME.
WELL ANGELO LAID FACE DOWN.
BLOODY HANDCUFFS BEHIND HIS
BACK. RESPONDING OFFICERS MEALS
ON ANGELO'S NECK. NEARLY FIVE
MINUTES. ANGELO SAID PLEASE
DON'T KILL ME. PLEASE DON'T
KILL ME. CASUAL LOS.
CONSCIOUSNESS. AND DIED FOUR
DAYS LATER AT THE HOSPITAL.
ASSEMBLY WITNESSED THIS
HORRIFIC TRAGEDY NO FAMILY.
EVER HAVE TO EXPERIENCE THIS
TRAGEDY GEORGE VOIGTS SAID I
CAN'T BREATHE. HE SAID THIS
TWENTY EIGHT TIMES. ANGELO KATO
SAID PLEASE DON'T KILL ME
PLEASE DON'T KILL ME. THIS IS
NOT ABOUT BLANKS. IT'S NOT
ABOUT TWO WEEKS. IT'S NOT ABOUT
SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS THIS. THIS
IS ABOUT LIVES. THERE ARE BEING
TAKEN AWAY OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL CONTINUES TO STATE THAT
THIS BILL REMOVES AN OFFICER'S
ABILITY. AND I WANT TO QUOTE.
FROM ONCE. RESTRAINING BUT
INDIVIDUAL LET ME SIMPLY SAY
THAT'S NOT TRUE. YOU CAN STILL
RESTRAIN AN INDIVIDUAL WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IT SAYS YOU
CANNOT CUT SOMEONE'S ABILITY TO
BRIEF. NO ONE SHOULD HAVE THAT
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM WHILE IN
CUSTODY. IT STATES THAT NGUYEN
PRESSURE OR BODY WEIGHT IS
BEING PLACED ON SOMEONE AND
UNDER REASONABLE POSITION. IT
CUTS OFF SOME OF THE BILITY TO
BRIEF. THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED AND
LOOKING SO. THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED TO GEORGE FLOORED LET
ME BE CLEAR THIS MEANS THAT YOU
CAN NOT YOU CAN NO LONGER. JEFF
CUT OFF SOMEONE'S EAR WAY
WITHOUT CARING. FOR THEM YOU
CANNOT CUT SOMEONE'S ABILITY TO
BREED OFF YOU CAN STILL ARREST
HIM YOU CAN STILL DETAINED THEM.
BUT NOT CUT SOMEONE'S ABILITY
TO BREATHE AB FOUR NINETY THE
COMMONSENSE POLICY. THAT IS
NEEDED NOW TO CLOSE A LEGAL
LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW USING.
THE USE OF FORCE THAT HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. IT WILL PLACE A LIMIT ON
RESTRAINTS USED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ENSURE THAT
THESE RESTRAINTS DO NOT TURN TO
BE UNNECESSARILY DANGEROUS AND
DEADLY. WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. IS THE
MOTHER OF ANGELO KATO CENTER
KATO COLLINS. WHO WILL JOIN ME
WHO WILL BE JOINED BY THE
DAUGHTER OR THE SYSTEM
ESSENTIAL KETO BELLA. IT ALSO
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APPLE TO ASSOCIATION WHO WAS
SELF INTRODUCED MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. BECAUSE
YOUR FIRST PRIMARY WITNESS
AVAILABLE. RECALLING ROBERT- TO
SANDRA. SANDRA. YES. YES HEAR
ME DISCUSS LOOKING AND WE CAN
HEAR YOU. YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
BRADFORD AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FUNDED BEGIN WOULD LIKE TO
THINK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
REGION TO SEE THIS BILL. MY
NAME'S CASSANDRA CAN COOK
COLIN. AND I'M ON THE LINE WITH
MY DAUGHTER BAY. WE ARE THE
MOTHER AND SISTER OKAY ANGELA.
NUMBER TWENTY THIRD OF TWENTY
TWENTY ANGELES PRINTING AMENTO
HEALTH CRISIS. MY DAUGHTER
CALLED NINE ONE ONE SEEKING
HELP. RIGHT IT CALM DOWN AND I
WAS ABLE TO RESTRAIN HIM IN A
BEAR HUG ON THE FLOOR. RIGHT
THIS. GREASY MONEY I'M NOT
GOING TO FOR ONE OFFICER WILL
BE. TO GIVE IT BACK THE
OVERHEAD COOKING HIM. LEANING
ON THE BACK OF HIS NECK.
BROWN'S LEONINE HEARD SOMETHING
AKIN TO THIS IS WHAT WE DO TO
CALM THEM DOWN. THE OFFICERS
BEGIN TO ONLY WITH MYSELF AND
LEAD AND WITH EACH OTHER. IT'S
NOT LETTING THE ANGELA WAS
EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
EMERGENCY. AT ONE POINT THE
OFFICER KNEELING ON HIM WHAT'S
RIPLEY. WAIT ANOTHER TWENTY IN
THE POSITION. THE LAST FOUR AND
A HALF MINUTES THIS RESTRAINT.
ANGELO WHAT'S ON RESPONSIVE AND
WOULD NEVER REGAINED
CONSCIOUSNESS OR THE ABILITY TO
BREED ALONE. EVEN NEEDED I THE
TAPE SHOT. ALL THREE SHOULD THE
SPOKEN TO AND DOES NOT PRACTICE
THEIR RELATIONS. IN MEMBER
RESTORED IT. RESTRICTING THE
BILL. TO ESPECIALLY BECAUSE-
ANGELA NOT BIO I HAD NO WEAPON
AND WHAT'S NOT KNOWN TO BE
UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF ANY
CARBON. WELCOME TO YOU. TODAY
WAS ON BEHALF OF GRANULAR AT
FOR A POLICY THAT COULD VERY
WELL SAVE HIS AND MANY OTHER
GâY. CHARLIE BELIEVE THAT
RESTRICTING CHRISTINE SHOULD
NOT BE ACCEPTABLE METHOD OF. OR
THEM. I ARE YOU QUITE A BIT
NINETY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DO WE ALSO HAVE BRIAN HALL.
CHECKING IN ATTENDANCE ONE
MOMENT PLACE. THEY'RE NOT ON
THE TELEPHONY AT THIS TIME SIR
ON RAP ALL RIGHT. SOMEONE ELSE
ONLINE THE CALIFORNIA FACT
ASSOCIATION. WHILE WE'RE
WAITING. AWAITING WE'LL COME TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE YEARS OR ANYONE HERE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
NINETY. SHE NINE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOMS ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS
WELL. WE'LL GO BACK TO
MODERATOR OF WAITING. FOR DO
NOT SHOW ANYBODY ACTIVE FOR
THAT- FOR THAT LINE APPARENTLY
BEEN MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT STATING
NAME AND ONLY IN THEIR
POSITION- AN ORGANIZATION ON
THE TELEPHONE LINES WOULD LIKE
TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE I'M GETTING SAID
SOME OTHER INFORMATION ONE
SECOND PLEASE.
OKAY APPEARS
THAT WE- WE HAD- THE ARE KEY
WITNESS WAS NOT IN THE- TALK
STATE SO I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING
TO TRY TO GO TO THEIR LINE NOW.
CURRENTLY HAVE A MINUTE AND A
HALF. IN SUPPORT. AB. ELEVEN
NINETY ONE. NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY. THANK YOU. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RON ROB SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AS A CO SPONSOR OF
AB FOUR NINETY I DO APOLOGIZE I
TRIED TO CALL IN ON THE MAIN
WITNESS LINE AND WAS
UNSUCCESSFUL SO I HAD TO USE
THE ALTERNATIVE- WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS OVER
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND FACULTY
INCLUDING TENURE TRACK
PROFESSORS LIBRARIANS
COUNSELORS AND COACHES FROM ALL
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. ONE OF OUR MAIN
PRIORITY DOES THE ORGANIZATION
IS RACIAL AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT
REFORM WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THAT WILL CREATE A UNIFORM
STATEWIDE POLICY- POSITIONAL
ASPHYXIA RESTRAINT WHICH
ENCOMPASSES THE NEEDED NEXT
TECHNIQUE TO ENSURE THAT THEY
THEY CAN NO LONGER BE
IMPROPERLY APPLIED ON
CALIFORNIANS. IN CUSTODY DEATH
IS ONE OF THE GREAT TRAGEDY THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON CAUSES IS POSITIONAL
ASPHYXIA PROVISIONAL ACT ACT
SIXTY IT IS WHAT LED TO THE
DEATH OF ANGELO QUINTO AND
GEORGE BOYD WHILE IN CUSTODY
CUSTODY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT LAST
YEAR THANKS TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON AND HIS AUTHORSHIP OF
BABY ELEVEN NINETY SIX IN
TWENTY TWENTY CURRENT LAW
PROHIBITS LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
USING ANY TYPE OF CHOKEHOLD
INCLUDING. THE THEY- GUARANTEED
RESTRAINT BUT IT DOES NOT
EXPLICITLY ADDRESS USING A
PERSONAL BODY WEAPON LIKE A
NEON AS SUSPECT KNACK AB FOUR
NINETY WILL MAKE THIS
CLARIFICATION IN EXISTING LAW
YES THEY BELIEVE THE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS A UNIFORM STATEWIDE
POLICY- POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA
RESTRAINT WHICH ENCOMPASSES THE
NEED ENACT TECHNIQUES TO ENSURE
THAT THEY CAN NO LONGER BE
IMPROPERLY APPLIED ON THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S FOR
THESE REASONS CFA IS PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR AB. FOR NINETY AND
WE'RE AT REQUEST YOUR AIBO ON
THE IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MODERATOR NOW LET'S GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES IN THIRD
WOULDN'T WHO ARE WISHING TO
SPEAK SPEAK SUPPORT AB. FOUR
NINETY. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO A LINE OF RON RAFFERTY
THERE. COOPERATIVE IT BOUGHT OR
USED AGAIN. TESTIFIED AT THE
MAIN WITNESS. HELLO YES. I
JUST- IDENTIFIED AS THE MAIN
WITNESS THIS IS RON ROUTE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OPPOSES CONSERVE A
BEFORE NINETY WE GOT IT THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR OTHER
WITNESSES WHO ARE WILLING OR
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
WE WILL STATE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION- YES SIR. WE HAVE
CURRENTLY THIRTY FOUR IN THE
QUEUE AS A REMINDER IT IS ONE
ZERO TO PUT YOURSELF IN THE
QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX THAT'S ONE NINE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHEN MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON
TOP OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. EXHORT A LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY THAT'S
TWO SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
MARTIN RIAZ IMAGE ON BEHALF OF
THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
AND SUPPORT. BY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE TWO FIVE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
LOCAL AUTO AND A VOLUNTEER WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE CALLING IN SUPPORT. FIND
ONE THIRTY ONE ONE THREE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS ERIC
HARRIS WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
BLIND ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE ONE SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
SERRA RAKING ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE DIRECTED TO TRANSPORT.
NINE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
TWO SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE KIANA
BUNDY HAPPENS EVERY TOWN FOR
GUN SAFETY AND SUPPORT. FIND
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN THREE
ONE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CANDY AND I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BE
CONSOLIDATED COLLECTED. IN SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA OUR
ORGANIZATION IS OVER FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN COMMUNITIES WERE BUILT
WE BUILD. IN POLITICS
INTERSECTIONAL ME WITH BLACK
BROWN AND INDIGENOUS FOLK
PEOPLE GOOD BUDDY QUEER AND
TRANS PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND
WOMEN ORGANIZATION PLEASE. AS
ARE THERE TO COLLECT. ARE LARGE
OR THE NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
PLEASE ONE MODERATOR WE'RE JUST
TAKING NAME AN ORGANIZATION AT
THIS TIME AND POSITION. WE'LL
GO AYE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE TWO FIVE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU THANK YOU IN
FACT HEARD IN COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JOSIE CAMACHO. ON THE FIRST
FLIGHT PRESIDENT OF THE ASIAN.
AMERICAN LABOR ALLIANCE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY. WE ARE THE ONLY
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF THE
UNION MEMBERS AND COMMUNITY
ALLIES. THERE ARE SOME IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHO SUFFER FROM WARM
BUT ONE DAY. HOW WITH PROPER
CARE COURTS WE NO HAT THEY CAN
LIVE COULD. WITH THAT. THANK IS
THE STORY OF THAT JONES WHO HAD
NOT AND GET. NOTHING CARE
PROVIDE BY A FAMILY. BUT THEM
ONE DAY. SIR WE WORRIED PRIME
TESTER WE JUST NEED NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE THIRTY WITNESSES IN Q.
WISHING TO SPEAK. SORRY SIR MY
NAME IS JOSIE CAMACHO FIRST
VICE PRESIDENT OF ASIA PACIFIC
EXTEND MY CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELL I NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
THREE THREE ZERO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ANGELICA CORD HAS
THAT LEAD TO LOOK YOU KNOW AND
THE JUSTICE FOR ANGELO KETO
COALITION STANDING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
THANK YOU. Q. GROWING NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO ONE
FIVE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. IN SUPPORT. HELLO
I NUMBER TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT TWO EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GABRIEL
YOUNG FROM THE FILIPINO SAN
JOSE AND FROM THE FIERCE
COLLISION CENTER TRANSLOCATION.
AND CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR NINETY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU COMMITTEE ONE CHAIR.
BUT I NUMBER TWO HUNDRED NINETY
TWO TWO NINE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS KELLY CALLING
HER AND I AM STANDING WITH THE
STATE WHY FOR ENJOY KEEP TRYING
THIS IS ALL COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
THANK YOU CHAIRED BRADFORD
INCLUDING MEMBERS TODAY. BUT A
LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
THAT'S THREE ZERO ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DONALD ON AIR
WITH EMPOWERING MARGINALIZED
ASIAN COMMUNITIES IN STOCK IN
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF
AB FOUR NINE ZERO THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX ONE THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS ALEX YEAH I
KNOW I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB FOR-
NINETY- ONE NOTHING WILL BRING
BACK ANGELO OR- YEAH ANGELOS-
OUR COALITION WANTS TO ENSURE
HAT NO OTHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS
LAW IT NEEDS NECOLE. THANK YOU.
PRIME ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN POP NATIONAL GUARD
STATION A SOCIAL WORKER
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IMPLEMENT
THANK YOU. HELLO I NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE TWO
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS MARY AND I'M WITH
THE UNITED NATIONS YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S PRODUCTIVE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY THANK YOU. SO I NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
TWO SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I AM JENNIFER DORADO AND
I'M A HIGH SCHOOL WHERE AN
INTERN WITH FILIPINO ADVOCATES
FOR JUSTICE IN STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
THANK YOU. WHAT DO I NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE ONE
FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CAROL
ROGERS I'M OF GUN VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR AND VOLUNTEER WITH THE
PROVIDER NETWORK AND MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE.
REPORT OF AB FOUR. BUT A LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE ONE EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DEANNA
CONSEQUENCES- AMMAN AND JOKING
ALL AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY THANK YOU.
PINE TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SEVEN TWO EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME'S THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF FILIPINO ADVOCATES
FOR JUSTICE FAITH IN UNION CITY
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE NINETY THANK YOU. NINE
TWO HUNDRED NINETY NINE TWO
NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MANAGED TO THE LARGE-
BUILDING ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE
MASON UNION CITY CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY THANK YOU. PINE TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR TWO NINE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS TERRENCE MAGNO CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR NINETY- MY
LITTLE BROTHER WAS PREVIOUSLY.
PROFILED BY POLICE AND COULD
HAVE ESCALATED MORE SO I'M
CALLING. IN SUPPORT OF THIS- OF
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY THANK YOU.
NINE THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN THREE TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE THREE TWO SEVEN
WE'RE CHECKER LINE FOR SELF
MUTE. HEARING A RESPONSE WILL
GO LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO THREE THREE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN.NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO PLEASE
CHECK YOURSELF FOR SELF MUTE.
BERMAN BONTA LINE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE THREE ONE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS STAND TO LOSE OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. BUT A LINE
ONE HUNDRED NINE ONE ZERO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
CATHERINE WADE- MY SON WAS. A
VICTIM OF POLICE BRUTALITY IN
ANTIOCH CALIFORNIA THE OFFICER
HEADED ME IN HIS NECK AND I SEE
HERE LOOK AT THE PICTURES
TODAY. OF THE B. ME AND MY
SON'S NECK. AND IT IS THIS.
WHOLE THE WAY THESE OFF OF THE
VIEWS BECAUSE THIS POSITION
TODAY HARD PEOPLE AND KILL
PEOPLE FARM IN STRONG. SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. HELLO
I'M THREE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
THREE ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS AMY I AM A NUMBER
OF ASIAN QUALITY CONTENT
ONLINE. SORRY OF THE COMMISSION
ON SAN DIEGO. I'M GOING TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT NINETY YEAH.
HELLO I NUMBERS HUNDRED ELEVEN
ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
I'M DAISY MAXIMUM ABILITY TO
ADVOCATE FOR THAT. COALITION
OAKLAND- CALLING AT THE PORT OF
THE FOUR NINETY. NO POINT THREE
HUNDRED AND FIVE THREE ZERO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SORRY I
LET ME MAKE. IT SIMPLE CLINTON
UNION CITY JUST FRAGILE. THANK
YOU DONE THE RIGHT SIDE OF.
ANGELA INTO APPLE. LAYDOWN
MARKS WHAT DO YOU. FIVE JUST A
MOMENT CAN TRY TO ISOLATE THAT
ONE WE WORKS MOMENT. TO WE NEED
TO SET UP AN MODEL. WHAT. THEY
REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM THE
QUEUE IT APPEARS WITH A LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE TWO SEVEN FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CAN CARBONELL. PARRY
MARCH NINTH EIGHTEEN
COMMUNITIES AND THE TWO OH NINE
API CORRELATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR NINETY THANK
YOU. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT THREE THREE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BRUCE
JOSH IT TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
PINE THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE THREE THREE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
BRADFORD COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ROBERT COLLINS AND YOU'RE
LOOKING TO SAYS THAT. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR NINETY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE THREE
FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS PLAYING IN THE
TAIL I'M HERE WITH THIRTEEN X.
ADVOCATE FOR JUSTICE AND I'LL
QUOTE THE COR EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY. FIND THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. H THIS IS JOSH ARE
YOU LOOK CALLING FROM ASIAN
SOLIDARITY COLLECTIVE BASED OUT
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY. PRIME
MEMBERS THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO THREE FOUR TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ALEXANDER
MO HARD WITH FILIPINO ADVOCATES
FOR JUSTICE BASED IN OAKLAND
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB FOUR NINETY THANK
YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE MORE THAT CHESTER
QUEUING UP SO I'M GONNA GIVE
THEM THEIR LINE NUMBERS WILL
HAVE THE MOMENTARILY. THE FIRST
ONE IS LINE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR THREE
FOUR FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
AM CALLING AGAIN MY NAME IS
ISRAEL- WITH FILIPINO ADVOCATES
FOR JUSTICE AND OAKLAND. AND
UNION CITY JUSTICE FOR ANGELO
COALITION ANSWER COALITION
THAT'S BE ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY. AND YOU'RE LOOKING TO
ACT NOW EIGHTY FOUR RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. IN ORDER TO LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
THREE TWO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THREE TWO THREE WE
CHECK CAROLINE FOR SELF MUTE
WE'RE HEARING AUDIO YES. MY
NAME IS COMMON. I DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING. IF YOU I THINK UNDER
IN ASKING I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
ADVOCATE WORKING FOR THE NUMBER
OF OUR PEOPLE I'M CALLING IN.
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY. THE MARKET-COMMUNITY THE COLOR THAT OVER
COOLEY BEING. I'M AND WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE THE EXAM
OF THE KEY OF THOSE SUPPORT
OKAY GREAT. NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I SEE THERE'S NO
LEAD. ITNESS IN OPPOSITION OR
OR AT LEAST LISTED IN
OPPOSITION- THERE ANYONE HERE
AND FORTY TWO OH THREE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR NINETY.
C. NINE WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE THERE IN
TWENTY FOUR THE FORTY EITHER.
MODERATOR WILL YOU QUEUE THE
PHONE LINES AND SEE IF THERE
ARE MEMBERS WHO ARE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
FOUR NINETY. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBERS THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THREE ONE SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IN TURN MEMBERS YOU
SHAUN MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS AND- WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN THREE ONE SEVEN. YOUR.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
PROCEED. ONE OF. ONE OF THE
PORTS- FOUR NINETY. YEAH THANK
YOU FOUR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT B. TWO IS COMING
TO AN END OKAY WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS HERE ARE
REGARDING AB FOR NINETY CENTER
SKINNER. I WILL MOVE THE BILL
HI- THANK YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF
FRIENDS WHO ARE VERY CLOSE TO
THE- KING TO A FAMILY AND WAS
MADE AWARE OF THIS INCIDENT
WITHIN A FEW DAYS OF ITS
OCCURRENCE- AND IT WAS TRULY
HORRIFIC I MEAN THAT. THE ME
BEFORE I SAY MORE. THIS BILL IS
NEEDED INDEPENDENT OF THE
HORRIBLE TRAGEDY THAT THE KING
TO FAMILY FACED I AGREE AND THE
BILL IS NEEDED BECAUSE SUCH A
RESTRAINT. CAN KILL PEOPLE AND
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE AS WAS
DESCRIBED IN BY THE AUTHOR AND
THE WITNESSES. IT WAS A MENTAL
HEALTH CALL. AND THE FAMILY WAS.
I DIDN'T KNOW QUITE WHAT TO DO
WITH THE THEIR FAMILY MEMBER
WHO WAS HAVING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS BUT BY THE TIME THE
OFFICERS ARRIVED THE FAMILY
MEMBER HAD. IT MORE OR LESS
CALM DOWN. AND- WAS NOT ARMED
AS WAS DESCRIBED AND YET WAS
PUT IN A HOLD. THAT TEN BECAUSE
THIS CONSEQUENCE WHERE I DID
THIS FAMILY NO LONGER HAS THEIR
LOVED ONES SO THEY DID WHAT
THEY THOUGHT WAS RIGHT AND YET
THEN THIS OCCURS SO. I'M SURE
THE OFFICERS DID NOT INTEND TO
KILL. ANGELO CANTO AND YET THE
HOLD THAT THE USED BECAUSE THAT
SO. WE HOPE THERE'S NOT
APPROPRIATE TIME TO USE SUCH A
HOLD THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LEARNING
THAT'S WE'RE BEGINNING TO
UNDERSTAND THERE'S NOT AN
APPROPRIATE TIME TO USE THAT TO
HOLD IT IS TO LEGAL. AND SO I
THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL I REALLY- MY DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY BUT
TO ANY. ANY FAMILIES WHO HAVE.
FIVE REGARDLESS OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCE HAD THE
CONSEQUENCE OF SUCH A HOLD
BECAUSE A PATH TO THEIR FAMILY
MEMBER- SO APPRECIATE DIFFERENT
BILL BEING BROUGHT AND- OF IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER I TO THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FORTH WHAT IS
USUALLY CONSIDERED COMMONSENSE
MEASURES- WE'VE LEARNED FROM
EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE THAT SUCH
RESTRAINT AREN'T NECESSARY
STRUCTURE THEN YOU KNOW SOMEONE
WHO IS NOT ARMED NONVIOLENT
HAVING A- MENTAL ISSUE THAT
REQUIRES. SOMETHING LESS THAN-
DEADLY FORCE TO- CONTROL FOUR
INTERVENE AT AT THAT SITUATION
AND I THINK IT'S CLEARLY
ANOTHER THIS- EXAMPLE OF THE
LACK OF. REVERENCE FOR LIFE
WHEN IT COMES TO. THE POOR AND
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE AGAIN A LOT OF- MORE
FEDERATION CONSTRAINT ISSUES
BEFORE APPLYING THESE THESE
TECHNIQUES AND MORE- FLUENT
COMMUNITY SO I THINK IT'S
CLEARLY- NOT ONE OF TRAIN MANY
PEOPLE ALWAYS WANT TO THROW IT
BACK TO TRAINING BUT- THEY SEEM
TO GET IT RIGHT IN THE RIGHT
COMMUNITIES BUT WHEN YOU'RE-
ARE YOU SEE IN A POOR MINORITY
COMMUNITY WITH THE SEEM TO
RESPOND WITH SUCH ACTIONS SUCH
AS THESE SO I THINK WE'VE SEEN
ENOUGH EXAMPLES FROM THEIR
GARDENS OF THE WORLD TO. THE
GEORGE FOR ITS TO MISTER KING
TO HEAR SO ARE A TOTALLY
SUPPORT. WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE
AND I THINK YOU AN INCH. IF
YOU'RE ARE PREPARED TO MAKE
CALLS THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND TO SENATORS
FOR YOUR KIND COMMENTS WE
REALLY PREACH I WANT TO THANK.
BECAUSE IT TAKES A VERY STRONG
CURRENTS- FOR THE MOTHER OF
ANGELO TO TESTIFY- AND THE
SISTER WHO ACTUALLY MADE THE
CALL- TO LAW ENFORCEMENT TO TRY
TO DE ESCALATE THE SITUATION.
ONE THANK HER ENOUGH AND THEN
ALSO THE DOT THE FATHER-
CALIFORNIA PACKAGES THOSE ARE
ALL THAT WHO HAS CALLED IN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. MY
COMMITMENT IS TO GET THIS BILL
ACROSS TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
MY COMMITMENT IS TO SAY
ANGELO'S NAME IS OFTEN AS I CAN
ALSO TELLS. HIS STORY THUS MY
COMMITMENT TO- THE FAMILY-
AGAIN PLACING- A KNEE ON THE
NECK WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT.
DEADLY FORCE AND LETHAL FORCE
THAT LEADS TO IT IS MY DESIRE
THAT WE CAN HONOR THIS THIS
FAMILY AND HONOR OTHERS- BY.
HAVING THIS BILL SIGNED INTO
LAW- PROHIBITING- POSITIONAL
TIXIER OR ANYONE'S ABILITY TO
BREED IN A HANDS OF THE CUSTODY
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK WHEN I
BUILDING THANK THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A TWO PASS
TO. APPROPRIATIONS ACCOUNTS SO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A V.
FOUR NINETY. AB FOUR NINETY
BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD AYE. CHAU
BOTH TERRAZZO KAMLAGER SKINNER
HI SKINNER I BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER GIBSON FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION ACCENT WERE- MEANS
ASSUMING WOMAN GONZALEZ FOR
SOME- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
FOR PRESENTING TO MEASURES
FIRST. AB SEVEN SIX FOUR AND
THEN AB NINE THREE NINE AM I
CORRECT THANK YOU. NO WORRIES.
NOT TO WORRY. WELL
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS GONZALEZ WILL.
WITH YOUR VERY ATTENTIVE
AUDIENCE OF WHAT PLEASE PROCEED
MADAM CHAIR. I LIKE YOU'RE A
100% OR THEIR- THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB SEVEN
SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CERVANTES- SHE FIRST OF ALL
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S SUGGESTED MOMENTS
AND THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
THIS DISTANCE WITH THIS BILL AB
SEVEN SIXTY FOUR WILL HELP
UPDATEOUR STATE'S CRIMINAL LAW
TO REFLECT THE REALITIES OF THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. UNDER
CURRENT LAW OUR COURTS CAN
ISSUE PROTECTIVE ORDERS AGAINST
PERPETRATORS HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF STALKING THEIR
CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
PERPETRATORS TO CONTACT A TRIP
SURVIVOR DIRECTLY BY TELEPHONE
OR USING PHYSICAL MAIL IN
VIOLATION OF PROTECTIVE ORDER.
HOWEVER THE REALITY OF OUR
MODERN WORLD IS THAT IT'S
INCREASINGLY LIKELY FOR
STOCKING TO OCCUR OVER SOCIAL
MEDIA AND THE INTERNET.
UNFORTUNATELY UNDER CURRENT LAW
CONVICTED STALKER MAY GO
UNPUNISHED FOR CONTACTING A
SURVIVOR USING SOCIAL MEDIA OR
THE INTERNET EVEN OF A
PROTECTIVE ORDER IS IN PLACE AB
SEVEN SIXTY FOUR CLOSE LOOPHOLE
BY ADDING CONTACT OVER SOCIAL
MEDIA OR ELECTRONIC MEANS TO
LIST OF PROHIBITED FORMS OF
ACTIVITY. THERE IS WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
BILLS PAT ESPINOSA REPRESENTS
INDIA COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY-
SUMMER STEPHAN THE SPONSOR THE
BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ABOUT THEIR. OWN LIVES.
SO IT'S GOOD WHEN YOU READ SOME
ELSE'S CAR POINTS. YOU LIKE TO
GO TO YOUR WITH. YEAH WHAT
HAPPENED MAN GERMAN IN. AND I'D
SAY OF THE COMMITTEE AT JUST
THOSE ON THE OF THE CARE
DISTRICT OFFICE. WHICH PER
SPONSORS OF. EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY FOUR
MAKES CHANGES TO PENAL CODE
SECTION. ONE SIXTY SIXTY ONE
CURRENTLY PIMCO'S SECTION ONE
SIXTY SIX B. ONE. MAKES IT A
MISDEMEANOR FOR PERSON
PREVIOUSLY CONVICTED OF
STALKING TO WILLFULLY VIOLATE A
COURT ORDER BY CONTACTING THE
VICTIM BY TELEPHONE OR BY MAIL
SB SEVEN SIXTY FOUR SIMPLY
UPDATES A LOT TO KEEP UP WITH
THE CURRENT CHANGES IN
TECHNOLOGY. I DON'T SIDE THIS
VERY COMMITTEE ROOM THERE IS AN
EMPTY PHONE BILLS AND THAT
ILLUSTRATES HOW OUR METHODS OF
GENE COMMUNICATION. EXPANDED
BEYOND THE TELEPHONE AND MAIL.
MODERN FORMS OF COMMUNICATION
INCLUDING SOCIAL MEDIA.
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION AND
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION
DEVICES AB SEVEN SIXTY FOUR
DOES NOT CREATE A NEW CRIME
THAT MILLION UPDATES EXISTING
LAW TO REFLECT CHANGES IN THE
WAY PEOPLE COMMUNICATE AND WITH
THAT WE BOURGEON I TOLD. WAS
THERE ANOTHER MAIN WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OR JUST THE ONE. OKAY
SO- WHAT WE'LL DO THEN IS SEE
IF THERE ARE OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN THE ROOM WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY. SEEING NONE. WE STILL
HAVE AN OVERFLOW ROOM. OR WE
NOT. THERE IT IS THE EMPTY
OVERFLOW. OKAY MODERATOR WE
WILL I. Q. U. UP FOR THOSE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN SIX FOUR AND WITNESSES
JUST YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
AND THAT YOU SUPPORT THAT IS
ALL WE'RE TAKING RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU MODERATOR. INDIVIDUAL
LIGHT TO QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN SIX FOUR YOU KNOW
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY SO DO WE HAVE ANY REMAIN
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
COUNCILLOR ANY MAIN WITNESSES
IN THIS ONE IN OPPOSITION NOW
ALL RIGHT SO LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. NOT SEEING ANYONE
AN OVERFLOW ROOM I DOUBT
SOMEONE SNUCK IN IN THE
MEANTIME BUT- THERE HASN'T BEEN
SO MODERATOR COULD YOU SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES WHO WANTS TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVEN SIX
FOUR. DO YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN SIX FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OF COURSE WE GO TO LINE
THREE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. OF
EIGHT SEVEN SIX FOUR THANK YOU.
VERY WELL LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OPPOSITION. BUT AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT MAKES EASY- AND I WAS
NOBODY HERE TO ASK QUESTIONS
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL ALSO GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE. HELLO AND- WE
GET SOME FOLKS HERE I HOPE
YOU'LL- DO YOU REMOVE THE VALVE
OF A HEALTHY ALTHOUGH YES JOHN
I THINK. I'M NOT THE FORMAL
CARE I COULD MOVE THE BILL
COULD NOT HIRE NOTE I AM
MODERATING NOW SO I HAVE TO
WAIT SO WE CAN DESTROY MOTION.
WHICH AGAIN WE CAN DO. WHEN
PEOPLE COME BACK OKAY. I
BELIEVE YOU'RE PRESENTING A
SECOND BILL. HEY I AM AB WHAT
WE'LL DO IS JUST OKAY HOLD ON
THE MOTION FOR THIS ONE. AND
ALLOW YOU 2% THE SECOND OKAY
THANK YOU. AB NINE THIRTY NINE-
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT- ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN SAID ABOUT THIS.
EVERY YEAR WE DRESSED IN JEANS
TO PROTEST AN ITALIAN SUPREME
COURT CASE WHICH HELD THAT THE
SURVIVORS CLOTHING COULD BE
USED AS EVIDENCE OF CONSENT IN
A SEXUAL ASSAULT CASE. YET
DESPITE A POP PROCLAMATIONS TO
THE CONTRARY ARE EVIDENCE CODE
LEAVES THE DOOR OPEN TO
CONTINUE TO VICTIM BLAME IN A
POLL THAT AN OUTFIT CAN GIVE
CONSENT. UNDER CURRENT LAW
SURVIVORS MANNER OF DRESS CAN
BE ADMITTED AS EVIDENCE OF
CONSENT IN A CASE INVOLVING
SEXUAL ASSAULT IF IT IS IN THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE. THIS MEANS
THAT THE JUDGE OUTSIDE THE
PRESENCE OF THE JURY MAKE A
RULING ABOUT WHETHER TO ADMIT
THE EVIDENCE. THE LEGISLATURE
HAS ALREADY MADE A DECISION TO
EXCLUDE SOME FORMS OF EVENTS
FROM BEING CONSIDERED AS
EVIDENCE OF CONSENT INCLUDING
DATING OR MARITAL RELATIONSHIP
OR REQUEST OF THE PERPETRATOR
HE'S A CONDOM OR BIRTH CONTROL
DEVICE. SEXUAL ASSAULT IS THE
MOST UNDER REPORTED AND UNDER
PROSECUTED TYPE OF CRIME WE
MUST MAKE SURE THE SURVIVORS
ARE NOT RE VICTIMIZED AND RE
TRAUMATIZED BY OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM. CONTINUING TO ALLOW THE
MANNER OF DRESS AS EVIDENCE FOR
CONSENT IMPLIES A VICTIM'S
PROVOKED THEIR OWN SEXUAL
ASSAULT. IF OUR STATE LAW
MAINTAINS THESE HARMFUL
POLICIES IT IS ENABLING
VIOLENCE SILENCING SURVIVORS
REDUCING ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY NINE FOR
FILLS THE PREMISE OF DENIM DAY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. BY MAKING
IT CLEAR THEY HAD A SURVIVOR'S
MANNER OF DRESS CAN NEVER BE
USED AS EVIDENCE OF CONSENT TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT CASE BUT FLORIDA
NEW HAMPSHIRE HAVE ALREADY
ENACTED LEGISLATION SIMILAR. TO
THIS BILL- WE WILL. GO TO THE
TESTIMONY AND HOPEFULLY
KOURTNEY A UNITED STATES NAVY
VETERAN CAMPUS SURVIVOR
ADVOCATE IN CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SAN BERNARDINO. HI
MY NAME IS COURTNEY UP UNDER
COLOR. IN MIND THE CONFIDENTIAL
SURVIVOR ADVOCATE. NUMBER IN
DETAIL OVER MY EIGHT YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN ADVOCACY
I HAVE BEEN A COMMON THEME
THEIR INVESTIGATION WITH THAT
WITH HIS OFFENSE AND YOUR
CREDIT PROVIDER. AFTER HANDLING
HUNDREDS OF SURVIVORS IN
SETTING BUT THE PART IN A
DIFFERENT COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND
AT THE PARTIAL CARE ACT BECOME
FAMILIAR WITH THE STRATEGIES
USED TO DISCREDIT SURVIVORS IN
THE. BACK OF THE STATE OR- SOME
OF THE MOST TIME JACQUI I HAVE.
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE SEXUAL
YOU. HOW CLEAR IT WAS INFLAMED
LEAVE ON THE GARBAGE.
REPUBLICAN AFFECT FAR OR LESS
LIKELY BE THOUGHT BASED ON WHAT
THEY'RE WEARING. SIDE WITH THE
VIRUS ALSO SOMEHOW ALL YOUR
FAULT. LEADERS OF OUR AN HOUR
HERE'S THE PRICE DIVIDE THERE
ARE TREATED AS IF THEY'RE BEING
IN THE IN OUR MAIL THERE'S AN
EVEN IT ONLY. AFTER IN THE
VIRUS THE CASE WITHIN PRIOR
DATA RULING ABOUT. AS AN AVID
I'M WITH TO THAT KIDS RIDING
THE- WHAT IS SOME OF THE LOWEST
NUMBER OF THEIR LIFE. IN THE
VIRUS MEMBERS INTO WHOLE BOB.
INTERNAL EXTERNAL GRAHAM AT AND
EVEN BEING PART OF NAKED. THANK
YOU OFFICE HOURS YOU VERY. AND
TRY. PROVIDE AFTER DEALING WITH
RATE. THEIR DINNER. TO LEAVE A
REPLY FELT OBERNOLTE. ANIMATED
DEPENDENCE AS THEIR STORY I
THINK THE. LESS THAN 5% OF RAPE
CASE BETTER ARE. NEWS THAT NOT
FIVE OF RATE REPORT ARE YOU.
WHAT BETTER IS BETTER 344% OF
THE VOTE. R. S. REPORTED MOST
OF OUR- IN BIBLE. THE ONLY WAY
TO COME BACK VIRUS. ACCORDING
IF THE J. THE CULTURE AROUND WE
TALK ABOUT IN WITH THAT ABOUT.
PROVIDER NOW ON THE TO BE IN
THAT AND COURAGE BE A PART IT.
ABU CONSIDERING PROVIDE
CLOTHING EVIDENCE THAT
PROFESSIONAL HOW APPROACH- IN A-
SOME EXTRA VERY BASED ON THE
PERSON IS. ONE PERSON MAKING HI
RIPPED AS A PROGRAM YOU ANOTHER
FOR HEARD ANYTHING THOSE. AT
END OF HER. ACTING. IT'S VERY
CLOSE IT WILL WOMEN ARE WHAT
FELT IT THERE NO EVAN WITH THE-
OF THE BASE OUT THERE AS I
WOULD THAT THAT. SO WHO ARE
MOST LIKELY TO A SELF ARE WOMEN
COLOR. WELL THE VOTER. ECONOMIC
BY. HOME ADULT WOMEN IN HOME
LGBT. I A PLAY WE- WHEN ACTORS
THEY'RE AWARE OKAY PATTERN
LOADING OVER FIVE. LAYERED
FOLDING INTO NOT BAY BREAK.
BLACK RISK OF VIOLENT BIG THEY
FROM WOMEN 90% MAKING SEXUAL
VIOLENCE TO THE STATE BUT AS
FAR. THE WAY SOMEONE IS DRESSED
AS MAKES MORE LESS LIKE TO
FOCUS ON CONSIDERING IN DOESN'T
HAVE WAY OF THEIR BUSINESS
PROVIDER RATHER THAN BELIEVING.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE MADE
WEARING IS LOT OF IMPORTANT
PIECE IN CONVENTIONAL. BY
QUESTIONING WHETHER SURVIVORS
WE ARE FINE THAT WOULD WE'RE
GOING TO NEED YOU TO WRITE
TESTIMONY PLAY I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT BUT WE'RE GOING TO
YOU. INCLUDE YEAH PROBLEM A LOT.
SOMEONE CAN BE NAKED IN SAY NO
TO THAT SOMEONE CAN BEGIN HAVE
SEX BY THEY KNOW WANT THAT ONE
INCIDENT THANK YOU THE LOW. IF
DID NOT GIVE. READ OF WHAT
WEARING AND THEY BOTH. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK NOW
WE'RE MORE TO A MAKE IN WARNER
PLEASE ARE BOTH. YES THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MEGAN WARNER AND I
LOOK CANDIDATE SEXUAL AT
STANFORD BONTA RESURGENCE OF
WITH THE CENTER INSTITUTIONAL
COURAGE RESEARCH CENTER SEEKS
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE OUR
INSTITUTION CAN FACILITATE
JUSTICE. URGENTLY INSTITUTIONAL
BETRAYAL NOT COURAGE IT'S FAR
MORE COMMON. GOOD NUTRITIONAL
BETRAYAL CCURS WHEN AN
INSTITUTION HARM SOMEONE WHO
DEPEND ON IT SOMETIMES WORKING
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS SYMPTOMS.
BUT SOME REPORTS THEIR
EXPERIENCE WITH SEXUAL VIOLENCE
TO AUTHORITIES THEY PLACE THEIR
TRUST IN INSTITUTIONS THAT TOO
OFTEN FAIL THEM. FOR EXAMPLE
PLEASE MAKE BELT UNDERGO A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION BASED ON
THEIR INTERPRETATION OF THE
SURVIVORS CREDIBILITY USING A
NARAL AND OUTDATED
UNDERSTANDING OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. VERY FEW SURVIVORS
WHO CASES GO TO TRIAL MAY BE
SUBJECT TO UNNECESSARY AND
HARMFUL QUESTIONING BASED ON
OUTDATED BELIEFS ABOUT SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. ONE SUCH BELIEVE
INCLUDES THE IDEA THAT THE WAY
SOMEONE IS DRESSED IS RELEVANT
TO DETERMINING WHETHER THEY
HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED. THIS IDEA
THAT SOMEHOW SURVIVORS WERE
ASKING FOR IT WITH THEIR
CLOTHING CONTRIBUTE TO HELP
PLANE. MUCH RESEARCH FINDS THAT
SURVIVORS BLAME THEMSELVES FOR
THE ASSAULT BECAUSE OF WHAT
THEY WERE DRINKING WHO THEY
WERE WITH WHAT THEY WERE
WEARING TO NAME A FEW. DON'T
BLAME CONTRIBUTE TO GREATER
ISOLATION AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISTRESS VIOLENT. PEOPLE WHO
BLAME THEMSELVES ARE PULLING ON
COMMON CULTURAL SCRIPT ABOUT
SEXUAL VIOLENCE THAT OUR
INSTITUTIONS REINFORCED. EXCUSE
PERPETRATORS AND GOING BACK
DOWN FOR THE VIOLENCE. WHEN THE
COURT IS VICTIMS TIRE IT
CONTRIBUTES TO THE IDEA BACK
HELP HOMEOWNERS TRUST COULD BE
EVIDENCE. THAT EVEN CONSIDERING
WHETHER THEY'RE AT HIGHER IS
QUOTE IN THE INTEREST OF JOBS
THAT. INVOLVE UNNECESSARY AND
HARMFUL QUESTIONING OF THE
VICTIM. ALSO MISTRUST IF NOT
BECAUSE OF THE FAULT AND IT'S
TIME TO ALIGN OUR LAWS WITH OUR
STATED GOAL OF SUPPORTING
SURVIVORS. THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB
NINE THREE NINE. THANK YOU NOW
WILL COME BACK TO FORTY TWO OLD
THREE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE THREE NINE.
C. NINE WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS
WELL. MISTER MODERATOR CAN WE
GO TO OUR PHONE LINES AND SEE
IF THERE'S WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB. NINE THREE NINE.
GENERATIONALLY SPEAKING SUPPORT
OF AB NINE THREE NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. TO
HAVE SOMEONE TO ANOTHER JUST A
MOMENT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS LESLIE LOGAN FROM LOS
GATOS AND I SUPPORT. MOMENT TO
THE NEXT ONE. I NEXT WILL GO TO
LINE THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ONLY
THE CAR ON BEHALF OF UC
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR.
OF THE DAY. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE THREE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHELLE THOMAS SHOP
REPRESENTING THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE ELSE COMING UP ONE
MOMENT.
THANKS FOR THE TO LINE
THREE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU HI THIS-IS KAREN MCDANIEL FROM THE
PLACE FOR GRACE. VOICING STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND THE TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU. NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I THINK WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE THE SO CALLED WILL AND
WE HAVE KATHY SHEARER ARE
EITHER OR BOTH ARE PREPARED
TESTIMONY AT THE STOCK. THIS IS
LESLIE I'M PREPARED THANK YOU
YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND A HALF
THANK YOU. THERE THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION UNFORTUNATELY IT
DOES SOUND LIKE THE PRIMARY
SUPPORT WITNESSES DON'T
UNDERSTAND EXISTING LAW AB NINE
THREE NINE IS UNNECESSARY AS
APPLEGATE'S JUDICIAL DISCRETION
AND WOULD PREVENT A FAIR TRIAL
TO BOTH PROS PROSECUTION AND
DEFENSE UNDER EXISTING LAW.
EVIDENCE CODE SECTION. ELEVEN
OH THREE SEVEN THREE SEVEN TWO-
EVIDENCE OF THAT THE MANNER OF
DRESS IS INADMISSIBLE UNLESS
THE JUDGE FINDS THAT IT IS
RELEVANT AND IN THE INTEREST OF
JUSTICE OUTSIDE THE PRESENCE OF
THE JURY THE JUDGE IS LISTENING
TO BOTH PARTIES AS TO WHAT THE
EVIDENCE IS. WHETHER IT'S AN
DETERMINES WHETHER IT'S
RELEVANT AND WHY IT'S NECESSARY
TO ADMIT. THE JUDGE DECIDE
STATING THEIR REASONS FOR THE
RECORD. THIS IS A FAIR AND
BALANCED PROCESS. THAT'S AB
NINE THREE NINE IS NOT
NECESSARY AB NINE THREE NINE AB
AGAINST YOUR GEAR SO THIS
QUESTION AND THE FUNDAMENTALLY
UNFAIR CALIFORNIA JUDGES UNDER
THE LAW WAVY OF THE DAM BALANCE
THE COMPETING RIGHTS OF THE
ALLEGED VICTIM AND THE
DEFENDANT. OF PUBLIC DEFENDERS
WE REPRESENTED MAN ACCUSED OF
RAPE WHO REFUSED TO PAY IS THE
GRADE AFTER THE FACT ONLY TWO
DAYS. GREAT CHARGES RATHER THAN
THEFT OF SERVICES. AND THAT IN
A- SEX WORK SITUATION LIKE TO
GIVE AN EXAMPLE- YEAH NAKED
WOMEN CAN BE GREAT HOWEVER I
HAVE A CASE WHERE. THE
COMPLAINING WITNESS WAS WEARING
ONLY HIGH HEELS AND A G. STRING
WALKING DOWN THE STREET KNOWN
FOR SEX WORK ON MANY OCCASIONS.
MY CLIENT WAS. CHARGED WITH
RAPE AFTER REFUSING TO PAY IN
DRUGS I WANTED TO PAY CASH
INSTEAD. THE COMPLAINING
WITNESS DEFINE DOES GIVE-
DENIED. RESTITUTION MARC UNDER
THESE AND MANY OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES A JUDICIAL
DETERMINATION THAT THE EVIDENCE
OF HOW A VICTIM WAS DRESSED
MIGHT BE ESSENTIAL FOR A FAIR
AND JUST TRIAL. BONTA MEDICALLY
EXCLUDING SUCH EVIDENCE COULD
DEPRIVE THE DEFENDANT OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
CONFRONT AND CROSS EXAMINE FOR
THOSE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOT TO THIS. GOOD
AFTERNOON KATHY SURFER ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION WE
RESPECTFULLY NOT SUPPOSED AB
NINE THIRTY NINE I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT EXPRESSLY EXCLUDES IN
EVERY CASE EVIDENCE THAT IS
FOUND TO BE RELEVANT AND IN THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE. AT LEAST
CALDWELL HAS ALREADY DESCRIBED
EXISTING LAW STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN ENSURING THAT THE
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
ARE NOT BLAMED FOR THE CRIMES
AGAINST THEM WHILE ALLOWING
THOSE ACCUSED OF THE CRIME. YOU
ARE INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN
GUILTY TO SEEK TO HAVE EVIDENCE
OF MANNER OF DRESS CONSIDERED
IN THOSE RARE CASES WHERE IT IS
NECESSARY FOR JUSTICE PREVAIL.
IT IS RARE FOR EITHER SIDE TO
SEEK ADMISSION FOR THIS TYPE OF
EVIDENCE AND RARER STILL FOR IT
TO BE ADMITTED. WHERE JUSTICE
DEMANDS THAT THE EVIDENCE
SHOULD BE ADMITTED OUR SYSTEM
OF JUSTICE SHOULD ALLOW THE
JUDGE TO MAKE THAT CALL. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE.
THANK YOU. NOW WILL BRING HIM
BACK TO ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
ARE THERE WITNESSES HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO. AB NINE THREE
NINE. SHE NINE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM AND THERE'S NO
ONE THERE AS WELL MODERATOR
WE'LL GO TO OUR PHONE LINE TO
SEE IF THERE ARE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. NINE THREE
NINE. YOU LIKE TO COME IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE THREE
NINE. PRESS ONE ZERO. FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. CANACCORD
ARMAND THE HALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
OPPOSITION. I HAVE ONE MORE
JUST A MOMENT. SHE. MEXICO TO
LINE THREE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DOES YOUR DEBATE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- NOW LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS A
RELIGIOUS AB NINE THREE NINE.
SENATOR GRAHAM WATER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WAS JUST
WONDERING IS MISS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ I GUESS AND- IN
LIEU OF THE AUTHOR CAN SPEAK TO
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION. SO I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT THE PUBLIC DEFENDER. DROVE
IT HOME- IT DOES NOT MATTER IF
A WOMAN IS WALKING DOWN THE
STREET IN A G. STRING AND HIGH
HEELS WITH A T. SHIRT THAT SAYS
PLEASE RATE ME. THAT IS NOT
EVIDENCE OF CONSENT. AND SO
THERE IS NO SITUATION THAT I
WOULD CHALLENGE ANYONE TO COME
UP WITH WHERE WHAT SOMEBODY IS
WEARING IS EVIDENCE OF CONSENT
IT IS TIME TO TAKE THAT OUT OF.
THE DISCUSSION IT IS A BARRIER
TO A WOMAN IF SHE FEELS LIKE
SHE'S GOING TO BE BLAMED OR
THAT THAT IS GOING TO COME UP
EVEN OUTSIDE OF THE JURY IS A
BARRIER TO IT TO HER. OR HIM
ASSERTING THE RIGHTS. AND SO I
YOU KNOW QUITE FRANKLY I CAN'T
BELIEVE IN THIS DAY AND AGE WE
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION IT IS A
SUGGESTS THAT YOU KNOW BECAUSE
SOMEBODY IT'S EVIDENCE OF BEING
A SEX WORKER I. I CAN'T EVEN
WRAP MY ARMS AROUND WHAT WAS
JUST SAT. IN IT SHOWS EXACTLY
WHY WE NEED THIS PROHIBITION.
NO MAN OR WOMAN. SHOULD BE
SHAMED FOR WHAT THEY WORE AND
THAT SHOULD NOT BE EVER
RELEVANT AS A MATTER OF CONSENT
IN A SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES. SO
MY FELLOW QUESTION IS THIS-
THIS IS ONLY PERTAIN TO- RAPE
CRIMES AND CRIMES OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR EXISTS FOR ALL
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. AT TWO
SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES SEX CRIMES.
YOU IN CRIMINAL CASES INVOLVING
SEXUAL ASSAULT- THE MICHIGAN
WHICH OF COURSE. NOT A QUESTION
PER SE BUT I YOU KNOW I HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING WITH WHETHER
THIS REALLY DOES REDUCE
JUDICIAL DISCRETION AND IT'S A
BIT DIFFERENT THAN SOME OF THE
OTHER BILLS WE HAVE WHERE WE
LITERALLY TAKE AWAY JUDICIAL
DISCRETION AND WE JUST SAY. THE
JUDGE MUST IF THEY DEFINE TEXAS
CRIME THE MOST SENSITIVE
CERTAIN WAY. AND I THINK THIS
IS A BIT DIFFERENT I DO
APPRECIATE. THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNED THAT IT'S TAKING AWAY
SOME FACTORS THE JUDGE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO USE HOWEVER WE KNOW
JUDGES LIKE ALL OF US HAVE
DIFFERENT BIASES. AND IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON TO HAVE A BIAS THAT.
THE PERSON IN QUESTIONS DRESS
SOMEHOW PLAYED A FACTOR IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE THE CRIME AND SO.
AND I APPRECIATE THE
EXPLANATION BY THE PRESENTER
THAT YOU KNOW THAT REALLY
CANNOT MATTER AND I GUESS.
WHILE I APPRECIATE THE
CIRCUMSTANCE THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER FACED WHEN DESCRIBING
THAT CLIENT I THINK THE MORE
RELEVANT WAS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVE THAT THAT CLIENT. I WAS
ACTUALLY ENGAGED IN A. FIVE IN
A TRANSACTION WHERE THEN THE
CHANGE B. B. R. DEMAND WAS
CHANGED AS TO THE PAYMENT ON
THE TRANSACTION- AND SO NOT
KNOWING ENOUGH ABOUT THAT CASE
I CAN'T IN ANY WAY SPEAK TO WHY
OR WHY NOT IT WAS UNABLE TO BE
DEFENDED AS A NON RATE. HOWEVER
I THINK THAT AGAIN D. D. YOU
KNOW THERE CAN BE SEX WORKERS
WHO ARE NOT DRESSED IN A
PROVOCATIVE MANNER SO IT
SEEMED- AGAIN I CAN'T YOU KNOW
USING EXAMPLE PROBABLY. IT WAS
IT IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY ADD
CLARITY TO US IN TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT BECAUSE IT VERY
WELL COULD BE THE CASE THAT
THAT PARTICULAR SEX WORKER- WAS
NOT RAPED AND SO THE PERSON
THAT THE PUBLIC DEFENDER WAS
DEFENDING YOU KNOW MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN. GUILTY OF RAPE EVER THAT
PARTICULAR YEAH I DESCRIPTION
OF JUST THE CLONING SHOULD NOT
REALLY BE A FACTOR SO. I THINK
ABOUT THE WAYS THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO CORRECT FOR THE
VARIOUS BIASES THAT WE KNOW
EXIST RACIAL BIAS SEES THESE
GENDER BIAS SEES. AND SO. IT
DID. YOU KNOW THIS ONE IS- IT
COULD BE A GRAY AREA THOUGH I
WOULD TRY HERE ON SAYING IT
SHOULDN'T BE A FACTOR SO I'LL I
THINK I MEAN I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THERE COME
UNDER. HE I APPRECIATE NINE
SENATOR SKINNER'S- COMMENTS YOU
KNOW I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
THINKING ABOUT. CASES THAT ARE
NOT SO CUT AND DRY WHERE
SOMEONE WAS WALKING DOWN THE
STREET AND THEN YOU KNOW. THE
DEFENDANT YOU KNOW. KNOCK
SOMEBODY IN THE HEAD AND
SEXUALLY ASSAULTS THEM VERY
RARELY ARE THE CASES THAT- THE
SIMPLE. I'M WONDERING ABOUT
CASES WHERE- THE- VICTIM WORD
IS ALSO PART OF IT WERE ENGAGED
IN CRIMINAL ACTIVITY AND WHERE
THE MANNER OF THEIR DRESS OR
WHAT THEY ARE WEARING- IT PLAYS
A ROLE IN EITHER. WEAPONS THAT
THEY MAY HAVE OR THAT ARE BEING
CONDEMNING THERE LIKE ALL OF
THESE OTHER THINGS AND I'M JUST
THINKING BACK TO THE NUMBER OF
CASES AND CIRCUMSTANCES THAT I
HAVE HEARD ABOUT AND OFTEN
TIMES AND I THINK THAT THE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS DO A
DISSERVICE WHEN THEY COME
BECAUSE THEY KIND OF SHARE VERY
ON SIMPLE EXAMPLES- BUT OFTEN
TIMES. THE NOT HOW PROVOCATIVE
SOMEONE IS DRESSED BUT HOW THEY
pARE DRESSED BUT MAYBE WHAT THEY
ARE WEARING MAY PLAY A ROLE IN
SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
CONCEALING MAYBE SOMETHING THAT
SOME WEAPON THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO USE AND THAT DOES BECOME
PART OF EVIDENCE AND THAT DOES
BECOME PART OF- WHAT IS
REVEALED. AND SHARED EITHER YOU
KNOW DURING TRIAL OR OR WITH
CHARGES AND SO MY CONCERN IS
THAT NGUYEN SOMETHING WHEN
CLOTHING IS RELEVANT. TO THE
CASE IN THAT WAY DOES THIS MAKE
THAT INADMISSIBLE SO IT'S NOT
SO MUCH THAT SOMEONE WAS
PROVOCATIVELY DRESSED BUT YOU
KNOW THE- YOU KNOW THE RAZOR
BLADE OR WHATEVER. WHAT IS THE
AND- YOU KNOW- SO THAT'S MY CAN
AND I WANT TO AND I'M DON'T
KNOW IF THIS ADDRESSES THOSE
KINDS OF SCENARIOS. SO THAT WAS
WHY I ACTUALLY ASKED M
ORIGINAL QUESTION BECAUSE I'M
TRYING TO GET AT IF THIS
PREVENT CERTAIN EVIDENCE- FROM
BEING ADMISSIBLE. SENATOR IF I
MAY. THROUGH THE CHAIR AT. MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL IS
THAT IT CANNOT BE USED FOR
EVIDENCE OF CONSENT IN A SEXUAL
ASSAULT NOT THAT IT CAN'T BE
USED- FOR SOME OTHER PURPOSE
WHEN THAT TYPE OF THE TYPE OF
SCENARIO YOU'RE GOING THRILLED
WOULD. PROBABLY INVOLVE MORE
THAN A RAPE HARGE IN OUR
ASSAULT CHARGE RIGHT THERE'S
OTHER THINGS GOING ON SO THIS
PARTICULAR- PROHIBITION WOULD
BE UTILIZING WHAT THE VICTIM
WAS WEARING FOR EVIDENCE OF
CONSENT. AND AGAIN I CHALLENGE
ANYONE BECAUSE- LITERALLY YOU
COULD WEAR A SHIRT THAT SAYS
PLEASE WRITE ME AND THAT IS NOT
EVIDENCE OF CONSENT SO I DON'T
KNOW I CAN'T THINK. I LIVE
RIGHT WHEN I SAW THIS I JUST
WENT ROUND AND ROUND OF LIKE
YOU PROBABLY ARE DOING LIKE
WHAT IN WHAT WORLD. SHOULD THE
JUDGE EVER. STATE OKAY IN THE
INTEREST OF JUDGE OF. JUSTICE
WE'RE GONNA ALLOW THIS IN THAT
SHOWS YOU THE DANGER THAT THESE
VICTIMS EVEN FACE COMING FOR
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THAT SO. I JUST. FOR
THE LIFE OF ME CAN'T IMAGINE
THERE'S A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE
WHAT SOMEBODY WAS WEARING HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH CONSENT. I
GUESS. THOSE ALONG. THE
QUESTIONS ARE HERE TO THAT THIS
BILL. DEALS STRICTLY WITH
CONSENT- AND NOTHING ELSE
BECAUSE TO I CAN. TELL YOU HAVE
MANY SCENARIOS WORD DRESS WAS A
FACTOR IN A CRIME THAT WAS
COMMITTED. TO LURE SOMEONE
SOMEWHERE I I'VE WITNESSED IT
YOU KNOW CHAU. I'VE HEARD ABOUT
IT SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS WHEN YOU CHOOSE AND YOU.
MADE IT CLEAR YES IF YOU'RE
WALKING ON THE STREET AND SAYS.
NO PLEASE TICK THAT'S NOT. YOU
KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUT
I'M THE ENEMY DOESN'T GIVE
JUSTIFICATION TO ANYTHING- YOU
KNOW TO SEXUALLY ASSAULT
ANYBODY MALE OR WOMAN BUT JUST
MAKING SURE THAT OTHER CRIMES
ARE COULD BE COMMITTED BASED ON
WHAT YOU LEARN IS NOT INCLUDED
HERE AND WHAT WE'RE- DEALING
WITH TODAY. YES AND THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS BILL I
HATE YOU KNOW THE YOU ALWAYS
RUN INTO DANGER WHEN YOU'RE
PRESENTING SOMEBODY ELSE'S
BILL. I KNOW THAT THAT'S THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE AUTHOR AND
IF IT NEEDS- AT IF THEY SHOULD
GO OUT TODAY AND THEY NEEDS
FURTHER CLARIFICATION TO ENSURE
THAT THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH THIS I'M SURE SHE WOULD BE
WILLING TO DO WE GET THE
LETTER. TO THE JOURNAL-
COUNSELOR STATING THAT ARE.
DESERVE SOME SAFEGUARDS THAT WE
NEED TO. BE SURE THAT. I JUST
QUESTION ON THE ARM CHAIR I DID
SEE ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS IT DOES SAY THAT THE
BILL RETAINS THE ADMISSIBILITY
OF THIS EVIDENCE. ON IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE BECAUSE
I DON'T I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
THE PENAL CODE IN RELATIONSHIP
TO IT. AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
IF THOSE PARTS THEY WERE
REPAINTED ARE ADEQUATE. AND
LIMIT AND THAT IT DOES DO THE
LIMITING THAT EVERYONE'S
DESCRIBING THAT WERE. IT THIS
IS THIS IS EXPRESSLY ONE- ON
THE CONSENSUS THAT'S EXPRESSLY
ON THE ISSUE OF CONSENT SUCKER.
SKINNER ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YEAH
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING. IT
IS RIGHT OKAY. SOON GONZALEZ
FLETCHER LOOKED CLOSE M. I
THINK YOU KNOW THERE ARE MANY
OF US WHO BELIEVE THIS WAS THE
LAW BEFORE BECAUSE WE TALK
ABOUT IT AS IF IT IS WE
CELEBRATE DENIM DAY AS IF THAT
IS THE LAW HERE AND IT IT I
SHOULD BE WE YOU KNOW WE DO
WANT JUDGES TO HAVE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF FLEXIBILITY- BUT
THERE ARE INITIAL BIASES THAT
SOME PEOPLE HAVE NOT GOTTEN
THRILLED AND I THINK- HOW IN
PARTICULAR WOMEN DRESS COULD
RESULT IN SOME OF SPICES IS I
THINK WE HEARD IN THIS ROOM
TODAY SO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
CAN I PUT. WE WERE SEEKING A-
ON A. B. THREE NINE. THREE I
MEAN I'M SIX NINE THREE NINE
I'M SORRY. I DO PASS ZERO
EMOTION ON AB NINE THREE NINE.
THERE IS A MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER. CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON ATVS NINE THREE NINE.
AB NINE THREE NINE I BELIEVE
IT'S TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
I JUST SORT OF DO PASS WILL
MAKE THE DEPOSIT FOR PERSONAL
CHECK IT REALLY QUICKLY I THINK.
ONE APPROPRIATIONS MY BEST.
FOR
WE ARE SORRY. RIGHT ABNINE
THREE NINE DO PASS BRADFORD
BRADFORD I'D SHOW BOTH DURAZO
CALM WATER FROM MY GRAD SKINNER
HI INTERACT. THROUGH ITS ENOUGH
TO GET OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU AND NOW WILL SEEK A MOTION
ON. IT SIR THUNDERS HOUSING
IT'S FISCAL HOLD ON. NOTICE NOW.
NINE THREE NINE. OF WORK AND
WE'RE GOOD. NO WE'RE SEEKING A
MOTION ON AB SEVEN SIX FOUR SO
MOVED WITH THE MEN WITH WITH
IMMENSE. AND WE HAVE A MOTION
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
AMENDMENTS. CANCEL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON AB SEVEN SIX FOUR.
BRADFORD ARE BRADFORD AYE CHOI
BOGUE DORADO KAMLAGER I'M SORRY
I WAS JUST WITH THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED OR ADDITIONAL IT'S
THIS IS ON AB SEVEN SIX FOUR
WITHIN MOMENTS PROPOSAL CAPABLE
DEFENSE ARE. KAMLAGER AYE
SKINNER PARK IN OUR EYES. THE
NECESSARY VOTES WILL BE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR. ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ NOW WE HAVE MISSED
CARILLO. BACK. WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTING AB NINE THREE SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD 2% ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE THREE SEVEN THE
VISION ACT. WHICH WOULD PROTECT
REFUGEE AND IMMIGRANT
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN
DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR RELEASE
FROM BEING FUNNELED INTO
IMMIGRATION DETENTION BY
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL JAIL FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
THESE ARE CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
COMPLETED THEIR TIME EARNED
PAROLE AND HAVE HAD THEIR
SENTENCE COMMUTED BY THE
GOVERNOR AFTER A CLOSE REVIEW
OF THE CLEMENCY APPLICATION.
WHEN LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
ASSIST WITH TRANSFERS OF THESE
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS TO ICE
THEY IGNORE THEIR RECORD OF
REHABILITATION THEIR STABLE RE
ENTRY PLANS AND THEIR NETWORK
OF COMMUNITY AND FAMILY
SUPPORT. MANY CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES INCLUDING LOS ANGELES
SANTA CLARA SAN FRANCISCO
HUMBLE TOWN JOAQUIN SANTA CRUZ
CONTRA COSTA HAVE ALREADY
RECOGNIZED THIS AND HAVE ENDED
ALL TRANSFERS TO ICE. MEMBERS
IF NOT FOR WHERE THESE
INDIVIDUALS WERE BORN THEY
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO RETURN HOME
TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES IN RECENT YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE IN CALIFORNIA
VOTERS HAVE DEMONSTRATED A
COMMITMENT TO REFORM OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THE
MASS INCARCERATION. HOWEVER FOR
IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE EARNED
RELEASED THIS JUST MEANS
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HANDED OVER
TO ICE AND FACE PERMANENT
SEPARATION FROM THEIR FAMILIES
AND FROM THEIR COMMUNITIES. LET
ME BE CLEAR. CALIFORNIA IS
UNDER NO LEGAL OBLIGATION TO
ASSIST THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WITH DEPORTATIONS. THE BILL
ALSO DOESN'T PRECLUDE STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
RESPONDING TO A CRIMINAL
WARRANT. OR PARTICIPATING IN
JOINT TASK FORCES FOR IF THE
PURPOSE OF THE TASK FORCE IS
CRIMINAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. NOT
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT WHICH
IS NOT THEIR JOB. ON MARCH
THIRTIETH A WOMAN FROM OMANI
NAME GABBY SOLANO. WAS
TRANSFERRED BY CDCR TO ICE.
GETTY CAME TO THIS COUNTRY AT
AGE AT THE AGE OF TWO. AS A
LAWFUL PERMANENT RESIDENT.
GABBY IS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR AND SPENT HALF HER
LIFE BEHIND BARS FOR A CRIME.
COMMITTED BY HER EX ABUSIVE
PARTNER. AFTER SERVING TWENTY
YEARS IN STATE PRISON GOVERNOR
BROWN COMMUTED HER SENTENCE IN
RECOGNITION OF HER DEMONSTRATED
RECORD OF COMMITMENT TO
SERVICE. MENTORSHIP AND
REHABILITATION. HOWEVER RATHER
THAN ALLOW GABBY TO RETURN HOME
TO HER FAMILY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA A PRIVATE COMPANY
CONTRACTED WITH ICE PICKED HER
UP FROM THE CDC OUR FACILITY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
TRANSPORTED HER TO A DETENTION
CENTER IN COLORADO. ICE
INCARCERATION WAS SO
EXCRUCIATING BUT GABBY DECIDED
TO SIGN HER OWN DEPORTATION
ORDER RATHER THAN CONTINUE
PURSUING HER LEGAL CASE MANY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE AN INTER MINUTE
SENTENCE MEANING THAT THEIR
ONLY OPPORTUNITY TO RETURN TO
THE COMMUNITY AFTER GOING
THROUGH THE RIGOROUS PEARL
PROCESS WITH THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THEIR CASE AND THE RECORD OF
REHABILITATION ARE CLOSELY
REVIEWED. IMMIGRANT
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAS SERVED OUT
THEIR SENTENCES OR HAVE
RECEIVED TO PAROLE SHOULD NOT
FACE A SECOND PUNISHMENT WE
SHOULD NOT FUNNEL THEM TO ICE
DETENTION WERE SYSTEMATIC
ABUSES IN INCOMING INTO MAIN
CONDITIONS ARE VERY WELL
DOCUMENTED. THE VISION ACT WILL
END ICE TRANSFERS FROM OUR
LOCAL JAILS AND CDCR A PRACTICE
THAT TREATS PEOPLE DIFFERENTLY
BASED ON WHERE THEY WERE BORN.
AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY OVER THE
PHONE AND SUPPORTER TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
DIRECTLY IMPACTED. LIABLE RUE
IS AN IMMIGRANT FROM ETHIOPIA
WHO IS CURRENTLY A STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY AND
A MEMBER OF THE SURVIVED AND
PUNISHED OF SURVIVED AND
PUNISHED ADVOCATING FOR VICTIMS
OF VIOLENCE AND IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS. AND GOD LOS ANGELES
GREW UP IN LA AND WAS
INCARCERATED AS A YOUTH HE
FOUNDED A CROCHET PROGRAM WHILE
IN PRISON AFTER SERVING TWENTY
NINE YEARS. WAS DIRECTED
DIRECTLY HANDED TYSON NEARLY
DEPORTED. TODAY HE IS A DRUG
AND ALCOHOL COUNSELOR SERVING
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
COMMUNITIES IN LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU. TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES ARE FOR TO TESTIFY
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES TOTAL
ONE MINUTE HAPPY TO SHOW YOU
MAYBE GET ONE READY. THANK YOU
HELLO NUMBER CARILLO LABOR SHIP
ON THE SCALE- HELLO CARE ABOUT
BREEDING COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS ALEA OF BLUE AND RED
AND I'M OFFERING CALIFORNIA AND
CURRENTLY. MAJORING IN
SOCIOLOGY I AM ALSO AN
ORGANIZER WITH THE VIKING
PUNISH CALIFORNIA WILL WORK IT
OUT GRILLING ALIVE. IMMIGRANT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS. I
CAN'T BELIEVE I NINETY NINETY
NINE BUT MY OLDEST OF AND MY
MOM TOOK ME TO WALK. FROM THE
COUNTRY OF THE BILL AFTER A FEW
YEARS I RETURNED TO THE CHINA
TO HELP TAKE CARE OF MY MOTHER
WHO WAS. WITH SEVERE HEART. BY
HOPING TO TAKE CARE OF MY
MOTHER I OPENED UP MY OWN
BUSINESS. TWENTY I MET MY-
BECAUSE WHO WAS. IN THE-
MILITARY. TWENTY FOURTEEN AFTER
TWO YEARS OF MARRIAGE WE MOVED
TO CALIFORNIA TO WHERE I
THOUGHT ALL NATIONS SHOULD
COULD BE FILLED WITH LOVE.
HAPPINESS AND PEACE.
UNFORTUNATELY MY MARRIAGE ENDED
UP IN A NIGHTMARE THAT BECAME
VERY PROTECTIVE THE BLACKLIST.
BY THE END OF TWENTY FOURTEEN I
WAS ELECTED. AND PROSECUTED FOR
THE BETTER MYSELF AGAINST MY
DEEPEST BACKGROUND WHO
CONDUCTED TOOK EVERYTHING. OF
THE- I WOULD. THINK YOU'RE A
STATE I THANK. WANT CONFLATED
NOT ONLY DID I HARD ON MY BUT
I'LL IN MY DEGREE I'M MILES ON
CREDIT FOR GOOD BEHAVIOR I
THINK THE CHARACTER TO YOURSELF
I THANK THEM. HOWEVER. IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY. WHAT WAS
THE MARKET AND BEEN. THEY ARE
INSTEAD MEALS I WHILE TRANSFER
TO LAW I IN PRISON FOR THE-
CRITTENTON. EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND
I THINK QUESTIONS PALOMAR
DURING THE ARTICLE CONDEMNED
THE LAST. ONE MORE SPENT ALL OF
MY OF PEOPLE. CAN DO OF THE CAR
ARE DON'T THAT KNOWS YOU
MENTIONED BE THE- BEST DURING
THE CALL AND- BY THE GRACE OF
GOD I WOULD BEFORE I GOT. THE
EXTREME MARKET. AND FACT. I
UNDERSTAND AND POORLY ATTENTION
COMBINE WITH OFF AND DOCTORS
THE GLASS AND DEMOCRATS ALL
HAVE NOT MANY TO CLEAN AT THE
END WITH CORN OF AND I THINK
THE QUESTION. I'M GRATEFUL BE
HOME NOW FOR TWENTY OCT. THREE
OF THE BY MY COMMUNITY
INCLUDING THOSE BY THE COLLEGE
BUT YOU SEE THE WALKED IT AND
THEN ARE IN THE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I AM HOW NOT A NINE
THAT MANY IMMIGRANTS REFUGEES
WELCOME TO BE PUNISHED AFTER
STARTING QUITE WHY THEY BE
QUITE A NEED TO TACKLE THE TEST.
I'M SORRY. IF YOU CAN RECORD TO
MONNING. YEAH I ALWAYS AMERICAN
WAS HOPING TO BE A MODEL FOR
PRESS NATION'S AS BLACK FROM
BUT EXTREME THAT THE THAT IT
HAS SELDOM THAT'S WHY THE
VISION AFTER DON'T TO ME IT
WOULD BY CHANCE BEEN A GROUP OF
REFUGEES GOING THERE HI IN
WHICH WEINER. THAT WOULD LOVED
ONES ARE WE FOR THE TO COME
HOME. YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE
FOR THE COMING AND PUNISH THE
OF OUR- EVERYONE DESERVES A
CHANCE AND I YOUR- YEAH FOR A
NINE THIRTY MONDAY NOT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE WITNESS.
MISTER MOON JOOSS. MONTEREY DO
WE HAVE MISTER MOON YES PREPARE
TO TESTIFY. MODERATOR I THINK
ALL IT IS- ON MUTED. YOU CAN GO
AHEAD AND SPEAK. BURKE FORTY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PROBABLY KNOWS I CAME TO LA
ENGAGED IN YOUR SOUL WITH MY
MOTHER WHO FLED THE
METROPOLITAN MEXICO. ABOUT A
PUBLIC FIGURE AND A MOTHER WHO
SPENT THE MAJORITY OF RETURN
WORKING I SAW LOVE AND SAFETY
ELSEWHERE THEY INCLUDE A
MECHANISM THAT CAN MEMBERS
UNDER PRESSURE OF THE VIOLENCE
IN THE PLEDGE OF LED ME TO JOIN
A. GANG AS A TEENAGER. IMPORT
ATTEMPTS YEARS OLD I WAS. FROM
RELATED MY NOT. AFTER. BUT THE
CRIMINALS YOU'VE BEEN WITH YOUR
OBJECTIVES UNFORTUNATELY I WAS
GIVEN A LICENSE TO THE PUBLIC
MOST. WELL OF COURSE RATED I
DECIDED TO INVESTMENT IN MY
EDUCATION AND START TRAINING
VOCATIONAL SKILLS ALSO FUNDED
COACHING PROGRAM WHERE PROJECTS
ARE DONATED TO MILITARY BRAT.
FIFTY PEOPLE TO BRING A THIRTY
TWO GALLON IN A SENSE OF SELF
COURT. ARE RELEASED TO THE
RIGOROUS POLL BUT YOU PROCESS
DURING MY TWENTY NINTH YEAR IN
PRISON. OR WHETHER UNITED WITH
MY FAMILY I WAS TRANSFERRED TO
I. WANT THEM TO CONTINUE. TO BE
INVOLVED IS BELIEVED. RICHARD
PRIOR TO I COULD TENSIONS AND
WORKS. INTO ACTION TO MY- IT
WAS STORMING ONE ARE THE NORM
REQUEST FOR DOORS PLACE ONE OF.
STALL FOR PRIVACY THE CARP. NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING DETAINEES WERE.
MORE ACTIONS PER TARGET. AN
EXTRA WILL DEBATE COULD NOT
CARE. WHAT YOU'RE DOING WAS
RELEASED FROM MARKHAM THAT
TWENTY TWO ONE AFTER THE LIST
OF THAT MANY OTHERS ONE
REPORTED. ACTIVE LONG AND P.
JOURNEY TODAY I AM PROUD TO SAY
MARKET AND LOOK ANGELES OF THE
DRUG CAL. REGINEK SB NINETY
SEVEN APART TO PREVENT FROM.
OTHER LIVES. HELLO FROM TO OUR
AFTER MIGHT WASN'T EIGHTY BY
EXPERTS. PLEASE VOTE YES ON THE
VISION THAT TO STOP I STRONG
STOP WITH THE PRE OF BERMAN.
AND STOPPING TOWARDS OF
IMMIGRANT INCOME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NOW WILL
MOVE TO WITHIN HERE AND FOR
TWO- THROUGH WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF. AB NINE THREE
SEVEN WE NEED YOU STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION PLACE.
BUT THERE IS BASICALLY I AM
WITH ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA. IS WORKING-
OUR- OF THIS BILL ALONG WITH
THE WITH THESE ORGANIZATION
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL BLACK ALLIANCE FOR JUST
IMMIGRATION CENTRAL COAST
ALLIANCE UNITED FOR A
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY FREEDOM FOR
IMMIGRANTS INDIVISIBLE VENTURA
AND LAND COALITION FOR
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE. LONG BEACH
SOUTHEAST ASIAN ANTI
DEPORTATION COLLECTIVE NATIONAL
DAY LABOR ORGANIZATION
ORGANIZING NETWORK RESILIENCE
OC SOUTH BAY PEOPLE POWER SIXTY
SEVEN SWING YOU KNOW IS SHOWING
UP FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE MARIN
COUNTY COALITION FOR THE HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CHIRLA. VOICES
FOR PROGRESS EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES LONG BEACH EMIGRANT
RIGHTS COALITION AND CHANGE
BEGINS WITH ME INDIVISIBLE WERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE DOWN JASON
ROUSER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER PART BECAUSE SPONSOR
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDING ME TO
USE ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FRIENDS SERVICE COMMITTEE SAN
DIEGO. WHEN THE SCENE-
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS COMMUNITY UNITED
AGAINST VIOLENCE HOMIES WE NEED
THOSE SEEKING INDIVISIBLE SAN
JOSE ME FOR THAT MATTER THE OF
VOTER RESTORE JUSTICE. SERVICES
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND EDUCATION
NETWORK SIREN YOUNG WOMAN'S
FREEDOM CENTER INDIVISIBLE
SAUSALITO CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HELP NETWORK C. PENN. CENTRAL
B. NACIONAL PARA EL DE SOTO A-
IN THE HAND I WILL HOW CAN YOU
SEE VIDEO CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE FAITHFUL
FRIENDS COULD CREATE COMMUNITY
CENTER OF THE EAST BAY. AND SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE THANK YOU WHERE IT'S
TRANSPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. HELLO MY NAME IS
RUNNING LARGE COM AS THE SON OF
IMMIGRANT FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER NEVER GRANDPARENTS
ON BEHALF OF THE SERVICES OF
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF AB NINE
THIRTY SEVEN. AND ARE JUST AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
A CODE OF. GOOD AFTERNOON- THE
NOT THE RESTAURANT FROM
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
AT UC BERKELEY AND I URGE YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR. THIS BILL
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KEVIN MCCARTY ON BEHALF OF THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
PRE LAW COHORT WE STAND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MCCARTY GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS KELLY WALTERS I'M A STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN WE ARE
A CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND AS
AN ATTORNEY AND A GRANDDAUGHTER
OF IMMIGRANTS I STRONGLY
SUPPORTED THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SHANTI
SHEA AS A MEMBER OF THE STATE
WIDE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
INITIATIVE AND LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
THIS. GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN
CANNON POLICY FOR THE WAY LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN MEMBER OF ALL OF US
ARE NOT EMPOWER SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. JESSE COLLIDE
BURLISON LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND ALL
OF LISTEN NINE. GRAND SON OF A
MATERNAL GRANDFATHER WHO WAS
DEPORTED TO MEXICO. A STRONG
SUPPORT. TRUANTS COMMUNICATIONS
MANAGER FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN
REMEMBER ALL OF THIS IS NOT A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SIR ANYONE ELSE HERE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE SEEN KNOWN
COMING FOR WILL MOVE OVER TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO
ONE THERE AS WELL. NOW MODERATE
WILL GO TO OUR PHONE LINES AND
SEEING IF THERE ARE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. OF AB. NINE THREE
SEVEN. IF YOU WISH TO COME IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE THREE SEVEN
IN A PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT AND FOR US TO
GO TO LINE THREE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I WANT
TO LINE A ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND KAREN LAYING ON
TOP OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR THE TO
LINE THREE NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK PLEASE. AND I'M
THE FUNDING. FOR SO THE TO LINE
THREE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON SHARON NUMBERS NINE
ONE EVOLUTION ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANKS TO GO TO LINE
TWO SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MARTIN THE DOCUMENTS
ON BEHALF OF NAY ROUTE PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANKS FOR THE TIME
THREE OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIC
MORE SIMPLER ON BEHALF OF PAUL
FLANK AND THE ALLIANCE OF BOYS
MEN OF COLOR WE ARE COSPONSORED
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE
THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANKS
FOR THE TO MIND ONE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
SERRA REGNI ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE ACCESS AND TRANSPORT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALSO WITH THE
USE OF HIS COALITION BASE IN
SOUTH CENTRAL FOR SPONSORS
DOLLARS. FOR THANKS TO THE TO
LINE FOUR OH ONE. FOUR ZERO ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS TONY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MEXICO
TO LINE FOUR OH THREE FOUR ZERO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR FIRST
PLAYING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
BABY ABOUT THREE NINE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE FOUR HUNDRED LINE FOUR
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS NOT A WHOLE SESSION ON
THE FLOTUS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT AND WE DO APOLOGIZE
FOR BEING LATE SUPPORT. THANKS
TO THE TIMELINE THREE NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SB SURE
OF HER ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. CEMEX OF THE
TIMELINE FOR SEVENTEEN FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS OSCAR SAID
OF ALL THE WORK YOU KNOW
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT AB NINE
THREE SEVEN THANK YOU. IN
MEXICO TO LINE THREE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JADI RODRIGUEZ WHEN ASKED
FAMILIES UNITE AND ALOT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. MEXICO TO LINE THREE
NINETY NINE THREE HUNDRED NINE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHN
GLOBALLY FROM NORTHEAST
DEMOCRATIC BY THE LOS ANGELES
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS FOR
THE TO LINE FOR EIGHTEEN FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS KILLING
LIMóN FROM CATHOLIC COMMUNITY
SYNAGOGUE IN THE EAST BAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOR TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THE MUNICIPIUM OF THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION PROUD
CO SPONSOR LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT ABOLISH ICE.
THANKS FOR THE TO LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE OR
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI JOSH IT. CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
CONSTRUCTS COURT. THANKS TO THE
TO LINE FOR TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BRIAN FOR ON BEHALF
OF SECURE JUSTICE HEARING
STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE FOR TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND I SAID TO LISTEN
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA. STRONG
I REPRESENT EIGHTY ONE
INDIVISIBLE GROUPS ACROSS THE
STATE AS WELL AS IN OUR
TOLERANCES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE THREE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARYLAND CLEVELAND WITH THE
BERKELEY SOCIETY A FRIEND IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS TO THE TO LINE TWO OH
SIX TWO OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK OF BAR WOULD IMAGINE
ACTION OC A STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS TO THE TO
LINE FOUR OH EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DON'T QUORUM FROM
COMMUNITY LEGAL SERVICES THEY
NEED A LONG TERM WERE STRONG
SUPPORTER. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE TO- FOR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TOOL FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MOVE O TO LINE ONE
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
THINGS THAT ARE POSSIBLE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
COMPLIANCE. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE FOR TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS THE STUDY OUR
GOVERNMENT WITH PRIDE INSURANCE
AND WE ARE TRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANKS TO THE%
TIMELINE FOR THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS A LIFE THE CHUMP
FROM THE CENTER FOR EMPOWERING
REFUGEES AND IMMIGRANTS IN
OAKLAND WE ARE CO SPONSORS AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE FOR
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS LISA BENNETT CO SPONSORED A
BILL WITH AYE SENATE MARIN ALSO
WOULD INDIVISIBLE SAUSALITO AND
SEARCH MARIN WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANKS
FOR THE TO LINE FOR THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PIETISTIC PAGO
ARE FROM CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
RIGHT WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. MEXICO TO LINE FOR
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS FRANCESCA
WANDER I AM A MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG
INDIVISIBLE REPRESENTING-
INDIVISIBLE SAN FRANCISCO
SACRAMENTO AND YOLO COUNTIES AS
WELL AS NORTH CALORIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MICHIGAN TO MIND FOR FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
PRINCE IGOR AND I'M FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD MY DAD TRANSFERRED TO
ICE AFTER SERVING TIME IN JAIL
ON BEHALF OF INTERFAITH
MOVEMENT FOR HUMAN INTEGRITY
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK TO GO TO LINE FOR
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY THE
GIVES THE BEST PHONE WITH
RESILIENCE ORANGE COUNTY AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY RAPID
RESPONSE NETWORK BOTH PUT ONTO
THE BILL ON THE PART OF THE
VISION ACT. THANKS WILL GO TO
LINE FOUR OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS WILLIE
LUKA I'M WITH WHEN THE STATE-
IN VENTURA COUNTY CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT WE ARE CO
SPONSOR. THANKS FOR THE TO LINE
FOR TWELVE. I- TO SEVENTY ONE
NINE TWO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I TWO SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINES OPEN. I WILL GO TO LINE
THREE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MICHELLE
SAKE- FROM ORANGE COUNTY RAPID
RESPONSE NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANKS FOR THE TO LINE
THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAND FELIZ
HOLD ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANKS FOR THE TO LINE FOR
ELEVEN FOUR HUNDRED ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PARENTS ARE
NOT A GRASSY RESULT POLICY
DIRECTOR AT ALLIANCE SAN DIEGO
ALLIANCE SAN DIEGO IS PROUD TO
BE A CO SPONSOR THE BILL ISN'T
STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS FOR THE
TIP LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND FOUR
FOUR OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SANDER LANGLEY FROM NEIL FROM
MARC MARON THE HALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANKS FOR
THE TO LINE FOUR OH TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY FREEDOM FOR IMMIGRANTS A
PATH BECAUSE ONCE EVERYTHING IS
DONE TO PRINT AT THE VISION.
THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A TWO MINUTE
WARNING WE GIVE EACH SIDE
FIFTEEN MINUTES OVER THIRTEEN
MINUTES INTO TESTIMONY SO. JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
THE TO LINE FOR NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS REVEREND ALLISON TAYLOR
PASTOR OF LAKE SHORE AVENUE
BAPTIST CHURCH IN OAKLAND MY
CONGREGATION IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETY SEVEN.
THANKS FOR THE TO LINE FOR
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARKET BIGGER WITHOUT BIG
PEOPLE POWER IT WOULD CAUSE
BONTA AND INSTRUCT THE PORT OF
THE VISION ACT THANK YOU. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FOR THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
GRACE NINE WITH HUMAN RIGHTS
WATCH AND WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS OF THE
VISION BACKED. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE FOR FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS HERE AND WITH
ASIAN PRISONER SUPPORT
COMMITTEE IN OAKLAND WORK HOW
CO SPONSORS EMERGED ON THE PART
OF THE VISION ACT. THANKS OF
THE TO LINE FOUR OH SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS MEREDITH
WILL CONCERN AND I'M WITH THE
NETWORK IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
PEOPLE OF GUATEMALA CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE VISION
ACT. THANKS FOR THE TO LINE
THREE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
SENATE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. QUITE
TRAVELED WITH THE BAND THE ARC-
A JEWISH ACTION AS WELL AS THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY NOTHING BUT MAKE THIS
IMMIGRANTS HAPPIER THAN TO SEE
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANKS FOR THE TO
NINE THREE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING BARCO
GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE TO
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ERICA
I'M FROM UTICA COALITION AND-
FONG. THANK YOU THIS MODERATOR
WE REACHED OUR FIFTEEN MINUTE
MARK FOR TEST OF TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. AND WE'RE GONNA TO
PAULA JONES FOR THE REST OF THE
CALLERS IN QUEUE NOW WE HAVE TO
MOVE THE OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THEY WILL BE
AFFORDED. A THREE MINUTE TO A
MINUTE HAVE EACH WE HAVE CORD
CELLS LOL AND WE HAVE JONATHON
FELDMAN ARE THEY PREPARED TO
TESTIFY THE STOCK. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY SOCIAL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION AB
NINE THIRTY SEVEN. AS WE STATED
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE DEBATE
ABOUT SB FIFTY FOUR SHARES DO
NOT UNDERTAKE IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT. THAT SAID MANY
COUNTIES MADE PUBLIC
CONSIDERABLE INFORMATION ABOUT
PERSONS DETAINED IN JAILS FOR
SUMMER REASONS. ALSO STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
MAY BE ASKED TO PROVIDE SAFETY
BY OTHER AGENCIES. AB NINE
THIRTY SEVEN WOULD ELIMINATE
THE ABILITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO DO EITHER OF THOSE THINGS.
IF THE ACTION HAPPEN TO INCLUDE
AN IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSE. ON THE PART OF THE
OTHER AGENCY. FURTHER
ELIMINATING THE REQUIREMENT
THAT OFFENDERS PLACE OF BIRTH
BE INCLUDED IN BASIC
INFORMATION STORED IN STATE OR
LOCAL CRIMINAL OFFENDER RECORD
INFORMATION SYSTEMS. WILL MAKE
THAT INFORMATION LESS ACCURATE
AND LESS USEFUL TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT RELY UPON
THAT INFORMATION. ACTIVE OF
WHETHER THE PERSON IS SUBJECT
TO ANY IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
ACTION. FOR THESE REASONS AND
THOSE- PREVIOUSLY STATED CSSA
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
NINE THREE SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THIS. MEMBERS
JONATHON FELDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION- IN OPPOSITION AS
THE MEASURE OF BRIDGES SOME OF
THE NEGOTIATED LANGUAGE THAT
WE- WORK TO THE COMPROMISE INTO
SB FIFTY FOUR AND THOSE REASONS
WE ARE POSED IN ASKING ABOUT.
THANK YOU. NOPE MOVING BACK TO
THE KING ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE OTHER WITNESSES HERE AND
OPPOSITION- AB NINE THREE
SEVEN. C. NINE IN OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM IN TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO
ONE THERE AS WELL MODERATOR.
THERE ARE OTHER CALLERS IN Q.
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE THREE
SEVEN.IT WAS TESTIFYING
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THE TIME. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS BY THE
COMMITTEE. CENTER TROUBLED I
JUST HAVE A COUPLE STEPS- SOME
COMMENTS ON THIS ONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- SO. SOME OF YOU
KNOW I'M A DAUGHTER OF
IMMIGRANTS HANNAH ANDERSON
FIRSTHAND AND I'M SENSITIVE TO
THE STRUGGLES THAT IMMIGRANTS
FACE. HOWEVER I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT OUR STATE HAS A DUTY TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE
HERE. SB FIFTY FOUR FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTY ALREADY
PROHIBITED LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
COOPERATING WITH IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS WHEN IT CAME TO A
LONG LIST OF OFFENSES. BUT EVEN
THOSE WHO BROUGHT THAT BILL
FORWARD ULTIMATELY UNDERSTOOD
THAT THERE WERE CERTAIN MORE
HEINOUS OFFENSES THAT IT WAS
ESSENTIAL FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO COOPERATE WITH IMMIGRATIONS.
OFFICIALS ON. THOSE ITEMS THAT
WERE EXCLUDED FROM THAT BILL
INCLUDED SERIOUS AND VIOLENT
FELONIES. AMONG OTHER SERIOUS
OFFENSES. NOW WITH THIS BILL-
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EXTENDING
THAT PROTECTION TO CASES THAT
INVOLVE THINGS LIKE MURDER.
FORCIBLE RAPE TORTURE HE CRIMES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
**** TO NAME A FEW. THERE THESE
ARE CRIMES AT THE STORE THE
LIVES OF THEIR VICTIMS AND
THOSE THAT LOVE THEM. IT IS
BECAUSE OF THOSE VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES BUT I CANNOT
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. IN
ADDITION QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
IN REGARDS CENTER COMMON IN DO
I WANNA. I THINK THE OTHER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. KERN SAID
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. CARRILLO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MAY I ASK A
QUESTION TO THE SENATOR. THE
ISSUE WILL YOU TAKE A QUESTION
SENATOR OTRO BOOK- HOPEFULLY I
CAN ANSWER. DO YOU THE TEACHER
THANK YOU DO YOU BELIEVE THAT A
PERSON WHO HAS. BEEN
INCARCERATED WHO HAS SERVED
THEIR TIME WHO HAS GONE BEFORE
THE PAROLE BOARD IN THE PAROLE
BOARD SAYS. YES YOU ARE
REHABILITATED TO RETURN TO YOUR
HOME. DO YOU BELIEVE THAT A
PERSON THAT IS INCARCERATED HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
REHABILITATED. I'M NOT AN
EXPERT AND NOT. IN THAT FIELD
SITE I DON'T FEEL PREPARED TO
MAKE THAT STATEMENT BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT- PERSONAL NOTE I
WOULD HOPE. THAT THEY WOULD BE
A AT THE ABILITY TO DO THAT.
BUT I THINK IT IT VARIES- AND
SO FORTH BUT I'M NOT AN EXPERT
IN THAT FIELD SO I CAN'T SAY
ONE WAYOR ANOTHER BUT
PERSONALLY I WOULD HOPE. I
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE AND I
GUESS MY FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS.
DO YOU BELIEVE THE PAROLE BOARD
THE THIRD JOB ACCORDINGLY TO
THE LAW TO BE ABLE TO SAY YES
THIS PERSON AS WE HAVE
ALLOCATED BECAUSE THEY ARE IN
FACT THE EXPERTS. I WOULD HOPE
SO BUT THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS
BILL DOES THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE THE PAROLE BOARD IT DOES
NOT CHANGE SENTENCING IT DOES
NOT CHANGE THE INCARCERATION
PROCESS IT DOES NOT TAKE AWAY
THE RESPONSIBILITY AN
OBLIGATION OF THE PAROLE BOARD
TO DO THEIR JOB ITSIMPLY SAYS
IF YOU HAVE COMMITTED A CRIME.
IF YOU HAVE SERVED YOUR TIME IF
YOU GO BEFORE THE PAROLE BOARD
IN THE PAROLE BOARD TO YOUR
POINT ARE THE EXPERTS AND THEY
SAY YES YOU ARE REHABILITATED
AND YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IN
A RIGHT TO RETURN HOME AND BE
WITH YOUR FAMILY. IF THE ANSWER
IS YES. AND THAT'S ALL WE NEED.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE YOU
WERE BORN WHETHER YOU ARE A
CITIZEN OR RESIDENT OR A TPS
HOLDER OR UNDOCUMENTED. WE HAVE
CREATED A SYSTEM IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT
UNFORTUNATELY. TREATS PEOPLE
JUST SIMPLY BECAUSE OF WHERE
THEY WERE BORN DIFFERENTLY AND
UNEQUAL. AND I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
YOU BUT I'M NOT OKAY WITH THAT.
I'M NOT OKAY WITH CALIFORNIA
CREATING A JUSTICE SYSTEM. THAT
TREATS PEOPLE DIFFERENTLY BASED
ON THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN. AND
WHERE THEY WERE BORN WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW THANK YOU. AND IF I MAY
I'LL JUST CLOSE FAR WILL ALLOW
YOU TO MAKE YOUR CLOSE THANK
YOU I WANT TO BRING INTO THE
SPACE. THE INCARCERATED
FIREFIGHTERS WHO HAD BEEN
DETAINED BY ICE AND ARE FACING
DEPORTATION THE VETERANS WHO
HAVE SERVED THEIR COUNTRY WELL
AND PERHAPS AFTER PTSD AND
OTHER ISSUES HAVE CREATED A
CRIME AND HAVE ALSO FACED ICE
ATTENTION AND DEPORTATION. I
WANT TO BRING INTO THE SPACE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
HAVE A RIGHT TO LIVE WITH
DIGNITY. AND THAT IS WHY THE
VISION ACT IS NOW MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER BEFORE TO
ENSURE. THAT JUSTICE PREVAILS
AND THAT ALL PEOPLE REGARDLESS
OF THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN OR
WHERE THEY WERE BORN. ARE
TREATED EQUALLY IN THE STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU WERE
SEEKING A MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SCISSOR MOTION
ON THIS MEASURE. LOVE BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR CALM WATER.
CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
AB. NINE THREE SEVEN AB NINE
THREE SEVEN BRADFORD ROAD FOR
DIETRO VOGUE NO TROUBLED NODE
TERRAZZO COM LONGER AND LONGER
AYE SKINNER. I BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISS CARRILLO WE HAVE.
MISTER CARTER YOU NEXT. THIS
COOPER WROTE CAN YOU.
GOVERNMENT PLANNING. OKAY YEAH
YEAH ACCORDING. TO ALLOW YOU TO
GO AHEAD SO WE HAVE MISSED
MCCARTY- PRESENT IN ELEVEN
NINETY ONE THANK YOU. FOR A
BELT WE KNOW THAT- WE LAY TO
GUN CRIME IS TOO MUCH IN OUR
STATE WE ALSO KNOW THAT TOO
OFTEN THERE'S A FEW OF THESE
BAD APPLE DEALERS THAT- ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT- SELL THE MOST
AMOUNT TO BE LEGAL I CRIME GUNS
SO THIS BILL WOULD HAVE OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. A LAUNCH A
DIVISION TO STUDY THAT- ISSUE
AB AGAIN- 75% OF ALL CRIME GUNS
ORIGINATE FROM WITH OUR STATE
INTO OFTEN THEY'RE FROM THE
SAME- DEALERS WHICH AREN'T
ALWAYS REPUTABLE DEALERS EFFORT
TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE OUR
FOCUS MUST BE THE NATIONAL
SOURCES OF CRIME GUNS FROM THE
RESPONSIBLE INDIVIDUALS WITH
PROFIT UP TO SELL THESE
FIREARMS INFILTRATOR COMMUTES
ACROSS OUR STATE- WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY. ARE THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN AGAINST VIOLENCE AND
THE COMBATING CRIME GUNS
INITIATIVE IN OAKLAND ASK THE
ARRIVAL THANK YOU. ISRAEL THAT
AFTERNOON. HELLO. YES ONE
MOMENT PLEASE HOLD ON. I
APOLOGIZE AND WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND- WE HAVE LEAD SUPPORT
ERICA RIGHT ON THE LINE I
BELIEVE. YES OKAY PLEASE
RECEIVE DIRECT. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ERICA WRIGHT AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALFOF BRADY OUR
NATIONAL GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION ORGANIZATION AND THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE
COMBATING CRIME DEFINITION AND
OAKLAND I CITY WITH NO BRICK
AND MORTAR GUN STORES BUT WHEN
PEOPLE IMPACTED BY EVERYDAY
CUMBERLAND FINANCING AT THE
CORE AT EIGHT ELEVEN NINETY
ONE. THE PROGRAM MANAGER OF
BRADY THE MAJORITY OF MY WORK
HAPPENED ON THE COMMUNITY LEVEL
OFFICIAL WORKER BY TRADE I'M A
HUGE BELIEVER AND PAYING MUCH
ATTENTION TO APARTMENT
ENVIRONMENT I THANK YOU THAT
MAKING HERE I HAVE A PLEASURE
OF LEARNING FROM FRONT LINE
WORKERS DOING VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION
WORK AND HAVE BEEN ALARMED BY
HOW FREQUENTLY THE DISCUSSION
TURNED THE FIREARM AND INCREASE.
THE CREDIBILITY AND THE LAST
YEAR. RIGHT BIKE EVERYONE HAVE
A GOOD IN THE STREETS RIGHT NOW
OR NOT UNCOMMON. WHICH IS WHY
THE TIME IS NOW TO FOCUS THE
SIDE SOLUTION. AB ELEVEN NINETY
ONE ALLOW HEALTH ACT AND ISSUE
A ON CRIMES AND PER. AND ALLOW
THE CALIFORNIA DOJ TO PROPERLY
ANALYZE EVALUATE AND REPORT ON
THE AVAILABLE DATA AND
INFORMATION REGARDING GUN
DEALERS AND CRIME GANGS AND A
MEANINGFUL AND LYFT DATING WAY.
ARAMBULA PROVIDE VALUABLE
INSIGHT AND A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW CRIME GUNS
ARE BEING DIVERTED INTO THE
CRIMINAL MARKET. BY IDENTIFYING
IRRESPONSIBLE OR NEGLIGENT
FIREARM DEALERS. THAT
PRIORITIZE PROFIT OVER PUBLIC
SAFETY CALIFORNIA'S LEGISLATOR.
CAN PROPERLY ADDRESS A GROUP
BECAUSE OF GUN VIOLENCE THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. I WOULD
AND INTERVENTION ON THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL IS AND WILL
REMAIN A VITAL PART OF REDUCING
GUN VIOLENCE. HOWEVER I BELIEVE
HOLDING BOTH COULD PROFIT FROM
GUN VIOLENCE ACCOUNTABLE IN THE
SAME WAY WE HOPE THOSE WHO
CALLS HARM IS ESSENTIAL AND
COMPLIMENTS THE MAYOR CREDIT
CARD CHEN. FOR THIS REASON I
URGE YOU TO CLASS AB. ELEVEN
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
MORE PRIMARY WOULDN'T SAID
FULLER. MATTIE SCOTT YES GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS MATT
SCOTT AND I'M THE FOUNDER OF
HEALING FIVE MEMBERS AND
NOMINATIONS AND ALL SOLD THE
PROPER THEN OF BRADY UNITED
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY WELL DONE BUT THE GUN
VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC TODAY. AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF BRADY
UNITED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE IN
THE BACKGROUND THE NOMINATION
MUGS AND CHARGE A MINUTE BROWN
THE IMPACTED BY GUN VIOLENCE IN
THE BAY AREA AND THEN
CALIFORNIA. IS SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE. JULY
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN NINETY SIX
I LOST MY YOUNGEST SON GEORGE
C. SCOTT EIGHT TWENTY FOUR.
YOUNG AFRICAN AMERICAN FATHER
OF TWO YOUNG AFRICAN AMERICAN
BOYS. GABLE FIVE INCOME ON TO.
THIS SATURDAY JULY SEVENTEENTH
WILL BE TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO
MY SON WAS SHOT AND KILLED WITH
A SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPON. I'M
THAT PROBABLY CAME FROM THE
STREET. THE NEXT DAY JULY
EIGHTEENTH. WAS MY GRANDSON BE
ABLE SIX BIRTHDAY EVERY YEAR
INCLUDING THIS YEAR IT'S NOT
PAINFUL HEARTBREAKING TIME FOR
ME AS A MOTHER AND A
GRANDMOTHER WHO LOST MY SON THE
GUN BY AND- THEN I HAVE
DEDICATED MY LIFE TO PREVENTING
GUN VIOLENCE HERE IN THE BAY
AREA CALIFORNIA AND NATIONWIDE
AND TO HELP COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED BY GUN VIOLENCE. IN
THE PAST YEAR WE'VE SEEN. GUN
VIOLENCE DIE ROCKET IT. THIS
CALL ALL SAN JOSE LA CAL. AND
ACROSS OUR NATION THERE IS NO
DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT MOST
CRIME GUNS YOU COME FROM
OUTSIDE I'LL SEE YOU THEN IN
MANY CASES OUTSIDE OUR STATE.
THE B. MERGING SEA IS ON THE
RADAR FOR EXEMPTS THE COMPANY
SHE GOT WHAT WORK CLOSELY WITH.
LOCAL NOW HAS THIRTY ONE HOME
THE FACT. THAT ALSO OAKLAND
POLICE CHIEF ROB ARMSTRONG.
ALSO EVP IN AMERICAN WITH
SEVENTY ONE HOMICIDE. AND NOW
SOME OF THE MAYOR SAM LICCARDO.
WHAT FORTY ONE ON THE BALLOT
MET RECENTLY WITH PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN TO ADDRESS DONE BY. AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE WILL EMPOWER
THE STATE WHAT INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW GUNS ARE MAKING THEIR
WAY INTO OUR COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY OUR BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE MOSTLY
IMPACTED. SO THAT WE CAN TAKE
CONTROL AND TAKE ACTION NOW
BURKE MAKING ALL CALIFORNIA
STATE. I'M TIRED OF GOING TO
FUNERALS I WANT TO GO TO
GRADUATIONS I'M WANT TO GO TO
WORK AND BE SAFE AND NOT GET
SHOT. I WANT TO AGAIN JUNE AND
THE GARLIC PRESS THE
CELEBRATION AND OTHERS AND NOT
BE SHOCKED. I ASK YOU AS A
MOTHER AND A GRANDMOTHER AND A
MAN OF COURSE YOU HAVE TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. OF ALL OF THIS HARD
WORK. A LOT OF MY SON GEORGE
HE'S GOT. PLEASE SUPPORT AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE AND IN
SUPPORT OF ALL THE VICTIMS THAT
THE B. T. EIGHT THAT WAS MURDER.
OF ALL TWO HUNDRED AND NINE.
ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE A BIG JUMP
OFF THEIR LIVES AND JUST
SEVERAL BASS SAN FRANCISCO
OAKLAND. COMBINED TOGETHER AND
ALL OF THE FAMILY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA PLEASE WE ACTUALLY
TOOK OUR- COURT A. B. ELEVEN
NINETY ONE BECAUSE THIS IS
ABOUT ALL OF US ARE NOT ABOVE
PLEASE HELP WITH THE STOP THE
KILLING THANK YOU START EIGHTY
DOLLARS THANK YOU TECHNICAL MY
LAST MONTH. NOW WILL MOVE BACK
TO THE ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
ARE THERE WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN NINETY
ONE. SHINO ONE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM WITH TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE EITHER.
MODERATE OR LET'S GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES INTO THEIR
WITNESSES. WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB. ELEVEN NINETY
ONE ON FOREIGN MARKETS. YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. INTEREST
TO GO TO LINE THREE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT EVENING
CHAIR NUMBER MICHELLE PALMER
SHOP REPRESENTING THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THUNDERSTONE OFTEN Q. RIGHT
WELL LET'S MOVE TO OPPOSITION-
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
LISTED HERE. R. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE AND FORTY TWO OLD THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. ELEVEN
NINETY ONE. SEE NO ONE. IN
THERE AND IF NO ONE IN TWENTY
FOUR THE FORTY EITHER.
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES AND SEE IF THERE ARE
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. ELEVEN NINETY
ONE. IF YOU LIKE TO COME IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN NINETY
ONE IN A PRESS ONE IF YOU'RE A
TIME. AND WE HAVE NOT WANTING
TO- RIGHT O. K. WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS FOR
THE SUMMER MCCARTY AS RELATES
TO AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE. NINE
NINE MISS MCCARTY WITH ARTICLES
THANK YOU I KNOW THERE'S A WAY
TOO MUCH GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR
STATE AND THIS ISN'T A DEBATE
ABOUT THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS
AN ISSUE ABOUT HOW WE CAN FOCUS
ON THE GUN TRAFFICKERS OF
PEOPLE GETTING GUNS IN THE
WRONG HANDS THIS WILL ADD FLOUR
TURNING GENERAL DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE TO HELP. GIVE US MORE
TOOLS TO GET ALLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO FOCUS ON THE BAD
ACTORS WITH THAT ASK THE RIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'RE
SEEKING A MOTION ON. AB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE TO DO FOR US TO
APPROPRIATIONS IS OUR MOTION
FOR THIS MATTER. HELLO IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR COM
LONGER COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON IT AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE BRADFORD
HI I PROVIDE CHOI BOGUE I
TOWBOAT GUIDE TERRAZZO COM
LOGGER. AMONG- I SKINNER.
MEASURE HAS THREE VOTERS. I
WILL LEAVE ROQUE FOR APTIMA.
NEXT UP HAVE. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE BY SENATOR ASSEMBLY
LUMBERTON CRISTINA GARCIA.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE WOULD
REPEAL THE EXISTING SPOUSAL
RAPE PROVISION IN CALIFORNIA
LAW AND WILL PROVIDE EQUITY
VICTIMIZATION NOT BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE OF THEIR
MARCH STATUS KRYLOV MINIMIZES
THE IMPACT OF RAPE AND HAVE
HOUSE ON MARRIED INDIVIDUALS IN
THIS BILL ALLOWS SIMILAR
OUTCOMES FOR BOTH MARRIED AND
UNMARRIED BIG BANDS THERE ARE
NOW ONLY NINE STATES THAT
DISTINGUISHED ALSO RAPE FROM
NORTH SOUTH OF RAPE IN THE
UNITED STATES. I AM I ENOUGH.
IF AN INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT BY A
STRANGER OR EVEN THEIR PARTNER
WHICH WITH THEY HAVE FOUGHT FOR
A YEARS LONG RELATIONSHIP THE
ACT THIS DRAMATIC AND IS
CARRIED ON FOR A LIFETIME IT'S
NO DIFFERENT WHEN THEY ARE MADE
BY SPELLS SPELLS EXPERIENCE
RAPE EXPERIENCE RAPE SUFFER
FROM LONG LASTING PHYSICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL EFFECTS FROM
THEIR EXPERIENCE. A HANDFUL
STUDIES HAVE FOUND
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
FEAR ANXIETY DEPRESSION AND
SEXUAL FUNCTION TO BE
CONSEQUENCES AMID A WAVE. OF MY
CHOICE AND DOESN'T MAKE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF RAPE ANY LESS
SEVERE. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
WAS SIMPLY FOR FIGHT PARITY IN
CALIFORNIA LAW. IT WOULD
REQUIRE THIS THING SANDERS A
SELF RATE THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
PENAL CODE FOR NON SPOUSAL.
RAPE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT I HAVE TIME FRANCISCO
DISTRIBUTORS THE ATTORNEY. SAYS
THAT THE DEAN AND THE PRESIDENT
OF CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION. FOR WOMEN HOLIKA
SIEGEL. ESPECIALLY I VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE. D. A. BUILDING.
THANK YOU CHAIR BRADFORD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME
AND YOUR ATTENTION ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE I ALSO WANT TO
SPECIALLY THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA PROVIDING THE- SPEAK
TODAY. ALSO SPECIAL THANKS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA AND
SENATOR CORTEZ BEFORE SERVING
AS CHAMPIONS FOR SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT. ROSTERING THIS
CHANGE IN THE LAW. AS OUR
COMMUNITIES CALL FOR RAISING
VICTIMAS REVIVAL VOICES FOR
HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE THOSE WHO
ENGAGE IN ACTS OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE CALIFORNIA LAW
CONTINUES TO PERPETUATE
CENTURIES OLD INHUMAN IN IN
AQABA PRACTICES THAT REINFORCE
THE IDEA THAT A SPOUSE IS
SEXUAL PROPERTY AND PROVIDE
THEIR VOCAL CONSENT WHICH IS
WRONG. IT MUST BE CORRECTED AND
THIS LAW WOULD CORRECT IT AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE PROVIDES
PARITY IN CALIFORNIA LAW IT
WOULD REQUIRE THE SAME
STANDARDS FOR SPOUSAL RAPE THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PENAL
CODE. FOR RAPE. RATED UNIVERSE
ACKNOWLEDGED AS A CRIME OF
VIOLENCE THAT IS BOTH
PHYSICALLY AND PSYCHOLOGICALLY
HARMFUL TO THE VICTIM.
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE WORKING TO
GET UNDER SPECIAL RAPE LAWS MAY
FACE LESS SEVERE SENTENCING AND
OTHER- SENTENCING REQUIREMENTS
AS A RESULT OF THE EGAL
RELATIONSHIP IN OTHER WORDS
THOSE WHO ARE UNABLE TO GET
MARRIED WHETHER BECAUSE OF
CLASS SEXUAL ORIENTATION
RELIGIOUS OBSTACLES OR WHATEVER
ELSE. ARE DENIED THE PRIVILEGE
AND- EQUAL TREATMENT. AS
COMPARED. TO THOSE WHO ARE
MARRIED. WHEN MERYL IS NOT
TREATED AS SERIOUSLY AS OTHER
FORMS ARE GREAT IT INVALIDATES
THE VICTIMS PROMETIC EXPERIENCE
AND CONTINUE TO PROMOTE RAPE
CULTURE. CRIMES INVOLVING
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND VIOLENCE
HAVE A UNIQUE IMPACT ON
SURVIVORS OFTEN LAYERED WITH
EXTENSIVE TRAUMA RESPONSES THAT
CAN LAST A LIFETIME. LONG
LASTING IMPACTS OCCUR
REGARDLESS OF THE RELATIONSHIP
STATUS. I'VE BEEN A SILENT WITH
A SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
WHETHER THEY HAVE NEVER MET
BEFORE WHETHER THEY'RE ON A
FIRST DATE WHETHER THEY'RE IN A
NON- OUR LEGAL MARRIAGE AT
ROCK- HABITATION WELL WHEN THEY
ARE LEGALLY MARRIED. THE
IMPACTS ARE- ALL THE SAME IN
TERMS OF THE LONG LASTING
NATURE OF THE HARM CAUSED
MOREOVER A PERSON WHO COMMITS
RAPE SHOULD NOT BE SHIELDED
ACCOUNTABILITY. SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY ARE LEGALLY MARRIED TO THE
VICTIM CERTIFICATE OF MARRIAGE
COULD NOT PROVIDE FOR MORE
LENIENT OR DESPERATE CRIMINAL
LEGAL OUTCOMES. REGARDLESS OF
THE RELATIONSHIP GREAT IS GREAT.
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
ELIMINATES THE DISTINCTION SO
WE CAN ENSURE JUSTICE FOR ALL
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
REGARDLESS OF THE RELATIONSHIP
THEY HAVE TO THE PERSON WHO
HARM THEM. SPECIFICALLY AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE REPEALS
PENAL CODE SECTION TWO SIX TWO
AND DELETE QUOTE NOT THE SPOUSE
OF THE PERPETRATOR AND QUOTE
FROM PEOPLE CODE SECTION TWO
SIXTY ONE. WORDS FREE TRADE
THAT'S GREAT THIS IS A
PRACTICAL AND NECESSARY CHANGE
IN THE LAW TO ADDRESS AN
ARCHAIC PROVISION OF THE
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE. THAT
DOES NOT PROTECT ALL SURVIVORS
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. AND THAT
TREATS WOMEN AS THE PROPERTY OF
THEIR SPOUSES. THERE IS
PRECEDENT FOR MANY OTHER STATES
AROUND THE COUNTRY SUPPORTING
THIS PROPOSED CHANGE IN LAW IT
WOULD SIMPLIFY THE PENAL CODE.
IT WOULD NOT IN ANY WAY CHANGE
THE BURDEN OF PROOF THAT
PROSECUTORS LIKE MYSELF WOULD
HAVE TO MEET IN A COURT OF LAW
BEFORE SECURING A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION. ALTHOUGH THERE ARE-
MANY STATES THAT HAVE MADE
PROGRESS CALIFORNIA REMAINS
ONE. OF VERY VERY FEW. THAT
FAILS TO MAKE THIS DISTINCTION
OR THAT THAT CONTINUES TO MAKE
THIS DISTINCTION I SHOULD SAY
BETWEEN SPOUSAL RAPE AND NON
SPOUSAL RAPE. THEY COMMONSENSE
REFORM CONSISTENT WITH ALL OF
OUR VALUES- EIGHT REFORM THAT
IS NECESSARY TO TREAT. ALL
WOMEN EQUALLY AND TO CREATE ALL
GREAT EQUALLY. THESE REASONS I
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE TO REPAIR AND INEXCUSABLE
WRONG. THAT LANGUISHES IN OUR
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM AS A
LEGACY THANK YOU THEY- BY LAW
THEY ARE- AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANKS WITH HIS. A SINGLE. GOOD
EVENING- I WANT TO START BY
THANKING EACH AND EVERYONE OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- INTO THE CHAIRS AND
THE BRADFORD FOR GRANTING US IF
HEARING ARE TO BE OUT THERE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
I WANT TO THANK HER AND DINNER
OR GET ME AND ALL OF THE
SENATORS THAT MYSELF AND DOCTOR
DAWBER HAVE SPOKEN WITH OVER
THE LAST FEW WEEKS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO JOIN YOU
TODAY AND FOR TAKING UP THIS
VERY CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. MY NAME IS KANIKA SIEGEL
AND I'M THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL DIVISION
FOR WOMEN AND SINCE OUR
FOUNDING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE ENDING VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN. HAS BEEN ONE OF OUR CORE
A SHE- BUT THE DEGREE CAL. NOW
HAS BEEN AT THE FOR. OF THE
SPELL THE RAPE ISSUE. SAID THAT
EARLIER INTEGRATION IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. SO FOR US IT'S A
LONG OVERDUE. THE RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE SEVENTY
ONE. A CALL FOR AN END TO THIS
PROBLEM A BIG SECTION IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE HEARD THE
STORIES FROM SURVIVORS
THROUGHOUT OUR MEMBERSHIP
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND I'M
HERE TODAY IN GEAR SUPPORTING
THEM. WE ARRIVED TODAY FOR THE
SAFETY AND PROTECTION OF THE
MARRIED WOMAN JUST AS WE WOULD
IN SUPPORT OF THE SINGLE ONE OF
THIS CRIME AND THE IMPACT ON
THE SAME. THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
WE SEE HERE IS THE ANTIQUATED
THINKING SURROUNDING SEXUAL
ASSAULT AN INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE. OUR COLLECTIVE
IGNORANCE. AROUND HOW WE DEFINE
AND YOU MAKE THEM AND THE
DISREGARD FOR THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF CONSENT. I WANT
TO ADD THE INABILITY TO JUST
CALL A SPADE A SPADE. MY
MESSAGE TODAY IS VERY SIMPLE
THAT RAPE IS RAPE IF YOU'RE A
COLLEGE STUDENT WITH THE GRADE
IF YOU'RE A WOMAN OF COLOR
WE'VE BEEN RAISED IF YOU'RE A
TRANS WOMAN WAIT FOR THE RAIN
IF YOU HAVE A DISABILITY AND
RAPE IS RAPE. IF YOU'RE MARRIED
OR NOT. WE A CALIFORNIA NOW ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE WHOLE WOMAN'S
AND THE WHOLE. AND ACROSS THEIR
INTERSECTIONAL IDENTITIES. WE
ASK THAT YOU STAND WITH
SURVIVORS AND WE CALL AN END TO
THE SITUATIONAL SUPPORT THE
VICTIM. AND AB ONE ONE SEVENTY
ONE DOES JUST THAT AND IT WOULD
PROVIDE A PARITY IN CALIFORNIA
LAW REQUIRED THE SAME STANDARDS
FOR THE RAPE OF THE SPOUSE.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
PINOCHLE PENAL CODE FOR THE
RAPE OF A NON SPOUSE. WE WERE
CONVICTED UNDER SMALL THE RED
LINE CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY. FACE
LESS SEVERE SEVENTEEN WHICH IS
UNACCEPTABLE FULL STOP. WHEN
MARITAL RAPE IS NOT TREATED AS
SERIOUSLY AS NON METAL MARITAL
RAPE IT INVALIDATES THE
DRAMATIC IMPACT ON THE
SURVIVORS WE'RE GOING TO NEED
YOU TO CONCLUDE. ONLY PLEASE.
OKAY REVERSIONARY BE SHIELDED
WHICH TRICKS VESSEL TREATMENT
WITHIN THE MOBILE AND THAT
INCLUDES BEING REQUIRED TO
REJECT REGISTER AS A SEX
OFFENDER AFTER BEING CONVICTED
OF SUCH A HEINOUS CRIME OF RAPE
IS RAPE REGARDLESS IN AB ONE
SEVENTY ONE ELIMINATES THAT
DISTINCTION AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. NO WILL MOVE BACK TO
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE OR
THEIR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE YOU STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
GOOD EVENING PATRICK ESPINOSA
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OR COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SHE NINE
WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES INTO THROUGH.
WITNESSES AND- WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE NOW IT'S TIME.
COMMENTS SUPPORT OF AB AND
SEVENTY ONE IN A PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. THAT'S WHAT GO TO LINE
FOR NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON MR
SHARED WITH ALEX CUTLER CALLING
ON BEHALF THE JOYFUL HEART
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. THANKS
TO GO TO NINE ONE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND ALTHOUGH
WE HAVE A NEUTRAL POSITION ON
THIS BILL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OFTEN TALK
WITH THIS WELL AS DISABILITY
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANKS TO THE TIMELINE FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT IS GLAD.
TRANSACTION AND- FOR THE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANKS
FOR THE TO LINE THREE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SAMPLES ALL ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THANKS FOR SURVIVOR AND ON
BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE FARM A
COALITION OF OVER EIGHTY GROUPS
ACROSS THE STATE WE ARE IN FOR
SUPPORT AND WITH GREAT CONTENT.
THANKS ABOUT LINE FIVE OH ONE
FIVE ZERO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT.
YES THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
ELENA FOX I'M CALLING IN TODAY
TO EXPRESS MY ADAM IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE WHICH
ARE GOING PREVIOUS MANAGEMENT.
SO IMPERATIVE TRAFFIC TO DO
SURE NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. RIGHT WHICH WE'RE JUST
NAME AN ORGANIZATION AT THIS
POINT NO MORE TESTIMONY. UP ALL
RIGHT MY APOLOGIES SORRY. THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR THE TO LINE FOR
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LAURIE TO SANTE ON BEHALF OF
THE POLITICAL AT THE FOUNDATION
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY STRONG
SUPPORT GRADE ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE. WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK.
YES HELLO- YEAH- MY NAME IS
SASHA- I MEET YOUR GOALS I LIVE
IN LOOK AND CALIFORNIA- I'M
WITH THE ENOUGH IS ENOUGH VOTER
PROJECT- AND I AM ASKING YOU
HAVE AB ONE ONE SEVEN ONE
PASSED WITHOUT AMENDMENT THANK
YOU. BYE THANK YOU. THANKS OF
THE NINE FOUR NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY HEAR ME. DO YOU. AT
THE TWO ELBE I'M A PROFESSOR
STEM LOS AND I'M ALSO THE CHAIR
OF ENOUGH IS THAT VOTER I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVEN
FOR. AND EQUAL TREATMENT FOR
ALL WOMEN WHO ARE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AND ALL OTHER
SURVIVORS REGARDLESS OF MARITAL
STATUS. AFTER I VOTE. THANKS TO
THE TIMELINE FOR NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
CAROLYN STABLE TURNED ON THE
PUBLIC POLICY OFFICER FOR THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
WE ARE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE THREE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
I'M CALLING FROM THE NATIONAL
CLEARINGHOUSE ON MARITAL AND
DATE RAPE WHICH LED THE
CAMPAIGN IN. NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT NINE AND I AM ABSOLUTELY
THRILLED TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION IT'S DESPERATELY
LONG. ORDER ALREADY EIGHTY SO
PLEASE MAKE IT HAPPEN THANK YOU.
THANKS TO GO TO LINE THREE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING TURN MEMBERS
MACHEL PUNISH ARE REPRESENTING
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS TO LINE TWO
OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
TOO OLD FOR YOUR LINES OPEN.
ONE TWO NINE THREE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
TORY BERBER STYLE BAR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
AND REQUESTING IN VOTING BY.
THANKS FOR THE TO LINE ONE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS CATHERINE POLLS
ARE CALLING AND I AM NOT WRITER
AND SURVIVOR AND I
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT.
EIGHTY ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOR EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
PLEASE CONTINUE HI. THANK YOU-
THIS IS KRISTIN REVERSED- ON
BEHALF OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS WHICH I AM ONE.
PLEASE SHOW YOUR RESPECT OF US
BY PASSING THIS TODAY. AGE DOES
NOT CHANGE THE FACT THAT
CONSENT IS CONSENT AND A LACK
OF CONSENT IS RAPE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE FOR THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY FOUR THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GO ON TO
LINE THREE NINETY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL
GO TO LINE THREE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY MORE.
PEOPLE IN AND I AM A SURVIVOR I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I BOTH.
FOR ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE ON FOR
ALL THE MEMBERS ON THE
COMMITTEE TO STAND WITH
SURVIVORS. THANKS FOR THE TO
LINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANY NAME GENESIS
GONZALEZ CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE TEN THE GOVERNOR OF ANY
GLOBAL MARKETS. SENATE GOVERNOR
THAT CHRONICLED CONCERT AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE SH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL
TODAY THANK YOU. THE MIX OF THE
TWO LINES FOR EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ALEXA COOPER FROM MONTANA
CALIFORNIA WITH ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH VOTER PROJECT AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE
ONE SEVEN ONE. AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO LINE FIVE OH SEVEN PLEASE
PLAN. HI I'M A PROVIDER MY EX
HUSBAND WAS CONVICTED OF
SPOUSAL RAPE- AFTER CONDUCTING
YOU'RE BREAKING UP FOR A DOZEN
TIMES OVER THE COURSE OF A YEAR
AND A HALF. I'M TERRIFIED FOR
MYSELF AND MY DAUGHTER THAT
HE'S GOING TO GET PROBATION IF
YOU CARE ABOUT FAMILY IF YOU
CARE ABOUT CHILDREN PROTECT
THEIR MOTHERS- AND SO IN FAVOR.
IT'S NOT TOO LATE- OTHERS
COMPLETELY Q. THANK YOU. THANKS
FOR THE TO LINE FOR NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LESLIE LOGAN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
FIFTEEN THOUSAND NUMBERS OF
ACTION TOGETHER BAY AREA
INDIVISIBLE GROUP IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE SEVEN ONE.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TWO PRIMARY ME WITNESSES
LISTED. AND OPPOSITION WE HAVE
LISA CALDWELL AND ALLISON'S OF
ALLAH SHOW IF THEY'RE PREPARED
FOR TESTIMONY YOU BOTH HAVE.
THREE MINUTES WELL THREE
MINUTES TOTAL AND A MINUTE AND
HALF EACH. HI MY NAME IS
ALLISON THE DALLAS AND- I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. E. J. OPPOSES
THE SPELL. SO WILL HAMPER THE
JUDGE IN PUNISHING THE
DEFENDANT THE MOST APPROPRIATE
WAY GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
THE OFFENSE AND CONSIDERATION
AND INPUT FROM THE VICTIM.
ALTHOUGH RATED DIFFERENT
WITHOUT THE RATE THERE'S A
SEXUAL HISTORY AND
INTERPERSONAL DYNAMICS AT PLAY.
UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
JUDICIAL DISCRETION AND VICTIM
INPUT NECESSARY. AB ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE WE'RE MAYES JUDICIAL
DISCRETION WHEN REQUIRES
CHRISTMAS IN FACT OFFENDER
REGISTRATION AND ALL CASES
HOWEVER ALL CASES MAY NOT
WARRANT THAT SEVERE OF A
PUNISHMENT. FAMILY AND CHILDREN
MAY BE A PART OF THE SENTENCING
TEAM CURRENTLY THE JUDGE HAS
THE TOOLS TO FASHION A
PUNISHMENT TO ALLOW FOR A
CHANCE TO WORK FOR- FAMILY
REUNIFICATION OR HAVING THE
OFFENDER PROVIDE FOR THE
FAMILY. THAT'S WHAT THE GREAT
FROM ONE. NOT EVERY CASE IS THE
CLAIM. ACTUALLY DEALING CLIENTS
FAMILY THAT. THE LEGISLATURE
NOT BE THE JUDICIAL OFFICER WHO
IS AND THE FACT THE VISION TO
RENDER THE MOST APPROPRIATE
PUNISHMENT GIVEN ALL THE
VARIABLES IN EACH INDIVIDUAL
CASE. A. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
IS NOT THE ANSWER. WOW YEAH
THANK. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
IT. THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS
THIS IS LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. ALL
THERE HAS BEEN DIALOGUE WITH
THE OFFERING OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WE BELIEVE MORE
TIME IS NECESSARY TO UNDERSTAND
THE BILL'S UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT SPELLS WILL RATE IS
ALREADY A CRIME. AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE TAKES DISCRETION
FROM JUDGES DISMISSALS BUT
DESIRES AND NEEDS OF VICTIMS
AND STRIPS DEVELOPMENTALLY AND
PHYSICALLY DISABLED
CALIFORNIANS FROM THE CAPACITY
TO CONSENT TO SEXUAL ACTIVITY
WITH THEIR SPOUSES. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE AS THE RAPE
SURVIVOR MYSELF AND THE MOTHER
OF A RAPE SURVIVOR AS WELL AS
THE CAREER LONG DISTANCE AND
TURNING I CAN SAY WE ALL WANT
TO EMIGRATE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
WOULD CRIMINALIZE THE SEX LIVES
OF MEMORY DEVELOPMENTALLY OR
PHYSICALLY DISABLED BROWSERS
JIM FENDER PANEL CODE SECTION
TWO SIXTY ONE SUB A SUB ONE
THEY WOULD BE DEEMED INCAPABLE.
OF CONSENTING TO SET. ALTHOUGH
CPD UNDER THE DESIGN. TO
RECOGNIZE THE TRAUMA DISPOSAL
RATE AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE IS
BAD PUBLIC POLICY IN THAT IT
TAKES AWAY JUDICIAL DISCRETION
AND IMPOSES A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
CENTERED. ON INDIVIDUALS BY
TAKING AWAY JUDICIAL DISCRETION
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE FORCES
COURTS DIFFERENTLY ABOUT THE
STATE PRISON EVEN IF THE VICTIM
EXPLICITLY STATE THEY DO NOT
NOT WANT PRESENT OR
REGISTRATION BOTH OF WHICH TAKE
AWAY AN INDIVIDUAL'S ABILITY TO
FIND OR KEEP EMPLOYMENT. THAT
VICTIM AND ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
THAT WOULD PLACE. ON THE VICTIM
AND THE CHILDREN. BUDGET
ALREADY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
IMPOSE PRISON AND OR
REGISTRATION ON A DEFENDANT
CONVICTED OF BELGRADE IF THAT
IS THE APPROPRIATE PUNISHMENT
AND TAKING VICTIMS NEEDS INTO
CONSIDERATION FURTHER THERE'S
ALREADY A TENSION IN CALIFORNIA
A LOT BETWEEN THE DESIRE TO
PROJECT DISABLED INDIVIDUALS.
AND RESPECTING THEIR RIGHT THE
CAN CONTROL THEIR OWN LIVES FOR
THESE REASONS WE URGE YOUR NO
VOTE UNTIL SUCH TIME AS THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF AB.
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE CAN BE
ADDRESSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
KNOW WILL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM ARE
THERE ARE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE. C. NINE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S NO ONE
THERE AS WELL. MODERATOR WILL
GO TO OUR PHONE LINES AND IF
THERE ARE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE NOW IS THE TIME FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THE YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE IN THE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. TO THE TO LINE TWO OH
FOUR PLEASE CLASS. AND TO LOOK
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN Q. THIRTY ONE
IN Q. THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE OTHER QUESTIONS ARE
CONCERNED CENTER PROBLEM. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANNA- I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR- BEING
THIS BILL FORWARD I- ACTUALLY
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
TALK ABOUT SEX- FROM A POLICY
STANDPOINT. I PERSONALLY
BELIEVE THAT AS A CULTURE WE-
EXHIBIT INCREDIBLE
SCHIZOPHRENIA- WHAT WE DO
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS IS
INCREDIBLY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
WE ESPOUSE IN PUBLIC- AND WE
ARE- INCREDIBLY PROVINCIAL- AS
A- COUNTRY. WHEN IT COMES TO
SEX BUT IF YOU ASK PEOPLE THE
REAL DEAL- YOU HEAR STORIES
AND- ABOUT THE BEHAVIORS AND
PREFERENCES THAT ARE- VERY FAR
FROM THAT. AND I THINK IF WE
CAN HAVE MORE AND MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT SEX- WE CAN
ERASE THE- STIGMAS THEN WE HAVE
PLACED ON IT. AND HOPEFULLY
ENTER INTO A DISCUSSION THAT IS
FAR MORE HONEST- THEN WHAT WE
TRY TO PORTRAY- I THINK AS A
RESULT OF THAT. SCHIZOPHRENIA
WE HAVE CREATED A VERY BROKEN
SYSTEM AS IT RELATES TO OUR SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRY AND HOW THAT
AND HOW SEX IS WEAPONIZED BY
OUR D. A.'S. TOM OFTENTIMES
AGAINST BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO IS SAY SEX IS TALK
ABOUT SEX AND PEOPLE GET
NERVOUS AND IT IS UNFAIR.
BECAUSE IT IS SOMETHING THAT S
REALLY REALLY HARD TO OVERCOME.
AND I SAY THAT ALSO AS A
SURVIVOR- I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. NUMBER ONE IS DOES
THIS BILL SPEAK TO- YOU KNOW
CONSENTING ACTS. OF ROLE PLAY
AND ROUGH PLAY THAT OFTEN TIMES
CAN HAPPEN- BETWEEN CONSULTING
CONSENTING- AND PROBABLY
CONSULTING ADULTS WHO ARE
MARRIED- BECAUSE I WOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT- EIGHT YOU KNOW
IF THIS IS SILENT ON THAT AND
THEN HOW THAT IS EITHER USED OR
MISCONSTRUED OR MISUSED OR-
BECAUSE I THINK CRIMINAL
CHARGES OF ANY NATURE REALLY
IMPORTANT AND SHOULD BE- YOU
KNOW THOUGHT ABOUT VERY
CAREFULLY. BEFORE LEVIED
AGAINST SO I JUST WANT TO KNOW
BECAUSE- TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION- THOSE COULD
COME INTO INTO PLAY- IF
ALLEGATIONS OF- OF SPOUSAL
RAPE- WERE LEVIED- PHIL LET ME
START OFF BY- IF THE SPELL THE
ROLE PLAY IS CONSENSUAL WHETHER
YOU'RE MARRIED OR NOT. I WOULD
SAY THAT. THAT'S NOT RAPE AND-
WE HAVE A VERY DETAILED IN THE
LAST QUESTION THAT I DON'T WANT
TO SAY YES FOR SURE THIS ISWHAT THE BILL SAYS OR THE LAW
THE PENAL CODE SECTION OF SPACE
SO I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK OUT OF
PLACE IT WOULD BE MY ASSUMPTION
BUT I'VE BEEN HERE LONG ENOUGH
THAT THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW OF ONE OF
THE WITNESSES THAT I HAD THE
DAC ABLE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION FOR YOU IN A BETTER
WAY AND IF THAT WOULD BE A
LITTLE BY THE CHAIR YOURSELF
FOR FINANCER. I DON'T SPEAK OUT
OF PLACE- ARM. AGAIN OPEN TO.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN
ASK MY SECOND QUESTION. OKAY
AND THEN MAYBE. THE WITNESSES
CAN- RESPOND TO BOTH OF THEM.
SO I. AM VERY INTERESTED IN WHY
DISABILITY RIGHTS HAS A NEUTRAL
POSITION ON THIS. I WILL ALSO
SHARE THAT- I AM THE- CO PARENT
OF A CHILD WITH DISABILITIES
AND I AM INTIMATELY INVOLVED
WITH THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY-
AND WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH A
COUPLE OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS
THAT ARE IN MY DISTRICT. AND I
TALK WITH THEM ABOUT THIS BILL.
AND- HAPPY TO REPORT THAT- OUR
DISABILITY COMMUNITY IS
SEXUALLY ACTIVE AND THRIVING-
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT OUR
DOMINANT CULTURE HAS A VERY
CONDESCENDING AND PATRONIZING-
ATTITUDE TOWARDS OUR DISABILITY
COMMUNITY- ONE THAT IS
INCREASINGLY FOCUSED ON.
PROGRAMS DESIGNED AROUND SELF
DETERMINATION SO THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO FULLY EXPRESS WHO THEY
ARE. AND I WANT TO KNOW IF THIS
BILL SPELLS OUT WHAT LEGAL
CONSENT LOOKS LIKE FOR THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY. AND THE
REASON WHY I ASK IS BECAUSE IN
MY INTERACTIONS WITH MY FAMILY
MEMBERS AND OTHER FOLKS- WHO
ARE DISABLED- YOU KNOW FOLKS
HAVE TICKS. FOLKS MAKE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF SOUNDS FOLKS
HAVE THE REGULATED AND
UNREGULATED BODIES. WINDOWS
DON'T ALWAYS ALIGN WITH WHAT
THE DOMINANT CULTURE CONSTRUES
AS BEING NORMAL. AND SO IN THE
HEIGHT OF A DISCUSSION AROUND
FREE BRITNEY AND
CONSERVATORSHIP AND SOMEONE
ELSE'S IDEA OF WHAT NORMAL IS
FOR A PARTICULAR PERSON. OR
WHAT SORT OF. MENTAL ACUITY
INSTABILITY LOOKS LIKE IT IS
VERY DIFFERENT FOR FOLKS YOU
KNOW IN THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY SPECIFICALLY FOLKS
WITH DOWN SYNDROME- AND SO I'M
VERY CURIOUS ABOUT DOES THIS
SPELL OUT WHAT LEGAL CONSENT
LOOKS LIKE FOR THEM BECAUSE
WHAT I SEE AND WHAT I HEAR.
RIGHT WITH TWO CONSENTING WHO
ARE ALSO WHO IN AND THE MANY
INSTANCES SOMEONE WHO HAS DOWN
SYNDROME IS MARRIED TO SOMEONE
WHO HAS DOWN SYNDROME NOT
ALWAYS THESE ARE SOME
GENERALIZATIONS BUT- I'M JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I
MAY SEE SOMETHING OR HEAR
SOMETHING AND SAY OH MY
GOODNESS. THIS PERSON IS BEING
RAPED. BUT THAT MAY NOT BE THE
CASE IT'S JUST A SOUND THAT
MAYBE I DON'T ASSOCIATE WITH
YOU KNOW WHAT I EXPERIENCE WHEN
I'M HAVING SEX. SO I'M CURIOUS
WHAT HOW THE WHAT THIS IS THE
SILENT ON THAT OR ARE THERE
SOME SPECIFICS ON THAT BECAUSE
I WOULD BE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
US CRIMINALISING SEXUAL
INTERCOURSE AND BEHAVIOR-
BETWEEN FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION I THINK. WE I
PERSONALLY FEEL LIKE WE NEED TO
CREATE THE SPACE AND BE BETTER
TOWARD DISABLED COMMUNITY X. X.
I THINK WE IMPOSE NORMS ON FAIR
THERE. AND THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE WILL AND ABILITY
THE FREE WILL TO SAY YES AND
ALSO TO STAY NOW- AND I AGREE
WITH YOU THAT OFTEN TEND TO
MISCONSTRUE THAT AND WE- WE ARE
NOT ALWAYS FOR IN THAT SPACE.
IN MY DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS COALITION- WE
STARTED TO ENGAGE IN DISCUSSION
OF A HIGHLY MAKE SURE THEY'RE
ABLE TO SAY YES AND ABLE TO SAY
NO. AND I WOULD SAY THAT AT
THIS POINT THE BILL ISN'T CLEAR
ON THAT SPACE AND AMENDMENT
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED BY A
COMMITTEE. AND IT IT DOES IT IT
ALLOWS FOR YES BUT IT DOESN'T
ALLOW FOR NOW. OUT THERE I
WOULD SAY NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS WE NEED TO GET THIS
RIGHT WHETHER IT'S- BEFORE THIS
MOVES- TO OUT OF DISPENSED OR A
NEW BILL MAKE SURE THAT'S IN
THE COMMITMENT WITH THE
DISABILITIES RIGHTS GROUPS.
THAT WE NEED TO FIGURE THIS OUT
I. BECAUSE THE AMENDMENT
OFFERED ONLY ALLOWS FOR YES AN
OFFER NO IT MAKES ME
UNCOMFORTABLE BUT IT I'M
WILLING TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION AND THAT'S HOW I NEED
TO MOVE TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION. BUT EITHER WAY MY
COMMITMENT IS TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE ALLOW FLEXIBLE SAY YES AND
I'LL ND IN A WAY WHAT THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS GROUPS ARE
ABLE TO COME IN AND HELP DEFINE
WHAT THAT IS. AND THE ANSWER
HAS BEEN THAT AT THIS POINT
THEY HAVEN'T HAD ENOUGH TIME.
TO FIGURE THAT OUT AND THEY
HAVE ASKED FOR MORE. TIME UNTIL
I THINK THE INITIALS ASIAN FROM
MY AND THEIR- THIS. WHETHER
IT'S THE BILL OR THE BILL WITH
THE M. WAS HAVE THAT WORK TO DO
AND I'M COMMITTED TO DOING THAT
WORK. WITH THEM- BECAUSE YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
ABILITY BOTH YES AND I'LL- SO I
THINK YOU FOR THAT- I DON'T
WANT TO GET EMOTIONAL BUT I
HAVE BEEN TO SO MANY. MEETINGS
AT MY REGIONAL CENTER WHERE-
FOLKS TO LABEL WHO ARE
IDENTIFIED AS BEING PART OF THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY ARE
FIGHTING THEY ARE FIGHTING FOR
SELF DETERMINATION. AND SO MANY
TIMES IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS THEY
ARE MET WITH RESISTANCE FROM A
DOMINANT SOCIETY THAT IS
PROJECTING NORMS ONTO THEM WITH
OUT THEIR INPUT AND WITHOUT.
FULLY UNDERSTANDING THE SCOPE
AND THE VIBRANCY AND THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS COMMUNITY
AND WE SHUT THEM DOWN WE SHUT
THEM DOWN WHEN THEY'RE SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT WE SHUT THEM DOWN
WHEN THEY ARE ASKING TO LIVE ON
THEIR OWN WE SHUT THEM DOWN
WHEN THEY'RE ASKING OR LOOKING
TO BE INVOLVED IN. ADULT
RELATIONSHIPS BECAUSE THERE'S
THIS PAROCHIAL. PATRONIZING
ASSUMPTION. THAT THEY CAN'T
MAKE IT WITHOUT US. OVERSEEING
HOW THEY LIVE AND THEY DON'T
WANT THAT- AND I EXPERIENCE OUT
EVERY DAY IN MY OWN HOUSEHOLD
HAVING TO. RE LEARN AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT TICKS AND
TRAITS AND BEHAVIORS MEAN TO
SOMEONE WHO IS ON THE SPECTRUM
AND NOT IN WORKING TO NOT
IMPOSE MY RATIONALE OF WHAT IS
NORMAL AND WHAT IS OKAY AND SO.
VERY RARELY DO WE HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY IN ANY OF
THESE CHAMBERS- AND SO I'M I'M-
REALLY ASKING THAT YOU CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE WITH THIS COMMUNITY
BECAUSE- AND IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
RATE BUT IT IS ABOUT SEX. AND
THEY DESERVE TO BE ABLE TO
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE IN A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT SEX IS
FOR THEM. I TOTALLY GET WHEN
THERE'S SOMEONE WHO IS NOT
DISABLED IMPOSING I MEAN I AM I
MEAN I KNOW WHAT RAPE IS. AND
THAT'S NOT A THAT'S NOT WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT BUT I AM
TALKING ABOUT THESE NEW ONES
SEASON NUANCES AND CREVICES
THAT GENERALLY DON'T GET THE
LIGHT WHICH IS WHY I DO
APPRECIATE THIS BILL. COMING
FORWARD BECAUSE IT ALLOWS US TO
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING THAT WE
DON'T REALLY TALK ABOUT VERY
OFTEN SO I AM ASKING THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO. WE ENGAGE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH ARM. THE
STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY. IF FOR NO
OTHER REASON. THAN BECAUSE THIS
SENATOR HAS A CHILD. WHO
DESERVES TO HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE WHEN DISCUSSING HOW HE-
IS ABLE TO LIVE AND I WOULD
SAY- I THINK WE ALL MAYBE NEED
TO GET A LITTLE MORE EMOTIONAL
ABOUT THIS THAT TO HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND WE DO NEED TO
HAVE THIS IS THAT DOESN'T HAVE
THE DISCUSSION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT THIS AFFECTS
OUT THERE- I AGREE THAT WE MUST
UNDERSTAND AND THIS IS TRUE
AND- I SURE WOULD DO THE
FRUSTRATIONS OF HOW WE DEAL
WITH THIS WITH OUR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY AND-
THERE HAS TO BE A SPACE FOR
MYSELF DETERMINATION AND THAT
SPACE I FULLY BELIEVE IN THAT.
I THINK IN GENERAL- TAKING THIS
ATTITUDE OF PUTTING PEOPLE AWAY
AND HIDING THEM IN AND NOT
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE BUT WE
NEED TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
OVER TO BE FAIR- TO ALL
INDIVIDUALS TO BE INCLUSIVE
TELEVISION COMPLETED ADDING
CIRCLE HERE I AM VERY COMMITTED
TO THAT DISCUSSION WHETHER IT'S
A DISCUSSION BEFORE THIS BILL
IF I EVER GET TO THE GOVERNOR
THIS YEAR OR A NEW BILL NEXT
CHECK ME THAT COME IN THAT
COMMITMENT TO- THE DISABILITY
GROUPS US THAT WHATEVER WE COME
UP WITH SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE LESSONS
THEY BOTH YES. AND NO- AND IT'S
FAIR THAT WE HAVE IN FIGURE
THAT OUT AT THIS POINT AND THE
LAST THE IN MY DISCUSSION THE
SAID WE'RE OKAY WITH THIS BILL
MOVING WITH THAT WHAT THE
COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FIGURE SOMETHING OUT FOR THIS
TO BUY THEIR TEN AMENDMENT DOWN
THE ROAD ARE YOU BILL MAKE SURE
SPECIFIC TO THE SPACE I AM VERY
MUCH COMMITTED TO THAT- AND
THEY'VE BEEN HERE FOR NINE
YEARS AND I THINK WHEN I SOME
COMMITTED SOMETHING I WORK ON
IT FOR YEARS ON END UNTIL IT
GETS DONE RIGHT I'M NOT GOING
TO WALK AWAY FROM THAT
COMMITMENT. BUT I ALSO FEEL
IT'S A HAVE TO DO IT ON HUNDRED
TERMS AND NOT MY TERMS AND SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE
NEUTRAL POSITIONS COMING FROM
FROM MY CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM
UP UNTIL THIS MORNING OUT THERE
INTO MY COMMITMENT IS GENUINE I
DON'T PRETEND TO HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS AND ALL THE ANSWERS
OTHER THAN THAT I DO KNOW THAT
WE NEED TO DO BETTER AND
ALLOWING SELF DETERMINATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE AND SO-
WHATEVER THE DISABILITY IS THIS
I MEAN THAT WE SHOULD NOT HAVE
HIMSELF WITH TERMINATION OFTEN.
SO I DO APPRECIATE YOU SHOW
YOUR PERSONAL STORY WE US- AND-
I HOPE. IN MY LIFETIME MY TEN
YEAR NOT MY- BECAUSE FIGURE OUT
A BETTER SPACE AND IS NOT JUST.
ON ISSUES OF SEX BUT JUST IN
GENERAL- HOW WE TREAT THIS AND THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK TO BE DONE IN THAT SPACE.
THIS IS DIFFICULT VERY CAPABLE
GAIN IF I COULD BRIEFLY RESPOND
TO THE VERY IMPORTANT AND
PERSONAL- QUESTIONS AND STORIES
THAT THAT CENTER CAMARGO
SHARED- BECAUSE I THINK SHE
REYES REALLY CRITICAL ISSUES I
WANT TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THEM
THANK HER. AS WELL FOR SHARING
AND HER CONTRIBUTION ON THESE
ISSUES- AND ALSO EXPRESSED BY
COMMITMENT TO SELF
DETERMINATION I HAVE MANY
FAMILY MEMBERS AND STAFF
MEMBERS IN MY OFFICE AS WELL
WHO ARE DISABLED- AND I THINK
IT'S A CRITICAL ISSUE THAT IS.
AS YOU SAY OFTEN OVERLOOKED
GETTING EXCLUDED FROM THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT SEXUAL
IDENTITY AND SEXUAL CONSENT AND
BEYOND- I ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR
AND TRY TO FOCUS ON WHY HE IS
THE REAL QUESTION WHEN IT COMES
TO- THIS ASSMBLY BILL. THIS IS
NOT AN ASSEMBLY BILL THAT OULD
IN ANY WAY CHANGE THE LEGAL
STANDARD FOR WHAT PROSECUTORS
IN A COURT OF LAW HAVE TO
PROVE. TO SECURE A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION FOR RAPE IT DOESN'T
CHANGE THAT. AND IT WOULD NOT
IN ANY WAY ALTER. OR ELIMINATE.
A VERY LONGSTANDING WELL
ESTABLISHED LEGAL DEFENSE TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT WHICH IS KNOWN
AS THE MAYBERRY THANKS TO THE
FENCE WHICH- ESSENTIALLY-
REQUIRES PROSECUTORS. TO
ELIMINATE THE REASONABLE
POSSIBILITY. THAT THE PERSON
ACCUSED THOUGHT. THE VICTIM
CONSENTED. IT IS OUR BURDEN AS
PROSECUTORS IN EVERY SINGLE
CASE WITH OR WITHOUT THIS
CHANGE IN A LONG. TO ESTABLISH
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT THAT
THERE WAS NO CONSENT AND THAT
THE PERSON ACCUSED COULD NOT
HAVE REASONABLY BELIEVED THERE
WAS CONSENT. MEETING THAT
BURDEN IS A VERY VERY DIFFICULT
THANKS MANY ARGUE MANY BELIEVE
IT'S TOO DIFFICULT AND THAT'S
WHY SO MUCH SEXUAL ASSAULT GOES
ON PUNISHED BUT WHAT IS
CERTAINLY TRUE IS IT IS
UNIQUELY DIFFICULT IN CASES.
WHERE BOTH PEOPLE ENGAGING IN
SEX ACTS ARE DISABLED
ESTABLISHING. A JURY THAT.
BACKS UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES
WAS NON CONSENSUAL AND
ELIMINATING THE POSSIBILITY
THAT IT WAS CONSENSUAL IS OFTEN
AN INSURMOUNTABLE BURDEN THIS
LAW WOULD NOT THIS PROPOSAL
THIS ASSEMBLY BILL WOULD NOT IN
ANY WAY CHANGE THAT LOFTY
BURDEN SO I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT IT DOES AND
DOES NOT DO I ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS MY COMMITMENT TO
WORKING WITH SENATOR TOM LONGER
AND THE SENATE IN GENERAL ON.
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION BRING
IT OUT OF THE SHADOWS AND
INCLUDING- DISABLED MEMBERS OUR
FAMILIES OUR COMMUNITIES. WITH
YOU TO THE TABLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS FOR THIS
CORRECT. WELL I I'D- M. THE
THANKFUL AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND FULL DISCLOSURE
THAT I ACTUALLY HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE DA OVER
THE WEEKEND ABOUT THIS BILL BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT
RENEGADES THE ABILITY FOR CALM.
FOLKS WITH DIFF DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES FROM CONSENTING
AND SO MY CONCERN IS IT TOO
LATE WHERE ESPOUSES INCAPABLE
OF GIVING LEGAL CONSENT DUE TO
A DISABILITY DO YOU KNOW LIKE
WHAT THE STANDARD IS SO
BECAUSE- ONCE AGAIN IN MANY
INSTANCES. THE COUPLE BOTH OF
THEM. CAN HAVE IF THEY BOTH
HAVE A DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
HOW DOES THAT PLAY OUT. SENATOR
THE SHORT ANSWER IS THAT IN ANY
CRIMINAL CASE CERTAINLY
INCLUDING THESE KINDS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. IT IS THE BURDEN
OF THE PROSECUTOR THE BURDEN OF
FOR EXAMPLE THE LAWYERS MY
OFFICE OR ANY OTHER DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OFFICES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHEN
FILING A CRIMINAL CASE IT IS
OUR BURDEN TO ESTABLISH EACH
AND EVERY ELEMENT OF. THE
PARTICULAR CRIME CHARGED BUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RAPE FOR
EXAMPLE IT WOULD BE OUR BURDEN
TO PROVE THE TEXAS COURT IT
WILL BE OUR BURDEN OF PROOF TO
PROVE THAT THE SEX WAS NON
CONSENSUAL IT WILL BE OUR
BURDEN TO PROVE. THAT NOT ONLY
WAS NON CONSENSUAL SEX BUT THAT
THE PERSON ACCUSED COULD NOT
HAVE REASONABLY BELIEVES. THAT
IT WAS CONSENSUAL SEX. IN MANY
INSTANCES EVEN IF THERE'S A
CONSERVATORSHIP IN PLACE FOR
ONE OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ALONE IS NOT ENOUGH THAT'S NOT
SUFFICIENT. IN OTHER WORDS WE
HAVE THE VERY DIFFICULT OFTEN
IMPOSSIBLE BURDEN AS
PROSECUTORS IF WE CHOOSE TO
FILE RAPE CHARGES. OTHER
SALVAGING THAT A PERSON EVEN A
PERSON WAS SEVERE DISABILITIES
COULD NOT HAVE REASONABLY
UNDERSTOOD. THAT THE PERSON
THEY HAD SEX WITH- WHO WAS
CONTENT. IN OTHER WORDS WE HAVE
TO ELIMINATE THE POSSIBILITY
THE REASONABLE POSSIBILITY THAT
THE ALLEGED VICTIM COULD HAVE
BEEN. IN CENTER. A DIFFICULT
BURDEN IT'S ACTUALLY MORE
DIFFICULT IN CASES WHERE
DISABILITIES ARE INVOLVED NOT
BECAUSE WE UNDERMINE THE SEXUAL
IDENTITY OR SEXUAL AUTONOMY OF
DISABLED PEOPLE I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT THAT WE DO AS A SOCIETY
BUT THAT'S A SEPARATE ISSUE
FROM THIS LEGAL REFORM LEGAL
REFORM IS REALLY JUST LOOKING
AT. WHETHER RAPE IS RAPE IT
DOESN'T. THE LEGAL STANDARD FOR
PROVING IT IF IT'S IF IT'S A
LEAD. IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE TO
ALLEGED CORRECTLY OR
INCORRECTLY WHAT IT DOES IS
CREATE A UNIFORM SYSTEM OF
RESPONSE THAT ACCOUNTABILITY
WHEN RATE. CAN BE PROVED IT.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT IT HAPPENS
FAR FAR FAR MORE OFTEN. THAT IT
CAN BE PROVEN BY PROSECUTORS.
WELL NO I THINK YOU FOR THAT
BUT I WE WERE TALKING I WAS
THINKING BACK TO A CASE THAT
WAS- TRIED IN MY COUNTY- FROM-
A FORMER DA- AND- THE PERSON
THE YOUNG MAN DID HAVE A DEBOUT
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY AND
WAS CHARGED WITH RAPE AND HE
THEN THAT WAS NOT WHAT
HAPPENED- AND IN FACT THE- THE
PROSECUTION SAID. WE KNOW HE
DOESN'T NEED JAIL- BECAUSE WE
KNOW HE HAS A MENTAL-
DISABILITY- BUT WE'RE GOING TO
CHARGE HIM ANYWAY BECAUSE THIS
IS AN EASY WIN. ARM AND SO I E.
II DO WHAT AID YOU KNOW I DID
IT SO I MEAN THAT'S JUST THAT'S
THE REAL STORY SO I'M AS AND I
WOULD HATE FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS TO BE PREDICATED ON WHO
THE D. EIGHT IS- BECAUSE AND
WE'RE PUTTING OUR EGGS YOU KNOW
QUITE FRANKLY IN YOUR BASKET IN
IN A COUPLE OF OTHER PEOPLE'S
BASKETS THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
FAITH IN. THERE ARE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT BATES SENATOR
AND- I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
DON'T THINK THIS LAW WOULD
CHANGE THE STORY THAT YOU
DESCRIBE. I MEAN IF THEY WERE
LEGALLY MARRIED. OUR GALLAGHER
WE'RE GOOD AT MAYBE IT WOULD
BE. WELL I THINK HI G. OF
COURSE ON THE CENTER. TROUBLE
CONDUCTOR CENTER SKINNER. OKAY
RIGHT WILL LOOK LET ME LET ME
GO ON RECORD I WAS REALLY
HOPING THAT THEY ARE AMENDMENTS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS PUT
FORTH AND I WILL CLEARLY STATE
ON BECAUSE THE AMENDMENT
DEFINITELY SPEAK TO THE BILITY
OF DISABLED PEOPLE TO SAY YES
AND TO SIGNAL AND CONSENTING TO
EIGHTY SIX AND AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THAT THE
BILL WOULD CRIMINALIZE WILL
FULL SEXUAL INTERCOURSE BETWEEN
MARRIED COUPLES OR ONE OR BOTH.
ARE DISABLED. THE BILL WHICH
DEAL TOTALLY DELETE AND LET ME
STATE AGAIN TOTALLY THE LEAKED
AND PARTY. OF SECTION CODE I
MEAN SECTION- WHAT I TO SAY
SECTION. STE. TWO SIX TWO.
WHICH WOULD REMOVE SPOUSAL RAPE
AND THAT'S THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL TO REMOVE THAT COLD AND
EVERYONE HERE SUPPORTS THE OVER
ARCHING GOALS OF THIS. BILL AND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
HERE- THE MEMBERS SHOULD NOT
ADDRESS ALL THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION WE'RE NOT HERE TO
SAY THAT IT DOES BUT THIS BILL
REMOVES DISCRETION OF JUDGES TO
GRANT PROBATION OR TO NOT
REQUIRE MANDATORY LIFETIME SEX
REGISTRATION AND AGAIN IT'S NOT
A SINGLE PERSON HERE WHO
CONDONES RAPE- I HOPE IT'S NO
ONE IN THIS BUILDING AND I'LL
NO ONE ANYWHERE AROUND HERE
WOULD DO THAT BUT I THINK THE-
BILL ALSO A SILENT ON THE FACT
THAT. MEN ARE REAP TO. AND ALL
THE TESTIMONY ONLY SPEAKS TO
WOMEN BEING RAPED AND MEN ARE
BEING RAPED EVERY DAY. IN THIS
COUNTRY AND IT SPEAKS NOTHING
THIS AWARD IS A STAND AS IT
RELATES TO MEN BEING HURT. A
CASE LET MYSELF WITH. MEN ARE
DEFINITELY RATES AS WELL IT'S
THIS IS AN THE GENDER DOESN'T
MATTER AND IT'S ABOUT POWER OUR
NEXT. AND SO IT'S NOT MY INTENT
TO THAT ONLY A IT'S ONLY IF YOU
KNOW FOR WOMEN I THINK IT
SPEAKS BILL OR THE GENDER
ROLLED IN THE PAR THEN I MIX
THAT WE'RE WORKING TO BRING
PARITY. TO AND THE WORDS THAT
WE USE THAT TIME SO I WOULD
START WITH THAT PIECE THE
SECOND PIECE I WOULD SAY WITH
THE AMENDMENT. THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED I THINK IT DEFINITELY
ALLOWS FOR YES- AND A SEARCH TO
ADDRESS HALF OF THE ISSUE AND
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
BUT IT DOESN'T ALLOW FOR NOW
YES HE DOES. WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO DISAGREE ON THAT IT
DEFINITELY LAWS FOR NOW. IT'S A-
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING AND
TALKING TO FOLKS AND IN TALKING
TO THE DISABILITIES GROUPS THAT
IT DOESN'T ALLOW FOR NOEL. LET
THE COUNCIL TWENTY. IT WOULD
STILL ALLOW FOR SOMEONE TO BE
RAPED SO JUST SO IF THE MAN IT
MAKES IT SO THAT A PERSON WITH
DISABILITIES IS NOT PRESUME TO
NOT BE ABLE TO CONSENT WITHIN A
MARRIAGE WHICH IS WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IT MAKES IT
STATUTORILY JUST AS WE SAY
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD CAN'T CAN'T
CAN'T CONSENT. UNLESS THEY'RE
MARRIED. IF THEY'RE MARRIED
THEY CAN. BUT IT DOES IT DOES
NOT CHANGE RATE A PERSON CAN
STILL BE CHARGED WITH RAPE IF
THE IF THE IF THE PERSON WITH
THE DISABILITY SAYS. I DIDN'T
CONSENT I A T. ATTACKED ME THIS
OR ANY OF THE OTHER THINGS IF
THE PERSON IS DISABILITY SAYS I
DIDN'T CONSENT IT'S STILL GREAT
EVEN UNDER THE AMENDMENT WHAT
THE SOME BUT WHAT YOUR BILL
CURRENTLY SAYS THE PERSON WITH
DISABILITY IS NOT ALLOWED TO
CONSENT EVEN IN THE PICTURE OF
MARCH. AND SO THIS JUST REMAINS
REMOVES FAT JUST AS A FIFTEEN
OR SIXTEEN YEAR OLD CANNOT
CONSENT BUT IF THEY'RE MARRIED
LAW RECOGNIZES. THEM IN
MARRIAGE AND THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
CONSENT. BECAUSE OCCASIONALLY
THEY GET MARRIED SO THIS IS
THIS BILL ALL IT DOES IS REMOVE.
THE AMENDMENT THAT SAYS PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES EVEN WITHIN
MARRIAGE CANNOT CONSENT IF THE
PERSON SAYS MY HUSBAND RAPED ME.
THEY CAN STILL BE CHARGED WITH
RAPE JUST LIKE THEY CAN UNDER
EXISTING LAW. SO IT JUST SAYS
IT JUST TAKES AWAY THE
PRESUMPTION THAT THERE IS NOT
CONSENT. I WOULD SAY THAT IN MY
DISCUSSIONS UP UNTIL THIS
MORNING INCLUDING LIKE THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS ATTORNEYS
THAT. THEY FEEL THAT IT DOES
ADDRESS THE OF THE YES SIDE OF
THE EQUATION BUT NOT THE NORTH
SIDE OF THE EQUATION WHY
THEY'VE ASKED FOR MORE TIME
GIVE US FOR THERE TO BE A
DISCUSSION THAT'S- YOU KNOW
SPECIFIC HERE AND AN ADDITIONAL
BILL TO TRY TO ADDRESS. THOSE
ISSUES- I AM FULLY COMMITTED.
TO GETTING IT RIGHT WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND- AT ENSURING
THAT WE ARE CREATING A BETTER
SYSTEM THERE ARE AND I HAD IF
THE AMENDMENT TO SET THOSE WITH
US I AM WILLING TO TAKE THAT
AMENDMENTS- IN IF IT DOESN'T I
WANTED TO FIND A SOLUTION
WHETHER IT'S AT SOME POINT DOWN
THE ROAD- AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR DISABILITY RIGHTS
STAKEHOLDERS ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH BUT THAT THAT'S IT IT DOES
TAKE IT BECAUSE IT DOESN'T DEAL
WITH. GREAT IT JUST DEALS WITH
THE IT JUST TAKES OUT THE OF
THE STATEMENT IN YOUR BILL THAT
SAYS A PERSON WITH DISABILITY
IS NOT CAPABLE OF CONSENT. SO
THIS A PERSON CAN. THAT IT DOES
THAT HAVE TO BE CAPABLE TO. I'M
SORRY I JUST I AM NOT AWARE OF
ANY PRESUMPTION IN THE LAW THE
DISABLED PEOPLE CANNOT CONSENT
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IF I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT. THAT
THAT IS WHAT THAT ARE. KERN SO
I HAVE NOT MADE ANY HEADWAY
WITH IT IS IN THE LAW STATES
THAT YOU ARE MISTAKEN. IT
WOULDN'T BE THE FIRST TIME WE
ALL MAKE MISTAKES I'M NOT AWARE
OF ANY EXACTLY ALL RIGHT WELL
WE'RE NOT GOING TO WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE A BACK AND FORTH WITH
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO
UNDERSTANDING THAT. AGAIN MY
COMMITMENT IS THAT IF THAT IS.
THAT IT GIVE IF THE AMENDMENT.
ALLOWS FOR YES AND NO. IT DOES
AND- IT'S FAIR AT THIS POINT
THAT'S NOT MY YOU'RE TAKING THE
MOMENTUM. IF IT'S FROM MY
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE WITH THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS. RUPE IT'S
NOT CLEAR TO THEM THAT THIS
AMENDMENT ALLOWS FOR SNL WE'VE
TALKED TO WILL WE MUST B
TALKING TO DIFFERENT GROUPS
BECAUSE DISABILITY GROUPS SO
WE'VE TALKED TO ARM APPROVED
THIS LANGUAGE SO MAYBE IT'S
DIFFERENT FACTIONS WITHIN THE
DISABILITY RIGHT COMMUNITY BUT
I THINK WE'VE CRAFTED AN
AMENDMENT THAT ACHIEVE YOUR
GOAL IT'S- I THINK IT'S NOT NOT
A MORE VILE DISGUSTING ACT.
THAT YOU CAN COMMIT ON SOMEBODY
RATE ABSENT MURDER ANYWAYS RAPE
IS WORSE TO MURDER BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO LIVE WITH THAT TRAUMA
FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE. AND
I HAVE. GIRLFRIEND EX
GIRLFRIEND IN COLLEGE WHO WAS
RAPED BY KNOW THE TORMENT THAT
IT PUT ON HER AND SHE STILL
SUFFERS FROM THAT. TODAY BUT I
ALSO HAVE FRIENDS WHO ARE
DISABLED AND HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO ARE DISABLED COURT
IN LOVING CARING RELATIONSHIPS
AND I'VE EXPERIENCED OVER THE
LAST COUPLE MONTHS OF THEM
INTERACTING. AND LEGACY IT'S
NOT ARE TRADITIONALLY
INTERACTION BUT- THEY
COMMUNICATE. AND LOVE IN A WAY
THAT MIGHT BE DIFFERENT FROM
EACH AND WHAT EACH AND EVERYONE
OF US HERE AND I DON'T WANT TO
BE THE ONE TO DENY THEM. THAT
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN WE'RE HERE TO
ACHIEVE YOUR GOAL OF.
ELIMINATING SPOUSAL RAPE WHICH
YOU CAN'T RAPE IS RAPE. NO
MATTER HOW YOU LOOK AT IT BUT I
THINK WE ALSO SHOULD SHOW A
LITTLE BIT OF CONSIDERATION
AND- WHO. CONSIDER THAT WHICH
DISABLED COMMUNITY HAS TO DEAL
WITH AND I THINK THIS AMENDMENT
GIVES YOU TO. GIVE US JUST THAT
AND GIVE YOU THE BILL THAT YOU
NEED TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS.
SKINNER APOLOGIES THAT I WASN'T
HERE FOR THE WHOLE DISCUSSION
BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING A BUDET
BRIEFING AT TIMING IS TERRIBLE
THE WHAT. I OBVIOUSLY WAS HERE
FOR MOST THE COMMITTEE UP UNTIL
THAT POINT- I WONDER DID ANY OF
THE DISABILITY RIGHTS GROUPS
TESTIFY HAVE WE HEARD FROM THEM
DIRECTLY AND I DON'T MEAN YOU
OF COURSE HAVE TO COMMIT BUT
DID. WAS THERE ANY TESTIMONY
PRESENTED IN. I THINK ONE
STATED THEY WERE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL AS OF TODAY. YES THAT'S
THE ONLY THING THAT GIVES ME A
SLIGHT PAUSE. BY COMPLETELY
APPRECIATE. SHARE WHAT YOU AND
STAFFORD TRYING TO DO HERE I
1100% APPRECIATE THAT AND I
ALSO HEAR. THAT OUR PUBLIC
DEFENDERS THAT WHAT ONE MAN
PUBLIC DEFENDERS SAYING THAT-
DA SAYING THAT THAT- WHATEVER
THE BILL DOESN'T HOWEVER WE
HAVE ANOTHER THE CHECK SO I'M
GOING TO ASSUME THAT IN FACT.
THE WAY THAT IT'S CONSTRUCTED
NOW IS HAS A FLAW IN THAT WE
HAVE TO FIX THE FLAW SO AND
I'VE HEARD DOCTORS SAY SHE'S
ALSO WILLING TO FIX THE FLAW.
NO I ALSO KNOWN AS BEING THE
FORMER CHAIR FOLK SAFETY THAT
OUR STAFF ARE REALLY GOOD. BUT
OF COURSE WE ALSO BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO FIX A FLAW FOR A
SPECIFIC COMMUNITY WHICH IS THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY. IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO KNOW THAT THEY
ARE. ALSO COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
WHICH WAY WE WERE SORRY WITH
THE WAY IT'S CONSTRUCTED- I
KNOW THAT'S HARD THIS OUR LAST
DAY HAVE COMMITTEE AND SUCH-
BUT WE- COULD BE BE WILLING
MEAN SHE'S COMMITTED TO TAKING
THE AMENDMENT. BUT CAN WE GET A-
CAN WE GET SOME INFORMATION
FROM THE PRIMARY THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS COALITION THAT THEY ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF IT. YES MEANING
THAT IT FROM THEIR POINT OF
VIEW ACHIEVES THE SAME
OBJECTIVE THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
TRYING TO ACHIEVE. WHAT I'M
GOING TO SUGGEST THAT YOU TAKE
IT HERE TODAY AND- IF GOING
FORWARD THEY HAVE THE- PROBLEM
WITH THE MOMENT THAT WE PUT
FORTH THEN WE CAN ADDRESS A
GOING FORWARD BUT- TO TAKE IT
HERE TODAY TO. GET MY SUPPORT
AND AN ADDRESS IT IN AND LEAVE
THE- ROOM OPEN TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON IT IF. THEY COME
BACK WITH OPPOSITION WILL BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO ADDRESS AT
THE- AT THANK YOU CHAIR I THINK
YOU CAN ACTUALLY HAVE THE SAME
GOAL ONSELEN OF THE STATE THAT
FOR THE RECORD I THINK ON THE
SAME TEAM. HERE AND SO- WE HAVE
THE SAME GOAL AND I THINK.
ASKING ME TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
OF THIS THE COMMUNITY HAS AN
ISSUE WITH THAT TO COME BACK
AND ADDRESS IT LOOKS I THINK
THIS RIGHT YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
LEAVING OUT. THE DOOR OPEN FOR
US I WOULD DEFINITELY DO THAT
AND SO I I'M COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT TODAY- AND ADDRESSING IT
AT THE END THE DAY I WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE OR DISABILITY.
STAKEHOLDERS ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH WHEREVER WE LAND AND IS.
AN AND THEY SHOULD HAVE A
REALIZATION AND BEING ME OVER
HERE IS SAYING THAT THIS IS
RIGHT OR NOT RIGHT AND SO VERY
MUCH COMMITTED TO THE TO THAT
WORK AND I IS ON THE FOR ME
THAT- WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
WORKING. TOGETHER AND IF THEY
HAVE CONCERNS WE WILL ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS AND IF NOT WE
WILL WE WILL LET IT BE THE BUT
THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE. I DO APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE STAFF YOURSELF
IN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
PUTTING INTO THIS OTHER WAY
TRYING TO GET IT BUT I DO.
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT WE'RE ALL
ON THE SAME PAGE HERETHAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE DOING
THAT BETTER FOR DISABILITIES
COMMUNITY. YES THANK YOU WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND TO CONTINUE. WORKING
ON ON ON THIS IN I DO HAVE TO
FACE WE'RE GOING TO GO. THERE.
CAN CAN CAN CAN YOU STICK TO
MOTIONS COUNCIL. PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR CALM
WATER. COME TO WE HAVE TO DO
PASSED AS AMENDED INTO
APPROPRIATIONS- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BRADFORD PARK ROAD FOR
NITRO BURKE I- BUG EYED DURAZO
COMMAGER COMMAGER I SKINNER
SKINNER I. THANK YOU. THE MOVE
WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE. STONE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. YOU HAVE AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN. ONE THREE
FINISH FOR A HOUSEKEEPING YOU
MAY BEGIN YOUR PRESENTATION.
USING TERRIFYING. YEAH IT WAS A-
BKD AMENDMENTS TO CHANGE THE
BILL'S REPORTING DATE TO
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SO THAT WE CAN GET A
REPORT BACK. REALLY BEFORE THE
PILOT SUNSETS ALL THIS BILL
DOES IS IT LOOKS AT AN
EXISTING. PILOT PROGRAM THAT IS
AUTHORIZED LEGISLATURE
AUTHORIZED IN SIX COUNTIES
ALAMEDA BUTTE NAPA. NEVADA
SANTA CLARA AND VENTURA. AND IT
ALLOWS ADULTS EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE. TO VOLUNTARILY OPT
INTO PROGRAMS THAT ARE AGE
APPROPRIATE SO THAT THEY ARE
SERVED IN THE JUVENILE SYSTEM.
AS OPPOSED TO THE ADULT
FACILITY. INDICATIONS ARE THAT
THE PILOT IS WORKING HOWEVER.
BECAUSE OF COVERED IN SOME
OTHER RESTRICTIONS WE JUST NEED
TO EXTEND THE SUNSET A LITTLE
BIT LONGER I SUPPOSE SURE THAT
WE GET APPROPRIATE REPORTS
BACK. THAT IS WHAT AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN DOES IS EXTEND THE
SUNSET AND CLEAN UP THE
LANGUAGE OF THE TIMING OF
GETTING REPORT BACK. WITH ME I
HAVE DANIEL SANTOS OF THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT AND I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU. WE CAN
START WITH YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS- DANIEL CENTERS. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER IS
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
SPONSOR AB THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN-
THIS PROGRAM REFLECTS RESEARCH
ON YEAH- THE YOUNG ADULT AND
ADOLESCENT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
AND REALLY THE IMPORTANT ROLE
AT AGE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS AND
RESPONSES IN THE JUVENILE-SYSTEM AND HELPING YOU. I THINK
THAT'S FULLY ON THE PATHWAY
THEN IN TRANSITIONING OUT OF
THE SYSTEM I'M AS STATED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE THIS
WOULD EXTEND THE CURRENT SENSE
THAT FOR TWO YEARS WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS VERY IMPORTANT- IN
PROGRAM CONTINUITY I WOULD JUST
BRIEFLY HIGHLIGHT A FEW
IMPORTANT FACTORS OF THE
PROGRAM IT BRIDGES THE NEEDS
AND PROGRAMMING SPECIFIC TO
YOUNG ADULTS THAT THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM PROVIDES WITH THE- GOAL
OF HELPING TRANSITION THESE
YOUNG ADULTS PERMANENTLY OUT OF
THE SYSTEM. IT REQUIRES THE
INDIVIDUALS AND VOLUNTARY
CONSENT TO PARTICIPATE IT'S
BASED ON A LOCAL MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM APPROACH TO
ESTABLISH THE PROGRAM AND
DISCUSS OPERATIONS OF THE
PROGRAM UPON SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF THE PROGRAM THE
INDIVIDUAL HAD THEIR CHARGES
DISMISSED AND THE RECORD
CLEARED AND IT REQUIRES RE
ENTRY PLANNING AND THE
IDENTIFICATION OF EDUCATION
HOUSING AND RELATED SUPPORT. SO
WE SEE THIS AS AN IMPORTANT-
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET ON- TO
CONTINUE CONTINUITY IN
PROGRAMMING FOR THESE YOUNG
ADULTS AND WE RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BEING
THAT THE CHARLIE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT WILL NOT
COME TO THE HEARING ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE IS OR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN
HERE IN THE ROOM SEEN ONE COME
FORWARD WILL GO CHORE OVERFLOW
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS-
EITHER. MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES INTO IF THERE
RE WITNESSES DESIRING TO SEE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN. IT AYE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIVE THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BE SURE
FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. CURRENTLY
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY
NOW WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY LEAD WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION SURE ANYONE HERE
AND FORTY TWO OH THREE DESIRING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF
THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN. SCENE NO ONE
AND THERE'S NO ONE IN TWENTY
FOUR THE FORTY EITHER.
MODERATOR WILL GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES AND LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF. THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN. LIKE TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AT THE TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. WE'LL
BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS
RELATES TO AB THIRTEEN INTEL-
OF THE BILL IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR SKINNER. WE HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROPRIATIONS- THURS NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
STONE WHICH ELECTED CLOSE
ASPIRO. J. COUNCIL WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN BRADFORD HI REDFORD
I'D CHOKE. I CHAU BUG EYED
TERRAZZO CAMARGO HANG FOR
MURDER AYE SKINNER BY
ENTERPRISE THE ITEM HAS FOR
VOTE SHE WILL LIBERAL OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CONGRADULATIONS AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST WE A MR SANTIAGO. THE
LOGAN A PROGRAM TOGETHER HE'S
HERE TO PRESENT. AB NINE NINETY
WHEN YOU'RE READY MR SANTIAGO
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GIVEN THE LATE
EVENING I'LL GIVE YOU THE
SHORTER VERSION AFFECT OKAY
BETTER. I CAN TELL BY THE
NUMBER YOU TO EIGHTY NINE
NINETY WOULD STRENGTHEN
VISITATION RIGHTS FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS OR INCARCERATED- BY
PEOPLE BY STORY VISITING HAS A
RIGHT VISITATION RIGHTS AND
I'VE BEEN TAKEN AWAY AS A FORM
OF PUNISHMENT THIS WOULD ONLY
END UP HARMING FOLKS WERE
INCARCERATED. PEOPLE FEDERAL
PEOPLE FAMILY IN PARTICULAR
THEIR CHILDREN- MISTER CHAIR-
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES WILL ALSO
BE BRIEF- MISTER J. VASQUEZ
FROM COMMUNITY UNITED FOR
STORED OF YOUTH JUSTICE AND THE
COALITION FOR FAMILY UNITY AND
THE- DRESS YOU'RE A FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT THE
COALITION FOR FAMILY UNITY.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AT THIS LATE HOUR
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
VASQUEZ READY FIRST SOMEONE. I
AM THANK YOU YOU MAY BEGIN YOU
KNOW A MINUTE HOW. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY. J.
VASQUEZ ON THE POLICY MANAGER
COMMUNITY NINE. THIS PROBABLY
OUT THE GLOBAL INSTANCE TWO
THIRTY ONE TOMORROW. YOUR CALL
THAT I WILL NEVER GET OUT. I
ALL WITH A DEPRESSED. ONLY THAT
LONG OF THE MARKET- HAVING MY
LOVED ONES PAID ALL THE BILLS
MOTIVATE. WORK ON MYSELF. FOR
THE- HELLO LICENSE WAS TOLD IN.
NINETEEN SIX. WELCOME OF THOSE
WHO WORK THE WEEKENDS NO LONGER
ABLE TO WITHOUT TAKING IT OFF
OF. IT'S CLEAR MANY HARDSHIPS
ONLY THEM ON THE ONES. YOU
WEREN'T ABLE TO BAKER. AND A
WAY. WE CAN ALSO LEAD TO MANY
ON THE BARRIERS. YEAH COOL MY
MOTHER WAS REQUIRED TO
UNIFICATION POLICY. APPLICATION
OUTSIDE BECAUSE GOD ME AND ON
THE WEST TWO DECADES PRIOR. IT
TOOK A WHOLE HERE MY MOTHER
CONDITION. EIGHTY NINE NINETY
FOUR AND THE BARRIERS TO
VISITING KEY BALANCE OTHER
PLEASE LEAVE THEM I WAS.
QUESTION I HOPE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WILL TO ENSURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JOANNE CHEER AND I'M
THE FOUNDER OF MEL FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT AND
APPROACH BECAUSE SPONSORED
EIGHTY NINE NINETY FOURTEEN
YEARS AGO MY ONLY CHILD ANTHONY
WAS SENTENCED TO LIFE IN PRISON
WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE HE WAS TWENTY YEARS OLD
I'D SPENT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN TRAVELING PHONE
CALLS MOTELS AND FOOD IN ORDER
TO SEE MY SON. IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN TWENTY RECEIVED A
TRANSFER TO THE HONOR YARD
LANCASTER WHICH WAS TO OCCUR
WITHIN THE WEEK WHILE VISITING
WITH ME HIS CELL MATE RECEIVED
DRUGS INTO THE CELL FOR
PERSONAL USE EVEN THOUGH TONY
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH IT HE
WAS GIVEN A ONE FIFTEEN
DISCIPLINARY RIGHT UP THE
RESULT OF THAT RIGHT UP WITH
ONE YEAR OF NO VISIT FOLLOWED
BY TWO YEARS OF NON CONTACT
VISITS WE WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
BE IN THE SAME ROOM OR TOUCH
EACH OTHER FOR THREE YEARS EVEN
THOUGH TONY DID NOTHING WRONG.
I'M BROKE NO VISITING RULES THE
TOLD THIS TOOK ON OUR FAMILY
WAS DEVASTATING FOR PROLONGED
SEPARATION PROVED TOO MUCH FOR
TONY TO BEAR AND HE STARTED
USING DRUGS TO DEAL WITH IT
SORROW FAMILY CONNECTION
MOTIVATE POSITIVE BEHAVIOR
WHICH BENEFITS NOT ONLY THE
INCARCERATED WITH CDCR STAFF AS
WELL THE GOLDEN SHOULD BE TO
SUPPORT FAMILY CONNECTIONS BY
MAXIMIZING VISITING EIGHTY NINE
NINETY WOULD PROHIBIT THE NILE
VISITS AS IT DID THE PRIMARY
MEASURE UNLESS RELATED TO A
VISITING INFRACTION. IT WOULD
ALSO PROHIBIT DENIAL OF VISITS
BASED ON HISTORY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXCEPT FOR SERIOUS
VIOLATION PREDICTING RULES THE
QUESTION HERE IS SIMPLE WOULD
YOU EVER ALLOW A GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCY TO REMOVE YOUR RIGHT TO
YOUR FAMILY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY
NINE NINETY TO RESTORE FAMILY
VISITING AT THE RIGHT THANK.
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU. NOW
WILL BRING ABOUT TO THE OR
FORTY TWO- THREE ARE THERE. AND
SO. OF AB NINE NINETY HERE THEY
COME. HELLO SHOULD KNOWN YOU
JUST RESERVE HERE FOR MAKING A.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN
CARE AND MEMBERS. I'M KEVIN
MCCARTY SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE NINETY ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR FAMILY UNITY AND
ITS MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS A NEW
WAY OF LIFE ALL OF US OR NONE.
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AGAINST
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES RISE CALIFORNIANS
IMPACTED FAMILIES PROJECT
COMMUNITY WORKS COMMUNITIES
UNITED FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
DROPPED L. UP EAST BAY FAMILY
DEFENDERS ESSIE JUSTICE GROUP.
FELONY MURDER ELIMINATION
PROJECT FAMILIES UNITED TO EN
EL UP HOMIES MEALS LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN MERRI MAC TRANSITIONAL
HOMES. THERE IS OF THE
COMMUNITY THE PLACE FOR GRACE
POLICY LINK. PRIDING TRUTH
PRISON FROM THE INSIDE OUT
INCORPORATED PROJECT AMIGA.
RESTORE JUSTICE RUTH REBOUND
SAMBAR DINO FREE THEM ALL
SILICON VALLEY DE BUG STARTING
OVER INCORPORATED. YOUNG
WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND US SINCE WE
ARE THE SEVEN O'CLOCK
NEUTRALIZE GROUP GO AHEAD
REDDIT. I AM JESSE KLEIBER
LISTEN I AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE NINETY ON BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
TEAM JUSTICE SAN DIEGO
COALITION WE THE PEOPLE SAN
DIEGO PILLARS OF THE COMMUNITY
ASIAN SOLIDARITY COLLECTIVE
THINK DIGNITY SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE SAN DIEGO
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO. THANK
YOU. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
SONNENSCHEIN I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINETY ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS. PRESS NOBODY
OWES YOU NEEDLES BRANDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA INITIATE JUSTICE
JESSE'S PLACE ADVOCATE GROUP
LEGAL AID AT WORK NATIONAL
LAWYERS GUILD. SIEGEL YEE
BRUNNER AND MET HER PRISONER
HUNGER STRIKE SOLIDARITY
COALITION RECORD CLEARANCE
PROJECT OF SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY RUBICON PROGRAMS
THANK YOU. YOU HELLO MY NAME IS
RUNNING ALONG A LOT HIM
REPRESENTING LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND-
ALSO SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE NINETY ON BEHALF OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION ALL OF US ARE NOT
BAKERSFIELD FOLLOW US OR NON
SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR YOUTH THE COMMUNITY JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
PRISON FOCUS CAGE UNIVERSAL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET.
THE CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES COMMUNITY LEGAL
SERVICES OF EASTERN AUTO CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE INLAND EMPIRE
CALIFORNIA JURORS ALONG
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA THE DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE ALLAH BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
SOLITARY SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
THANK YOU. DO. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS KELLY WALTERS I'M A
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AS A CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY AND A CHILD OF A
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PERSON I
STRONGLY SUPPORT NINE NINETY.
JOIN A BILL AND YOU POLICY
MANAGER FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND ALL
OF US OR NONE. IN SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVES STRONGLY IN LOVE AND
ABOUT REHABILITATION IN THAT
YOU CAN'T HAVE REHABILITATION
WITHOUT LOVE AND YOU CAN HAVE
REHABILITATION WITHOUT
RELATIONSHIPS. I REALLY WANT TO
URGE US TO VOTE YESTERDAY AND
REALLY BE ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
FAMILY UNITY. THANK YOU. THE
CAMERA. THEN I DO HAVE BROWN
WITH UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
INITIATIVE AT UC BERKELEY- I
BEFORE YOU GUYS HAVE- I- AND
ALSO AS A CHILD OF AN
INCARCERATED PARENT. WOULD MEAN
THE WORLD TO ME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. JOHN CANNON AGAIN
POLICY FELLOW AT LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PERSON
THAT BELIEVES IN FAMILY
REUNIFICATION AND A STRONG
SUPPORT OF HIS BILL. THANK YOU.
FOR WILLIAMS COMMUNICATIONS
MANAGER FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR
THOSE WITH CHILDREN MEMBER OF
ALL OF US NOT AND FORMALIZED
THROUGH ONLY STANDS BEFORE YOU
RIGHT NOW ADVOCATING ON BEHALF
OF MEN AND WOMEN INCARCERATED
ALL OVER THE STATE. THE ONLY
HERE BECAUSE OF THE LOVE OF MY
FAMILY IN CONNECTION WITH MY
FAMILY I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
VOTE FOR THIS- YES FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
THE WAY FROM IN WHAT. RIGHT NOW.
LET'SGO TO OUR PHONE LINES AND
TWO THIRDS INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. NINE
NINETY. YES SIR AND IF THERE
ARE ANY IN THE ANY VOICES IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINETY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME WE
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE FIVE
TWENTY. BY A PLACE. I KNOW THE
RODRIGUEZ WITH A MEMBER OF
FAMILY NINETY AND L. Y. I AM A
WHITE AN INCARCERATED PERSON
WHO HAS BEEN TRAVELING FOR
TWENTY FOUR YEARS IF YOU MY
HUSBAND AB NINETY I'M TOTALLY
IN SUPPORT OF IT. I GAVE FROM
BOTH THE FROM THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU TO
THIS POINT. ONE NINE THREE ONE
TWO. MISTER MEMBERS STAND ON ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BY IN FIVE
TWENTY THREE. THE PREVIOUS
SYSTEM IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBER
I'VE BEEN TRAVELING TO VISIT MY
HUSBAND FOR THE LAST SIX YEARS-
PLEASE PLEASE SUPPORT AB NINE
NINETY THE FAMILY'S DATA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BYE IN. FIVE
THREE SEVEN. THIRTY ONE MAN
NAMED MIKE I AM FROM MEDICAID
AT THIS AND I AM SYSTEM
IMPACTED AND CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB. NINE NINETY. NINE FIVE
TWENTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS ALAN
FROM JESSE PLACE ADVOCATE GROUP
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
NINE NINETY THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE FORTY THREE- HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER HOW PROJECT IS FIVE
ADVOCACY GROUP AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE. EIGHTY NINE
NINETY. NINE FIVE THIRTY. HI MY
NAME STELLAR ARMS BUT I'M
CALLING IN FROM FLORIDA IN
SUPPORT OF- EIGHTY NINE NINETY
I WOULD HEAL AND I'M READING
THE BILL ONLINE THE PRISONERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. NINE FIVE
TWENTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS
SUNSHINE DAVIS I'M CALLING FROM
PATTERSON CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOTHER COMING IN SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY NINE NINETY. PINE FOR
FORTY SIX. PINE FOR FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME
MODELER LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- I APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T
KNOW I HAD A MEMBER IN THE
QUEUE- JUST TALKING- THIS IS
APRIL GRAYSON FROM THE ELEMENTS
SENATE POLICY ASSOCIATE MEMBER
OF THE IF YOU AND CONCORD AND
HOW CO SPONSOR IN. STRONG
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY NINE NINETY.
PINE FIVE THIRTY TWO. HEY THIS
IS TERRY OUR TOPIC WHY. AND
FAMILY MEMBER OF INCARCERATED
LOVED ONE SERVING LIFE AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
NINETY THANK YOU SO MUCH. NINE
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT. MY NAME IS
SANDRA FLOODED FOUNDER OF CHEN
HIS PLEASE ADVOCATE GROUP AND
ALSO A MEMBER OF INITIATE
TESTED MY HUSBAND SERVING
THIRTY THREE YEARS NOT INVITING
CRYING BECAUSE OF ENHANCEMENTS
WE HAVE A TWO YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
I NEED TO SEE HER FATHER MORE
OFTEN AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORTER AB NINE NINE ZERO I
URGE YOUR ARGUABLE. THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE ZERO FOUR. HI MY NAME
IS GINA HERNANDEZ I'M WITH
FAMILY UNITED AND I'LL LOCK AND
THEN ISSUE A JUSTICE SYSTEM
IMPACTED I HAVE A HAS BEEN
SERVING A NOW WHAT SENTENCE AND
WE HAVE A CHILD AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE NINETY
TO KEEP OUR FAMILY UNITY. FONG
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE FOUR SIX.
HI MY NAME IS JOANNA VAN I'M-
I'M SILICON VALLEY DE BUG. AND
I'M YEAH OF. NINE NINE. BY IN.
FIVE THIRTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA DELGADO- I AM CALLING
FROM TURKEY SPACE ADVOCATE
GROUP AND SUPPORTED AB NINE
NINETY- MY HUSBAND HAS A ONE
YEAR OLD AND THAT HE HAD NOT
SEEN YET- SO I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE FAMILY UNITY THANK
YOU. NINE FIVE TWENTY FIVE.
PINE FIVE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GO TO LINE. ONE SIXTY.
BY ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE SIXTY
IF YOU COULD PLEASE PICK UP
YOUR HANDSET OR CHECKING ME
FEATURE WE CAN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN RIGHT NOW. HELLO. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU ARE RIGHT
THANK YOU JENNIFER BOB AT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKER CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE THREE
FORTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS PETER
AND I'M CALLING FROM SANTA
CLARITA AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE NINETEEN
MY DAUGHTER THERE TO HUG HER
FATHER THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
FIFTY. HI MY NAME IS ERICA HERE
REMAIN CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF CHEN
PLEASE ADVOCATE GROUP AS WELL
AS- MY- NINE FIVE FIFTY WE SEEM
TO HAVE LOST YOUR LINE IF YOU
HIT ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN WE CAN
BRING YOUR LINE OPEN AGAIN.
ONLINE FIVE SIXTEEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. NINE FIVE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE ON
TO LINE FOR TWENTY ONE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THE RIVER BREWING. WELL
IT DOES NEED TO TALK. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI
THIS IS OUT OF THE THIRTY I
GOVERNMENT I AM CO FOUNDER AND
TREASURER OF PRIDE IN TRUTH
BASED HERE IN EAST LA- I AM
CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF MY
INCARCERATED LOVED ONE MARK WHO
HAS BEEN INCARCERATED FOR OVER
SEVEN YEARS FOR STEALING A PAIR
OF BATTERY. FOR OVER SEVEN
YEARS HE HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
SEE ANY OF HIS LOVED ONES
INCLUDING HIS CHILDREN AND
MULTIPLE OF THESE NEW
GRANDCHILDREN TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE AND I LOOK
LIKE- JOHNSON FIRST SECOND
THIRD THINK WHAT IT WOULD BE
LIKE TO BE INCARCERATED FOR
SEVEN YEARS A REGULAR BATTERY
RUN A TIGHT SCHEDULE MY- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. PLEASE
I YES. MODERATOR DOWN OUR LAST
FIVE MINUTES SO WE CAN. PUSH
FOLKS ALONG WITH PRESSURE. IT'S
A LINE. FIVE ZERO FIVE. MEMBERS
MY NAME AGAIN. I THOUGHT YEAH I
MEAN LOOK YOU IN COUNTY I AM A
NUMBER ALL. ADVOCATE GROUP
FAMILY AND I ARE PART EIGHTY
NINE NINETY WELL RESTATE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL AS WELL
MAKE IT A RIGHT FOR OUR FAMILY
AND OUR- FAMILY I THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE THIRTY THREE. HI MY
NAME IS DIANA CRUZ I'M AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER WITH
WRITING TRUTH AND AS WITH THEM
IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBERS I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE
NINETY EVERYTHING SHOULD BE A
RIGHT AT LEAST ARE A MAJOR
SPORTS AND REHABILITATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE. BY ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS JOANNA BACH AND I'M
CALLING FROM THE ALLEY AREA AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE NINETY. THANK YOU. IT WILL
TAKE TWO MORE CALLS AND THEN WE
HAVE TO. CUT IT OFF. ABSOLUTELY
NINE THREE SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
FIVE OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU MAY LEARN FROM MONDAY-
MOTHER AND- STARTED LOCAL AND I
AM NINE NINETY. THANK YOULAST
CALL. WELL AS WE GO TO LINE
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JUANITA
MARINO CLAYTON RICHMOND- I'VE
BEEN DENIED ADDITIONAL TEACHING
NINETEEN EIGHTY G. DISPOSITION
ISN'T IN MY LIFETIME AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE
NINETY. YEAH THANK YOU. NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS LISTED COREY SELLS ALOE
SO IF HE'S READY WE CAN HAVE.
HIM BEGIN HIS TESTIMONY NOW.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CORY CELLS ARE LOW ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY NINE
NINETY WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AS IT RELATES TO COUNTY
JAIL VISITATION. SHERIFF'S
UNDERSTAND THE BENEFITS OF
VISITATION FOR INCARCERATED
PERSONS AND THEIR VISITORS BUT
THIS BILL GOES TOO FAR
MANDATING VISITATION AT THE
EXPENSE OF SEVERAL OTHER
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS. BY
LIMITING THE ABILITY TO SUSPEND
VISITATION TO ISSUES RELATED TO
SECURITY JAIL AUTHORITIES WOULD
BE PROHIBITED FROM CONDITIONING
VISITATION TERMS OF VISITATION
ON BEHAVIOR AND DISCIPLINE
CONSIDERATIONS. THIS LANGUAGE
WOULD ALSO PRECLUDE THE
SUSPENSION OF VISITATION THAT
HAS BEEN ADOPTED BY PRISON THE
MOST JAILED BECAUSE OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WHICH
NECESSITATED LIMITING ACCESS TO
AND MOVEMENT WITHIN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES. FOR
THE MEDICAL SAFETY OF INMATES
AND STAFF. CHALLENGES LIKE
OTHER PANDEMICS NATURAL
DISASTERS AND EVEN LOGISTICAL
REALITIES LIKE POWER OUTAGES
AND HVAC BREAKDOWNS. WOULD NOT
SUFFICE AS LEGITIMATE REASONS
TO CANCEL OR POSTPONE
VISITATION UNDER THIS BILL.
ADDITIONALLY SOME JAIL
FACILITIES PROVIDE VISITATION
VIA VIDEO TECHNOLOGY. THIS
PROCESS HAS BEEN PERMITTED
UNDER STATUTE AND REGULATION IN
PLACE AT THE TIME. AND AB NINE
NINETY WERE OSTENSIBLY IMPOSE
MASSIVE MANDATED COSTS. IN
PERSON VISITATION WERE REQUIRED
BY THIS BILL. FOR THESE REASONS
AND AS PREVIOUSLY STATED CSSA
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
NINE NINETY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW WILL COME BACK TO THE
HEARING ROOM IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE NINETY
HERE IN FORTY TWO ALL THREE
SEEING NO ONE WILL GO WILL GO
TO- TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE AS WELL MODERATOR NOW
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES
INTO IF THERE'S ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
NINE NINETY. IT WAS TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE NINETY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE A ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AS WE GO TO LINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
WILL MOVE ON TO NINE FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I
ADDED THE LORD IN ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AGAINST
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT AND I'M
NUMBER FIVE FIFTY EIGHT. I SAID
DURING THAT- IN THE PORT CALLS
SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY
NINE NINETY AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL I AM WE ARE
ALSO A MEMBER- THANK YOU THE
FAMILY UNITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN FROM HER HEAD OR.
HEY HEY. ACTUALLY ONLINE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LONG. THAT
MOVE ONTO. NINE FIFTY FOUR
FOUR. ONE FIVE FIFTY FOUR FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WILL WANT TO LINE FIVE
FORTY FOUR FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. YES GLAD YOU CAN HEAR
YOU. PROVIDE. HELLO MY NAME IS
IT WILL BE SOME WITH ALL OF THE
SENATE SACRAMENTO LEGAL
SERVICES IN PRISON AS A
CHILDREN I'VE BEEN WAITING HERE
FOR A WHILE NOW TO SUPPORT THE
PREVIOUS BILL THE VISION THAT
BILL I IN ALSO THIS BILL I'M
SORRY I HAD TO GET ON THE SIDE
TO MAKE MY VOICE BE HEARD BUT-
LET IT BE NOTED. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER THANKS TO THE TO
LINE FIVE FORTY EIGHT BY. FORTY
EIGHT. THE QUEUE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO TWO CAN'T GET BACK IN
THE QUEUE- FIVE FORTY EIGHT
OKAY BUT- HI THIS IS MARIE
CLOUD BASED ON THE HAVE A
VIBRATE THAT BELLY FAT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE
NINETY. MODERATOR THINK THAT'S
OUR OVERFLOW FROM OUR SUPPORT
DO WE HAVE OPPOSITION. THURSTON
NO FURTHER OPPOSITION THEY
CREATED THE QUEUE- ONLY
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE NOW.
I WOULD LIKE TO GO TO LINE.
FIVE SEVENTY NINE. HELLO. BUT
WE CAN HEAR YOU HI GOOD
AFTERNOON HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
THANK YOU I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR
A LONG TIME BUT THIS IS IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE NINETY-
MY NAME IS ANITA ON THE TELECOM
BALAJI BURKE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. WE'RE
SEEKING OPPOSITION IF THERE'S
NO MORE OPPOSITION OR WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT.
DOLLARS GETTING LATE. SENATOR
SKINNER THANK YOU- HE SAID
DENYING VISITATION IS NOT AN
APPROPRIATE PUNISHMENT GIVEN
THE BENEFITS WE KNOW. THAT
VISITATION PROVIDES SO I MOVE
THE BILL AND I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING IT. AND YOU KNOW
IF THERE'S POWER OUTAGES HAVE
PRISON OR JAIL- PRETTY MUCH
THING STILL FUNCTION SO I
APPRECIATE WHY SHERIFF'S MAY
HAVE SOME PROBLEMS WITH THE
PROVISIONS HOWEVER I THINK THE
EXAMPLE THAT WAS GIVEN WAS- A
LITTLE BIT. WHAT ABOUT WHATEVER
SO ANYWAY- IMPORTANT BILL AND-
I MOVE IT. THANK YOU. IT'S BEEN
PROPERLY MOVED ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS HERE BYE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SENIOR NINE SIMMONS
SANTIAGO TALKED CLOSE YET THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT STRUCTURE THIS LATE
HOUR AND I WANT TO SAY WE'RE
NOT SAYING THIS BILL THAT YOU
ARE BE ARE YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
VISITATION I WANT THIS BILL
THAT COULD BE DISPOSED OF IN
THE COMMITTEES IF THERE'S AN
EARTHQUAKE NATURAL DISASTER. OR
THINGS FELL APART WERE SAYING
YOU CAN'T DENY UNDER UNDER
SECTIONS OF- EIGHT SIXTY FOUR
ONE IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY OF
TOP MY HEAD IN THE LIST OF
REASONS WHY YOU CANNOT DENY IT
DOES IT DOES NOT SAY
EARTHQUAKES. IN ACTS OF GOD
NEED TO RICK SANTORUM SILVA I
WANT TO DISPEL THAT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT HERE- BUT
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO CLEAR
THAT UP- AS WE CONTINUE THIS
JOURNEY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE JUST FEEL FUNDAMENTALLY AN
ACTUAL PLAN A MILLION EVERYBODY
SATISFIED THAT THIS IS THE
VISION OF THE HUMAN RIGHT AND
IT'S IT AND IT'S WHAT CONNECTS
SOMEBODY THE OUTSIDE THIS IS
PART OF THE REHABILITATIVE
PROCESS AND IT'S FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE VERY CRUEL TO NOT
ALLOW SOMEBODY TO VISIT LOVED
ONES. NOT TO MENTION WHAT IT
DOES TO FAMILIES ON THE OUTSIDE
NOT TO MENTION WHAT IT DOES TO
THE TO SMALL CHILDREN WHO NEED
TO BE CONNECTED TO THEIR
PARENTS OR LOVED ONES AND FOR
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE. THANK YOU AND I JUST WITH
THAT THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE IF WE REALLY BELIEVE IN
REHABILITATION SECOND. CHANCES
IT REQUIRES. DIRECTOR COM.
INTERACTION WITH FAN LOVE ONE
FOR AN AND- YES- BUT IT SHOULD
BE SOME HUMANITY AND BEING-
INCARCERATED IN THIS PART OF
THAT AMENITY IN KEEPING
FAMILIES TOGETHER SO. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
WE HAVE A TO PASS TO A PORT
REPORT CREATIONS- COUNCIL WE
CALL THE ROLL ON AB NINE NINETY
AB NINE NINETY BRADFORD ROAD
FOR DIET CHAU BOKE NOT PHONING
JAVA NOT VOTING DORADO. DRAWS I
COM LONGER HANG FOR MURDER AYE
SKINNER HI SKINNER- FOR
MEASURES OUT FOR THE ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS YOU SANTIAGO WE
THANK ALL OF OUR WITNESSES BACK
THERE WHO BEEN PATIENT ALL DAY
LONG I MEAN BEEN HERE ALL DAY
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY NOW WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK THE CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE. SIX ITEMS ON
CONSENT I'M A CORRECT. A MAN
GET COUNCIL PLAY. PLEASE PUT
ALL OF ROLE I MEAN PUT THE CALL
ON THE CONCERT COUNTY. ALTHOUGH
I CENTER HI SKINNER I FIVE ZERO
TWO SIX KILOMETERS OUT FIVE
ZERO NOW WE'LL START WITH OUR
FIRST MEASURE AB THREE BY SOME
WOMEN FONG WILL LOOK TO CALL.
RIGHT EUROPE GERMANY I DON'T
KNOW I. FOR MYSELF. ALL RIGHT
I'LL GO BACK AGAIN SO THE
VOTERS THREE TO ZERO CHAIRS
VOTING AYE DORADO DRAWS OUR
EYES SKINNER BY DINNER AT THE
THAT'S FIVE ZERO IMAGES OUT
FIVE ZERO NOW WILL GO OUT FILE
ITEM TWO A. B. EIGHTY NINE. AB
EIGHTY NINE JONES SAWYER TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS
THREE TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D RAZA. DRIVES AWAY
SKINNER. BY DINNER AT FIVE FIVE
ZERO IMAGES OUT FIVE ZERO NOW
MOVING ON TO AB TWO TO THREE BY
WARD. BUT STILL PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. TO ZERO THE
CHAIRS VOTING II DURAZO DRESS
SO I CALM WATER VOTING CAMARGO
NOT VOTING SKINNER AYE SKINNER
AT A BORDER ZERO. HE NOW MOVING
ON TO AB TWO TWO NINE BY SOME
WOMEN HOLDEN- MAYBE TWO TWO
NINE THE VOTERS FORTY ZERO
TERRAZZO. DRAZEN HI FIVE TWO
ZERO THAT MEASURES OUT FIVE
ZERO. I'M MOVING ON TO A. B.
TWO EIGHT TWO BY CINNAMON
LACKEY. AB TWO EIGHT TO THE
VOTE IS ONE TO TWO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING NO DORADO. DRAWS
ARE NO THE VOTE IS ONE TWO
THREE. AND HE ASKED FOR
RECONSIDERATION P. AND
RECONSIDERATION WILL BE GRANTED.
AB FOUR NINETY GIPSON THE
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE
IS ONE TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D A CHOI BOGUE. NEWS
TROUBLE NOW DROWNED SO. I'M
SORRY COULD YOU TELL ME WHICH
ONE AGAIN ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
FOUR NINETY GIPSON HI DURAZO
I'D CALM LONGER FROM MUGGER I'D
VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE. MEASURES
OUT FOR THE ONE. THANKS BABE
MORE DOWNTURN ITEM TWELVE AB
SEVEN SIXTY FOUR- IT'S THREE
TWO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
HI AND IT'S TO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS A CHOI BOGUE.
YES YES FOR TWELVE SUPPORT OF I
AM NOT A TURBO GUIDE TERRAZZO
HI RATHER I. FIVE ZERO. THE
FIRM AB NINE THIRTY NINE
CERVANTES IT'S DO PASS AND IT'S
THREE TO ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE
AYE CHAU BOGUE THIRTEEN RIGHT
YES. THANKS BYE BYE OKAY SORRY-
JOB AYE DORADO I DRESS OKAY.
THIS ITEM FOURTEEN WAS PULLED
FROM ITEM FIFTEEN AB NINE
THIRTY SEVEN- IT'S TWO TO ONE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
DURAZO AYE DRUGS AYE AYE-
SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER I FOUR TO
ONE THE MEASURES- FOUR ONE. AB
ELEVEN OH FOUR GRAYSON FORTY
ZERO DORADO HI BROWSER I. ZERO
FIVE FIVE ZERO. AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE GARCIA DO PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS IT'S
FOUR TWO ZERO TORONTO I PRESENT
I FIVE TWO ZERO ZERO MEASURES
OUT. AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
MCCARTY THE PASTOR PERFORATIONS
THAT THREE TO ZERO CHAIR VOTING
I'D DORADO THROWS AWAY SKINNER
HI SKINNER AT A FIVE ZERO ZERO
FIVE ZERO OR LESS OFTEN. AND SO
ON AB ARE WE'VE GOT TO GET TO
MEET THE POLICE BUT AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN- THE MOTION WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS SO WE
NEED TO JUST WHEN YOU SAID IT
SAY IT'S OUT CLARIFIED THAT
IT'S AS AMENDED. SO AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WE JUST NEED
TO CORRECT THEM OUR MOTION AND
IT'S FORTY ZERO TORONTO HI OKAY
THAT'S FIVE ZERO IMAGES OUT AND
ALLOWS HIM TO VOTE ONLY ON WELL
YES AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE BIGELOW
THE VOTE IS- TWO TO ZERO DURAZO
HI. RATHER AYE COMMAGER. CHECK
NOT SKINNER. SKINNER THE VOTERS
ZERO. ZERO FOUR ZERO MEMBERS
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR
THIS EVENING. I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL AND TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
A PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE UNABLE. TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE. PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
FISH- HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION IN THIS.
HEARING TODAY I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE OF YOU. FOR YOUR
PATIENCE YOUR COOPERATION I
KNOW WAS A LONG AFTERNOON. WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE GENDER OF
THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WE STAND ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU EVERY.